foreign
Microsoft Excel is the simplest yet an
important skill required by it employees
Excel improves the data management
effectively and escalates the
productivity exponentially the simple
spreadsheet software is now an integral
part of most business organizations
across the world msxl is used for
various needs and requirements of
business organizations in fact a few use
Excel for tracking sales Trends and
generate valuable insights from the
business data the simple interface helps
users to easily understand the software
and perform basic activities in the
Excel file cost we will be learning the
topics from the advanced Excel section
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt the latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our Channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from simplyground one of the major
advantages of Ms Excel is its
flexibility feature this feature allows
users to define the structure of
information they need to manage with
ease Excel is so simple to use that even
a completely new user can manage to
implement a few functionalities in Excel
for complicated tasks the user needs to
undergo training and gain hands-on
experience to use it in a better manner
even after 3 decades Ms Excel is still
the most preferred and used spreadsheet
software around the world access updated
features help users to connect to a
variety of data sources and import data
the data collected can be cleansed
modified and fat using Advanced Excel
features the fine-tune data can be run
through formulas and necessary insights
of the data can be extracted not just
this users can also visualize the data
reports making Excel one of the most
powerful business intelligence tools the
Visual Basic support from Excel will
allow users to customize and generate
interactive business reports and
dashboards anyhow the top uses of Ms
Excel are as follows Ms Excel is
commonly used for financial related
activities the reason for its popularity
is that the user can Define custom
formulas and calculate quarterly half
yearly and annual reports for the sales
and marketing Community Excel helps to
effectively keep track of the sales
leads project status reports
professionals from data science
background as it allows them to easily
work with statistical formulas and
graphing the finance department makes
use of Ms Excel for payroll expenses tax
calculations leave reports timesheets
and employee performance in analysis
another important use of Ms Excel for
any industry is forecasting this helps
organizations in Revenue projections
cost projections and manage their supply
chain effectively now let us go through
the salaries of data oriented jobs that
require Ms Excel the average salaries of
data oriented jobs with excellent
requirements is anywhere between 5 lakhs
per annum to 10 lakhs per annum based on
experience and job roles and
responsibilities having the introduction
and applications of excel discussed now
we will go through the agenda for
today's session we will start up by
discussing Excel basic knowledge where
we will go through the fundamentals of
excel followed by that we will start
with learning how to log or protect
cells in Excel followed by that we will
learn the print plate setup in Excel
next we have goal seeking Excel charts
in Excel and then we will go through
data validation in Excel followed by
that we will go through the lookup from
functions so there are basically three
types of lookup functions which are
vlookup Edge lookup and X lookup
followed by that we will learn slicers
in Excel followed by that we will go
through Excel budget template then we
will understand what exactly is Mis
report in Excel then we will dive into
Excel macros and visual basics for
beginners then we will learn regression
in Excel followed by that we will go
through Excel power query then the
perfect tables in Excel and finally to
make things interesting we will go
through the most frequently Asked Excel
based interview questions and answers so
I hope I made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with the
advanced Excel tutorial
what as Microsoft Excel so Microsoft
Excel is a software product designed and
developed by Microsoft store in data in
an organized way that is rows and
columns
and Microsoft Excel is also capable to
manipulate data through some
mathematical operations
followed by that Microsoft Excel is also
used to extract the insights from the
data and represent it in the form of
visually appealing graphs and charts now
we have a basic understanding or an
overview of what a Microsoft Excel
software product is
now moving ahead we will understand the
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
so following are some fundamentals that
you need to know before getting started
with Microsoft Excel so basically when
you install the Microsoft Office in your
computer you will have various Microsoft
products out of which Microsoft Excel is
one of the product so we will be dealing
exactly with that particular product
that is Microsoft Excel so when you get
started with Microsoft Excel this is
what you will see in the first page
so this particular page is called as
Microsoft Excel home page where you will
be having various varieties of sheets
Microsoft Excel will give you some
suggestions based on the type of sheet
you want to work with we will see this
in a better way through the Practical
session so once you get started with the
sheet you will have some more options so
this particular option is called as the
toolbar menu you will have the file home
insert raw paste layout formulas data
review View and help so these are the
tools that you will be using to work on
your data using Microsoft Excel
furthermore we have a toolbar ribbon so
when you select sum or the other option
from the file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review View and
help buttons you will have a ribbon so
for example you can see that I have
selected the Home Tool here so when I
press on the Home Tool this is the
ribbon which Microsoft Excel gives me so
this ribbon has some options in it which
can perform various operations now in a
further more detailed way we will have
toolbar groups so when you see in the
previous slide we have a complete
toolbar ribbon so this particular ribbon
is segmented into groups so you can see
the first group as paste Cut Copy format
painter etc etc and the second group is
the font the size of the font and to
increase the size of the font to
decrease the size of the phone bold
italic underline etc etc and here you
can see the text alignment so each and
every group has separate functions
so each set is called as a group
and I think you can see a small Arrow
option over here so this Arrow option is
used into the toolbar groups when the
group is not able to fit all the
operations or all the functionalities in
one single provided section so when you
click on this particular Arrow Mark you
will have another dialog box so this is
called toolbar more options so you can
see that when I clicked on this icon you
can see a new dialog box which opens me
a new set of operations which are not
able to be fit in this particular group
so we will also see more about this in a
better way in the Practical session now
moving forward we have cell and address
so when you open a Microsoft Excel sheet
you can find boxes so each and every box
is named as a cell and each cell has its
own address for example the highlighted
cell over here has an address B3 so B is
the column name and three is the rule
name
and apart from that you can have the
sheet tracker in the bottom left corner
of the Excel sheet where you can
navigate through different sheets
and in the bottom right corner you have
an option of increasing or decreasing
the sheet size so these are the basic
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel that you
need to keep in mind before getting
started so we will have more on this in
the Practical session if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so now we enter the demo inventory in
Microsoft Excel so we will be using
Microsoft Excel to create a sheet of the
employees in a company
so basically an employee in a company
has employee ID name and designation
salary etc etc so we will be trying to
create the same table using Microsoft
Excel but before that let us understand
the fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
through the Practical demo first so I
have started my Microsoft Excel and this
is how the home page of Microsoft Excel
looks like so you have a blank workbook
over here if you want to create a new
workbook you can select new Option so
Excel will provide you with various
variety of sheets you can see money in
Excel adjustable meeting agenda
streaming show list small business cash
flow and many more if you're not able to
find what you're looking for then you
always have an option of selecting the
particular type of sheet what you're
looking for so you have various options
if it's business if it's personal if
it's planners and trackers list budgets
charts etc etc so let's imagine that you
wanted something from business so just
by clicking at business option the Excel
will load a variety of sheets related to
business options so this might take a
while so you can see that the Excel is
loading few types of sheets
so you can see that Excel has provided
us with some online varieties of sheets
for example any calendar business
expenses Channel marketing budget budget
summary report blue product list etc etc
you can see construction proposal
invoice your name and Excel has got it
so Excel will provide you with some
variety of options based on your
requirement now for this session let's
get started with a blank workbook which
looks something like this since this
tutorial is based on the fundamentals
we'll go with the blank workbook
now over here you can see the toolbar
that we discussed earlier that has the
file home insert draw paste layout
formulas data review View and help so
this is the toolbar and under the
toolbar I have selected home and you can
see this is the particular ribbon what
we discussed about this particular
ribbon belongs to home page and when you
select file option you'll get back to
home and if you select insert option
you'll have another different ribbon
with different groups etc etc so every
particular tool has different ribbons in
them and remember the extra options that
we discussed when you press over this
Arrow key this is it so when you press
the arrow key you'll have few more
settings which cannot be fit in this
particular section of groups so you can
have some variety of options over here
of changing the font changing some FX to
the text font size and font style etc
etc apart from this we discussed about
the cells in every sheet so this
particular cell has an address so you
can see the address over here which is
B3 so B happens to be the column name
and three happens to be the row name now
we also had a discussion about the sheet
tracker right now we just have one sheet
if you want multiple sheets you can just
feel free to select on the plus option
which will always create you some extra
sheets and you can navigate through
sheet name
and when you get back to the bottom
right corner you have an option of
increasing and decreasing the cell size
or the sheet size now let's keep it
default with hundred percent
now these are the few fundamentals that
you need to keep in mind before getting
started with Microsoft Excel now that we
know the fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
let's get started with a practical
session which is about the employees
details in a company
now let's select this particular cell
let's type in employee details
yeah we have the cell
now an employee details table will have
the information related to employees so
the information will be about name
it will be about employee number
it will be the designation
and maybe salary
and maybe blood group as well
and let's take another one which is
phone number
here
so so far so good
and you can see that we with this
particular column the designation and
the name uh the name of the designation
is practically good but it is not
visible so when you uh when you're not
on that particular cell you can see that
the name is incomplete over here so you
can always fix that you can just you
know manually change the size of the row
or cell or you can also feel free to you
know double click on that cell which
will automatically you know set the size
of that particular cell and same goes to
the blood group just let's try to double
click on that and same goes to phone
number
great
so you can see that the employees
details are just confined to the first
two cells it's supposed to be somewhere
in the middle right so no problem we can
do that as well we can select all the
cells and we have an option of merging
them
you can just select this one which will
help you with merging and centering that
particular data to the center part
so that's how we do it
now let's get started by adding the
names of the employees
let's add the names Joe
John
uh Mary mark
Susan
and then
Jennifer
let's open mic
let's open them
chef
Jeffrey
yeah we have a couple of employees now
let's type in the employee numbers
foreign
yeah we have the employee numbers now
let's type in the designation okay let's
choose uh Joe to be the CEO of the
company
and John as the software developer
and Mary as tester
Mark and finance
Susan also in finance
and Jennifer in testing
and Mike in marketing
same goes for yeah
and again Jeffrey into software
development
and uh
Morgan into testing again
now let's click on a c so that it gets
you know resized according to the length
of the text
now it's done so let's get into salary
uh ten thousand dollars
and fifteen thousand dollars
and
nineteen thousand dollars let's increase
the salary of a CEO so let's keep it one
lakh dollars
and finance again twenty thousand
so yeah the salaries are allocated again
the blood group
here we have the blood groups now let's
type in the mobile numbers
foreign
[Music]
yeah now we have typed in some random
mobile numbers as well
so uh yeah this is how you can add in
some data into your table
and now let us imagine that you forgot
to add or remove a column so let's
imagine that we wanted to add a serial
number as well but somehow we forgot to
add it now you can always add a new row
or column for example here we wanted to
add a new column so we just have to
right click on a select the insert
option
here we have a new row now
let's type in serial number
and let's type one
now can you see the small box option
over here if you just drag it you can
you know copy paste all those over here
and now let's right click
and
fill series now we have the employee
number starting from 1 to 10.
that's how you do it and apart from this
you can also uh you know change the font
of the entire row you can change the
font to
say
aroni and you can always also change the
font
and same goes to the employee table we
can select it bold it and you can also
increase the size and again select the
color for the text maybe a different
color green would be better
and you can also select the entire cells
and align them to the center
looks more good
and you can select or double click the
row names so we'll have the proper
spacing between all the rows and columns
so we have double click on the column
right yeah so basically that's how you
make things happen now let's save this
so I'd like to go to the save option and
amp data
let me save this in my local location
and just save it's done
so that's how you work on your Excel
file with some basic data
and to learn more don't forget to get
subscribed to Simply learns YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to stay updated so you are the
first person to get an update on any
technology not just Excel now we are on
the Microsoft Excel and this particular
spreadsheet is related to employee
details
yeah now the screen is visible a bit
better now let us imagine that this is
our confidential data and you want to
edit only two columns that is the
designation column and phone number
column now let us imagine that the
company has finished one annual year and
now there are some promotions happening
in the company and let us also imagine
that the phone numbers of the employees
provided by the company have undergone
some changes so now the minor edits that
you want to make are related to the
designation column and phone number
column now you can see that all the
columns that is the blood group new
salary salary hike current serial number
employee number everything is editable
so in such kind of scenarios when you
pass on this data there might be a
possibility where your colleague or
subordinate might end up making some
mistakes right so you want to avoid that
so you can do that by locking the cells
now let us rename this sheet foreign
successfully so now you can lock the
cells by the following process
so in this process you have two major
steps first one is to lock the cells and
the next one is to protect the cells by
a password now when you select all the
cells in this particular sheet you can
just click on this edge here and you
have all the cells selected and now
right click somewhere on the sheet and
you can see an option called format
cells
so in this particular option you have
some options provided which is number
alignment font and you want to go into
the protection part so you can see by
default Excel keeps all the cells locked
now we want the phone number and
designation to be unlocked okay so let's
cancel it for now and get back to the
sheet and select the columns D and I
and now let's right click and go into
format cells and in the protection
option make sure that you uncheck the
locked icon now select OK and now
okay so you cannot include the merge to
self find we have a cell here which is
merged okay let's remove that
okay now again select the entire column
right click get into format cells and
uncheck the log option select ok
now we have finished the first part that
is locking all the cells which you don't
want to get added and unlocking the
cells where you want to make some edits
now the second stage is protecting the
sheet now right click on the sheet name
and you can see an option called protect
sheet click that and now here you can
see select love cells and also select
envelope cells so let us provide a
password here so let us use some simple
password so that we don't forget that so
I'll be selecting one two three and now
select ok
re-enter the password to proceed now let
us type 1 2 3 again now select OK and
now the sheet is protected
now we have successfully logged and
protected Excel now let us verify that
the cells you wanted to protect are
really protected and locked or not so we
have unlocked phone number and
designation and everything else now let
me try and edit the blood group so when
I double click or try to edit this
particular sheet then I'll be receiving
a warning from Excel it says the cell or
chart you're trying to change is on a
protected sheet to make a change
unprotect the sheet you might be
requested to enter a password
so it says that this particular cell is
locked and you cannot edit it now let us
try to edit the phone numbers which we
kept as unblocked
so you can see I can really edit the
unlocked cell here now let me try to
change this phone number let me enter
some random phone number
so you can see the cell is editable now
let us go through the designation column
and try to edit this particular column
now since I said that there's a
promotion happening in the company so
the deputy CEO is now the current CEO of
the company
and software developer happens to become
the cemia software developer and the
tester as well let us imagine that he
will become the senior
and so on
okay so this proves that this particular
sheet is editable not the entire sheet
but only the sense that we kept in the
analog mode
okay
foreign
setup in Ms Excel
so to understand the pitch setup in Ms
Excel we will go through a demo
inventory in Excel where we'll be
considering some restaurant data
now without any delay let's get started
with a practical demo
now whatever we have the First Column
that is
and next we have the restaurant name
followed by that we have the sales
happening through that restaurant and
then we have the segment category that
is what kind of service does that
particular restaurant offers now this is
the list what we made and what if we
wanted to represent this data and form
of a printed paper right so I guess you
can see all the columns and rows here so
you can see that we have almost like 250
rows so there is no chance or there is
no way to print all those 250 rows in
one page of course it is practically
possible but when you try to read the
content it'll be so tough to read
Because all the rows will be clapped
together so closely so that you cannot
read it so you need to print them Page
by page so and you need to also take
care of the data is aligned properly
according to the page size everything
any of our data and what actually we are
trying to make now let us see how page
setup is possible in Ms Excel so to go
to the page setup menu or go to the page
setup or go to print option
you can also go to print menu by
pressing a shortcut method that is Ctrl
p
so you'll directly end up on the page
setup options now let's look at the
second method so the second method is
you can see the toolbar over here right
which has file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review web page
layout option from the toolbar
when you click on the page option from
the toolbar you have on this ribbon is
all about page setup options so it will
offer you margins it will offer you
orientation size print area breaks
background print tiles etc etc right so
all these options are menus in this
ribbon belong to page setup now let us
look at the third method so the third
method is something similar you have
view option on the toolbar so just
select a view and you can see we have
few page setup options over here as well
the normal page break page layout custom
views and we have gridlines formula bar
heading zoom in zoom out
the page setup options so we have the
three methods on page setup for that let
me use the simplest method that is
holding the control key and pressing P
which navigates me to the print option
now we have various set of options here
we have no scaling normal margins letter
portrait orientation as a printers
option for example if you are connected
to a printer which is the hardware
printer then your Ms Excel will show the
printer's name here so other than
printer you can also make some other
arrangements where you can just directly
print your complete data in the form of
PDF and then you can export your PDF to
your recipient that's also possible okay
over here
so let us kind of select all the items
and create a new sheet and try to paste
it over here
or let's try to paste it over here
okay now let's try to extend these
this should be fine now let's rename
this sheet
sheet uh
or let's rename it as
let's try to
for our reference now let us get back to
the print sheet option so I'll use the
shortest method that is holding the Ctrl
key and press P now you can see that
here we have six pages in total from the
active sheets so the active sheet is the
top 250 sheet so this particular sheet
is the current active sheet so if we
print the entire data in this particular
sheet then we will end up printing six
pages now let's select the other options
12 pages so what is a workbook so
basically workbook is the collection of
entire sheets in your Excel home page so
in this particular Excel homepage you
have 250 and the second sheet that is
the restaurant sheet 2 right so the
combination of these two sheets make up
a workbook
so when you select the entire workbook
option you'll have 12 pages so that's
how we use this setting where you select
the active sheets the entire workbook
and there is another option where you
can only print a selected if you want to
do this then let's get back here now
what if your customer or what if your
client wanted the top 10 restaurants
only so you can select the top 10
restaurants
by
doing this
now you have the top 10 restaurants
let's go to print
so you can see Excel has automatically
selected the selection only print the
selected content only so you can see we
have only the top 10 only the top 10
restaurants or top 11 restaurants that
we have selected in our sheet and it is
ready to get printed so this is how we
use the first option now let's get back
let's not select that and let's make the
pages normal now get back to the print
option again now you can see the next
option that is the latest one two three
one two three and one two three and the
next one which is uncalated one one one
two two two three three three so why are
these numbers present here and what does
collected mean anyway so this is your
question right now the answer for this
question will be a little similar to
your examination Hall okay let us
imagine that you are an examination Hall
and you are the invisilator and you have
10 students in your room
so you wanted to provide question papers
to all the 10 students okay so you have
your question paper distributed into
three sheets that is you have marked
questions and your questions are fit
into three papers right in this scenario
we have 250 rows and all the data is
split into six sheets that is sheet 1 or
page 1 Phase 2 page 3 page four right
now if we wanted to print 10 copies then
the arrangement of papers will be page 1
page two page five page six in
continuous order right that is collated
if you wanted 10 copies of different
different ways where you wanted to print
first sheet first then you wanted to
print the second sheet second and the
third sheet third that is you'll have 10
copies of first page 10 copies of second
page 10 copies of third page and so on
that particular approach is called
uncollated approach and if you printing
the pages in continuous order for 10
times then that particular approach is
called as correlated approach so this is
what we had to learn about collated and
uncolluted now let's get back to the
third option
now let's press again print now we have
our data over here
there is something wrong
elements control P yeah now we have a
data pack now we have the third option
that is the portrait orientation okay so
when we click that we have two options
that is portrait and landscape so you
might be having a good idea like when
you try to click a picture in your phone
we have two modes as well that is
portrait mode and the landscape mode so
when you click on the portrait mode this
is how your data will be looking now to
understand the difference let's click
the landscape mode so when you click the
landscape mode this is how your data
representation will change you'll have a
wider page to print so this is why we
use the page orientation for now let's
keep the page orientation as portrait
orientation
and we have now the fourth option so
what is the fourth option we have
various sets of options in here that is
letter and A4 size there are also some
more page options over here where you
can select the page types you want to
print
so basically you'll be having few more
options that is afo A5 A3 Etc but here
we just have two that is A4 and letter
so basically you will get those options
and followed by that next we have
margins so here you can see we don't
have any margins for our data okay so
now we can add some margins by setting
up this one as an option like last
custom setting or you can also choose
normal wide narrow right so your page
will be changed according to your margin
size
right so this is how you can change the
margins now let's keep it as default
let's set the
normal one
now we have the next option that is
scaling option
so here you can see we are trying to fit
the page so when you're trying to print
the sheets using no scaling then the
actual size of the page will be printed
now you can also modify that you can fit
and print these sizes so remember the
first option that I said of printing all
the 250 rows in one single sheet this is
how you can fit it so fit the sheet on
one page where you can see all the 250
rows are fit into one page but the data
is not readable so but we don't want
this type of an approach right so let's
keep it as the default one which is no
scaling so these are the variety of
options in print
now if you wanted to print the all six
pages into the PDF format and mail it to
your client you can also do that I think
I have explained it in the first place
so you can see we can do it by just
selecting this option where you can
print all the six pages and into PDF
format and then you can mail them to
your client
and you can also select the number of
copies you want you can increase the
copies to two three and any number of
copies you want for now I'll keep it as
one copy
[Music]
now let's print this
now let us select the
location
rename it and publish
now let's get back to documents and see
if the page is presented or not
here you go here we have the restaurant
data in the form of PDF
so we have our entire pages of data in
the PDF format
now we are back on the home page now we
have some limited functions in the print
functions over here
we have tried to export the data so you
can also export the data or try to print
it from the print option over here you
can just select the address
I need it
here
yes the pages are printed now
there you go we have the restaurant 2
PDF data
so that's how you can print all your
data you can either choose
the export option or you can either
choose print option now you see into the
print option we have limited number of
page setup options over here now let's
check out we missed so we are in the
page layout here so we had gone through
the margins we have set all the margins
and then we have also gone through the
portrait and unscape now you can see
this size when we were in the print menu
option we had only A4 and letter but
here you can see there are a wide
variety of options that is other than
later we have tabloid legal statement
executive A3 right we have A5 and many
more other options and if you want some
more paper options you can go to more
and you can always select few more
options that's how you do it and yeah we
didn't had the break option so remember
when we had been through the print
option we did not have the break option
there
that's just a normal A4 so you cannot
see the break option over here right so
here we have the brick option so what
does break option does right you can
actually break the page remember we
spoke top 10 things or the top 10 rows
you can always do that so you can just
keep the top 10 restaurants in your
first page and then break the remaining
and the second page you can select the
cell now I need to obtain so I'll select
this particular cell which is in the
11th position
and now I'll try to implement the page
trick insert a page trick and now you
can see on my sheet there is a thin line
which is separating the two pages that's
how you can see the indication of app
page break implemented onto your page
now how do you see it you can see it by
selecting Ctrl P where you can see first
top 10 restaurants being printed on your
sheet so there you go we have the first
top 10 restaurants printed on our sheets
so that's how you use the page break
now let's try to eliminate those tricks
so you can select breaks and reset all
page tricks so the page break has been
eliminated
now you can always choose a background
for your data as well you just if you
want you can add a picture to your
background I think that's not
available for now
okay you can work offline as well
let us select this one
so you can see that we have added a
background to our data
we can select all the
files and then you can change the color
so that the text becomes a little
visible
yeah that's how you do it if you don't
want the image to be added on your file
you can also remove that delete page
background and there you go all the
images are gone
now the next important part that is the
print titles
now why do we need print titles for that
let's try to print this
so now you can see the first page in the
first page we have the title rank
restaurant sales segment category but if
you go to the second page you don't have
that title right if you don't have the
title rank name of the restaurant sales
and their service category so if we want
that then we need to add titles
now for that let's select the print
titles option now let's select the rows
to repeat on top
now for that we need the first row
select the first row and this particular
row will be repeating into all the pages
now let's try to print it
so yeah now you can see the titles are
added to all the sheets you can see the
page 2 page 3 page 4 page 5 and page six
so you can see the titles are added to
all the sheets
so that's our USD print titles option so
now we are on the Excel sheet and you
can see that in this particular Excel
sheet we have some student details we
have the serial numbers names role
numbers class blood group and some
subjects like maths science statistics
social GK and the final marks obtained
percentage and total marks right
so let us imagine that a company has
come for an interview so all these are
going to attend an interview and the
minimum percentage to attend the
interview will be like 75 percent so you
can see that we have 75 here and all the
students have got above 75 except for
the one student who watches Mike right
so for Mike during the interview he
needs 75 percentage or above so uh he
can make some modifications in one of
these subjects right so there is always
an exam after the exam called as
Improvement exam so if you can like this
course and next from other subjects
which you have scored less so that you
can make up to the percentage what
you're expecting you can do that so here
in this particular sheet uh Mike has six
subjects right and in six subjects you
can see he has code 76 91 45 71 94 and
62. so out of these he have scored less
and one subject compared to all the
subjects one subject is low that is
computers so what if he can give an
improvement exam and increase his
percentage to 75 right so that can be
done so if we can do some Brute Force
methods like we can change the marks
like 55 and then check this particular
one so it's getting 74 right so using
the brute force method will be a little
bit lengthy so you can do this because
it is just a small table which has least
number of data and you just have one
single cell to modify so that can be
done in small tables but we had some
table with hundreds of rows or thousands
of rows that will be time consuming
right so for that we have some inbuilt
functionality in Excel that is called
goal seek in Excel so for now let's
eliminate the marks here
so we have eliminated the marks and the
upgraded percentage is 65. now we need
the target as 75. okay so let's write it
as
Mike's Target right you need mic so mics
new Target as
[Music]
okay now to make sure that we need a
Mark here which can get mic to 75
percentage we will use the data
operation
so here on the tool are the file home
insert Etc we have one other option
called as data so when you click on data
from toolbar you'll have this ribbon and
in this ribbon we have various options
so when you come into forecast group we
have an option called vertices when you
click on what-if analysis you will have
a set of options out of which we have
goal seek
now for goal seek we need to select a
table cell that is this particular table
cell that is M9 so we need the value 7 5
here right so what is that cell that you
need to change here for that you need to
select this one and select this
particular cell here right and now you
can select ok now you can see that Excel
has automatically run all the
permutations and combinations and has
come up with a number
so that the overall percentage of mic
will be 70 percent right so the expected
marks that Mike should be getting in his
computer's Improvement exam should be
equal to 56 or greater than 56 to the
final Target as 75 so that he can attend
the company's interview so this is how
we use goal set or goals Excel now let's
quickly get on to the Practical mode
where we will have some data sets over
which we will be trying to apply the
charts now there are various types of
charts in Tableau and there are the pie
chart the column chart the bar chart
column versus line pivot and sparkline
charts so we will discuss one after the
other first let us discuss about the pie
chart
so as you can see we have a small data
set on my screen which I have personally
created and this deals with the
companies and this deals with the shares
of the automobile industry so now for
this let's create a pie chart
select our data and then get into the
Tuple bar and inside the toolbar you can
see various options and inside that
we're gonna use the insert option and
when you select the insert option you
will have a ripple here and inside the
ribbon you can see groups tables
illustrations add-ins and here you go
these are the charts so now we needed a
pie chart so select on that icon and you
have various types of pie charts you
have two dimensional pie charts three
dimension charts donor type of charts
Etc right so I would like to go with the
three dimensional chart as it looks a
little more appealing and easy to
understand and now there you go this is
the title of the chart and these are the
legends of the chart and this is the
chart area
and these are the values now we can uh
you know kind of add the data labels as
well so you can just have to press the
plus icon over here and you will have
the options you can add the data labels
which will give you a lot more
interesting values
and you can also turn around
as you can see we on double clicking any
part of the pie chart you'll get this
option which is called as
format data point and let's assume that
you want to show automation related to
this particular one which is a Volvo
which has the biggest share so this is
in front right now now what if you
wanted to show the information related
to Tata which is over here right for
that you can select this particular
Arrow key and you can just twist it and
there you go it is coming in front this
will be a great way of presenting your
data to your clients right
yeah and there is another option where
you can directly explore this like you
can pick it out you can say this right
Point explosion where you can split it
out and you can show that especially
like you can highlight it and show it so
that's the you know a great presenting
your data so that's how you can work
with pixel now let's quickly move to the
next one that is the column chart
and in the column chart we have the data
related to some company and the profits
of that company based on air so you can
see that the year has started from 2008
and it has gone until 2021 and these are
the profits of that company year after
year so since we are dealing with column
chart I'll tell you the simplest way to
create a column chat that is a shortcut
key
which is alt F1 and there you go you
have the chart right on your screen
now you can expand the chart just by
dragging it like that and
you can see that there is some problem
with this chat that is we have numbers
here instead of years right you can see
that the First Column is the years which
is 2008 to 2021 but here you can see we
have one two three four which is not
proper right
so to change the
access that as you can see the axis
which is one two three four from one two
three four to the ears 2008 2009 2010 11
Etc you just have to make one change
here and also you can see I have pressed
the plus icon over here which will open
the option where you can include the
access titles if you have and data
labels everything right so for now I
think I'll keep it as it is so you can
include the data table as well as it is
here and you can include that in the
chart there are various options that
Excel provides you
so now let's focus on changing the axis
from one two three four to the ear for
that you select the chart design and
inside the chart design you have an
option called select data press that and
here you have vary set of options you
can see profits you can see EOS now I
will select years and we will remove
that and now you can see the editing
here right select that and now it will
ask you which card to visit for the
access range for that let's select this
and now let's select the years here
um
press OK and there you go again press ok
so there you go you have the ears over
here instead of the numbers which you
had in the first place so that's how you
create the column chart and we have the
next type of chart which is really
simple
now you know you kind of change that
directly bar chart there is no big deal
in that
so uh for that you just need to select
the change chart type over here you're
just changing the chart type and you can
get the paragraph over here column and
bar graphs are completely same to each
other only that you can see these uh
bars in the horizontal way rather than
in the vertical way and let's do that
let's not create a new thing for that
so uh yeah there you go when you select
the change chart type option you have V
set of chart type options on the menu
bar over here so what we needed was the
bar chart now let's select that and
there you go
let's select OK and you have the power
chart
okay and if you want you can include the
data labels which look a little bit more
interesting you can also include the
data table as well
okay for now I think we have expanded
chart to get the Clear View
yeah that's how you do it
right now let's move into the next type
of one here we dealt with the bar chart
so we'll directly enter into the column
versus line chart
so we have similar kind of data we just
had here and profits in the previous
part now we also have included the
expenses right we needed another column
to showcase the line chart compared to
the columns right so for that I've
included a new column that is expenses
all as well now just let's select the
data
and let's select the option
alt F1 to create a chat
right now automatically uh Excel has
provided us the column chat we have The
Columns of expenses we have the column
of profits and we also have these now
let's change the data as we did before
select uh here and remove it and then
edit
select edit and select the year that is
from here to 2021
select OK and we have the ears over here
now what we needed to do is
change the chart type right select the
change chart type option and since
wanted to create column versus length
chart it is a combination whenever you
want one or two types of charts included
in one single chart window then it has a
combo option so here we need to select
the combo option and inside that we have
various types of combination charts that
clustered column we have Cloud line on
secondary axis we have clustered stacked
areas clustered column and the other one
is custom combination so let's go with
the first one that is clustered line
let's select that and there you go we
have the line graph with the column so
that's how we create the column versus
line
and if you want you can input the data
labels and you can include data table as
well yeah
okay I think we need to expand the
canvas a little more to get the Clear
View
yeah
so you have Legends over here you have
the data labels and accesses everything
and chart title you can always change
the chart title so for now let's uh
rename it as
profits versus expenses
yeah that's that's how it goes
done
spelling mistake here
yeah it's clear now
the next type of chart we're going to
deal with is the preview chart
so uh we have dealt with pie chart
column chart bar chart and composition
now previous chart is a little bit
different it's like you're going to
create some active chart which responds
to the variations you are making to your
data so to understand that better let's
create a practical chart over here
and select all the data
if you
yeah I have selected the data now
to create a chart
select
the insert option from the toolbar and
inside the ribbon we have charts group
and inside that we have the wheelchair
now let's select the preview chat option
and there you go now it's asking for
range and we have selected the range
over there
and uh we are not going to create a new
worksheet for the entire chart you're
going to create the chart inside the
existing worksheet itself so for that
let's select the uh area where we want
to select the chart to be present now
for that let's select this and
yeah select ok
okay there is some error
and let's cancel this and try again
let's select the data
and preview chat again
we have selected the range
here
that's how you select the range
and now select the position where you
want to create it existing worksheet we
have selected that and press OK yeah
that's that's the way we've got our PV
chart over here and you can see our
previous chart is completely blank right
now it will respond to the changes you
make to your previous chat for now we
have serial numbers and these are the
names of the guys who have
okay so these are the names of the guys
you who have some dealerships for
various car makes such as Ford Ferrari
Honda Kia Alfa Romeo BMW etc etc so uh
we're gonna change or we're gonna see
um you know we're gonna make some charts
of the persons who own the cars or the
car brands or dealerships in various
regions so we're gonna work on that now
let's drag in the name
and uh let's drag region
and cards
and the units
yep so we have our chart over here
column chart which has the different
different names and the dealerships and
some of cars over there right so you can
see that we can also change some values
over here what if we wanted to know only
uh the details regarding Jennifer you
can do that you can unselect everything
and you can just select Jennifer and
press ok now you'll have the details of
only Jennifer of having the car brands
so we have the regions as well so
Jennifer owns dealerships in two
different regions that is South and West
and the sum of units and count of cars
as well
so that's how the PV charts are used in
real time
and now let's select sales and track the
sales as well
yeah it's been dragged and you have the
sales of Jennifer
the details of her sales
and let's move the chart a little bit
and you have the plus icon where you can
include the data labels for a better
information
yeah so that's how you use the previous
chats so we are on the last type of
charts which is the sparkline chart Now
to create a sparkline chart we need to
get into the insert option and inside we
have the ribbon and inside the ribbon we
have the group that is sparklines
now
to generate a sparkline chart we need to
select this particular column and then
select the type of sparkline you want to
create so now let's create the column
type of sparkline chart yep we have to
flop these cells together first we've
got that because we're gonna insert the
sparkline chart right above here
now for that let's merge the cells
[Music]
yeah
so we wanted to create the
sparkline chart of column type and now
it's asking for the location where we
want to create the spark launcher so
this is the location now let's select ok
and there you go we have the sparkline
chart right over here
now you can see that we have a negative
Point here so if you want you can change
that from negative to positive and
automatically update that and if you
want to add the access to this
particular chart you can select the
options sparkline and there you go you
have certain options like hi point no
point and if you wanted to add some
margins and you can also do that
and the data type access and they're
going to have the access
show access yeah you have the access now
and you can have the high point and low
point for that as well which is the you
know the biggest change and the smallest
change in this particular segment that
is few Furniture yeah Furniture has the
highest sales in January and Home
Appliance at the lower sale and you can
also change the color
and let's type of change the color again
here we have a different color over here
which resembles a little bit more better
or you can also go with this one
and if you wanted to add the same to all
these tables you can do that just by
tracking it and you have it for all the
six months
now if we wanted to add some new data in
this row or you wanted to add a new
complete row then you can do that as
well and change that and bring that
change implemented in these charts as
well
now let us try to add a new row here
which includes the miscellaneous we have
that data right over here let's select
that
copy and let's paste it over here
so there you go we have the extra row
here so yeah now we have added the
miscellaneous row and right now we have
the sparkline chart for only four
columns or four rows that is for initial
technology home appliances and office
needs and miscellaneous is missing now
to add that as well let's select
sparkline
and inside sparkline just select edit
Group location and data and now let's
select the entire data
and now select ok
there's something wrong
again
sparkline edit data
select range
this should be helping yeah there you go
we have all the five rows now including
Furniture technology home appliances
office needs and miscellaneous so what
is data validation in x cell so it is a
feature by Microsoft Excel where it can
restrict data entry into certain cells
by using data validation
and it will prompt the users to enter
valid data in the cells based on the
rules and restrictions provided by the
creator of that particular sheet now
this would be a little confusing to
understand so to understand it in a much
better way let's get back to the
practical way where we will start
entering some data validation rules to
our Excel sheet and try to enter data
into it now we are on the Microsoft
Excel and this particular sheet is based
on employee ID employee name employee
Department employee salary fiscal year
and work timings of the employees
now we will be applying some data
validation rules to each and every
column and try to enter data based on
the rows we have entered now for the
first one which is the employee ID we'll
enter rules based on the employee ID
number so to apply the data validation
you need to go into the data tab on the
toolbar
and inside the ribbon you can see data
tools group and in the data tools group
you have the option of data validation
now select the entire column go to the
data tools group select data validation
option and you will have this particular
pop-up menu
and here you can see different types of
options so since we are entering
employee ID it would be a whole number
so let us select whole number option and
now here you can see the option of
between not equal to equal to not
between greater than less than Etc
so let us select between
and let us assume that your employee ID
has five numbers and it should be
between 10 000 to
11 000.
so let us provide 10 000
and 11 000.
now select ok
and now the new rule has been applied
so now the minimum value of each and
every employee ID should be equal to or
more than 10 000 and less than 11 000
and it should have five digits now let's
try to enter a wrong employee ID that is
just one
there you go you can see that Microsoft
Excel is not allowing you to include a
wrong number it says this value does not
match the data validation restrictions
defined for this cell so now you can
press retry and try to enter some number
which is in between 10 000 to 11 000.
now it is 10901 and this will take the
entry
now let us assume that because I am the
creator of this I know what should
be entered here but what if I give this
to you and you are the person who
is trying to enter the number and it
shows the error and you don't know what
was the error right to avoid this kind
of confusion what you can do is you can
do some uh ways where you can provide
the message to the user so that can be
done by
okay let's select this sheet again and
go to the data validation and here you
have the same settings now here you have
another option saying input message
so before input message let us go to
error alert now here
the error title will be data entered
is
not valid
please enter this is the error message
please enter
EMP
ath between
ten thousand to eleven thousand
press ok
now when you try to enter the wrong
number it will show that particular
error alert message
see data entered is not valid please
enter employee ID between 10 000 to 11
000. now this is fine but how long this
will be you know what if there is an
option where you just hover over to the
cell and it automatically tells you to
enter the value between ten thousand to
eleven thousand without having to face
the error yeah even that can be done so
you can select the entire column go to
data validation and here this is the
input message this is where you can do
that
so
here you can write the message name
valid data
please enter
data between
10 000 to
11 000 now when you hover over to any
excel in this particular column it will
automatically show you this message
where you can avoid all the errors
just select OK see when you select any
cell in this particular column it will
automatically tell you please enter data
between ten thousand to eleven thousand
so here you don't have to face any
errors right now let us try to enter the
valid data
1 0 9
0 2
and it will take it as the correct value
and again 1 0 9 0 3.
now in case if you try to provide the
wrong number it will show the error
see
so that's how it is now we have finished
the whole number part now let's get into
the employee name where we have to
provide
uh the second type that is text length
now let us imagine that uh in your
company you're trying to provide ID
cards to your employees and you know
that ID card is really small and inside
that ID card you need to include the
employee photograph and your company
name employee ID blood group phone
number address everything and also you
need to include the name of the employer
so what if there is an employer with
very lengthy name like 30 characters 40
characters yeah in India it is really
possible that you might have a lengthy
name so what you can do is you can
provide the text length where the text
is limited to like 15 or 20
characters so you can include that name
in the ID card so you can do that by
allowing the data validation criteria
with text length minimum can be anything
so minimum can be one and maximum here
you can provide 15. and press ok ok
minimum will change it to at least two
and yeah let it be one
so minimum is one and maximum is 15
characters and press ok
and let us also provide the input
message
enter
character type character data
please enter valid name
error alert
invalid data
please enter validator
please enter characters
less than
50.
press ok
now let us try to enter a random name
okay uh we'll enter characters more than
15 here equality
uh yeah it's like one two three four
five eleven
okay now this is more than 15.
okay I think it's not more than 15.
let's try to enter a little bit more
characters
now we have entered more than 15
characters and it is showing please
enter characters less than 15. so now we
can retry and try to enter some valid
name
um
foreign
ters less than 50 so it will take as the
proper name
now let us try to enter another name
I'm just entering some random data
so another name maybe
great now the next type of data
validation is also done now let us get
into employee Department employee
department is something really superb so
I'll tell you about it it's actually a
list now let us finish the other ones
first that is employee salary fiscal
year and work timings after that we'll
learn about uh the list one
now let's come into employee salary so
salary is something where you have to
include decimal points so now let us go
to a data validation and inside the
values we have already dealt with whole
number
uh text length
yeah now we'll deal with employee salary
that is decimal
now minimum is okay what is the uh
minimum can be one
point zero zero and maximum can be
one lakh
point zero zero or let us
put that as 10 lakhs
press ok
okay not not just them and enter valid
okay now let's change it to minimum is
10 000.
so the employee minimum salary will be
10 000 and input enter valid salary
and uh
salary
between
ten thousand
to 10 lakhs
let us include a comma here too
now error alert
invalid salary
please enter
between
10 000
to 10 lakhs
press ok now the message and the data
validation conditions are applied to
this column now let us try to enter some
invalid data first
it will show the error
now we need to enter the valid data
yeah now it is taking the valid data let
us provide twenty thousand
and this has 35
000.
now the next one is fiscally let us
imagine that we wanted to you know work
on the employees for current working
gear that is 2020 to 2021
and or you can consider 2021 to 2022 not
more than 2021 and not less than 2021
for that you can provide the year option
as well so for that you need to select
the entire column go to data validation
settings and inside here you have an
option of date
so let us provide the date option as
between and start date is 0 1 0 1 slash
2021 and end date is
0 1 0 1 slash
and input message
let us provide data as current
fiscal year
Current financial year
enter date
between
2021 to 2022
let us copy this and go into error alert
error message will be saved invalid
[Music]
select ok now the error message and the
data input message and the data
validation rule has been applied for
this column so let's try to enter some
date here
you can enter 0 2 of February
2021 it will take as the correct data
now let's try to enter some wrong data
which is apart from 2020 to 0 to 0 2
22. it will not take this it will throw
error
so that's how it works now let us try to
enter as 2021
and this is merge
it will take it now another data
0 4 this time and 2021
so that's how your uh date data
validation will work now coming into the
next type of data validation that is
time
so we have time here let us imagine that
you are providing some work timings to
your employees that should be from 9 am
to 5 PM not more than that so you want
to keep your work life balanced for all
your employees so you just want them to
work between nine to five and that
should be fine and anything apart from
that time should be invalid so you can
do that by selecting a Time option
between it should be in between and the
start time will be 0 9
0 0 and this should be
uh
17.
that is 5 PM in the evening
and input message
please enter
time between
9 am
two
okay
5 PM
this should be the input message
foreign
error message
now
okay work timings now
this should be okay
we can do this as two columns actually
let us
cancel
let us copy this and paste it here
you can do it as login
timing and this should be okay
this should be a log out
so this should be
okay so this will be considered as login
and logout times
now let us provide the login time
with the right time
[Music]
let's try to provide wrong timings zero
eight now it will not take it it will
throw as error
so it's working fine let us provide 10
now let us provide the logout time it
should be below 5 PM
so let us provide five it will take it
okay
let's try to provide something just one
minute less than five
that is 59
okay there is some problem in this let's
check it
okay it is taking uh three that is
including seconds
okay let's provide seconds as well
zero five zero zero 0 0
okay still there is some problem
[Music]
okay we have entered four we should we
are supposed to enter 24 hour timing
right
okay uh it should be 17. I think this
will work yeah
now we are following 24 hour timing here
so let's provide another timing that is
300 this will be valid and 15 30.
this is also value now we have finished
almost all types of uh data validation
things that is we have finished with any
value whole number decimal date timing
test length and the last one is list so
this is where things get interesting now
let's cancel this now
select the employee column now if you
are running a company then definitely
you will not have only one Department in
it you might have multiple departments
right so let us consider that you have a
software development company so in that
the basic departments will be software
development team and software testing
team so what you can do is you can
provide a list
so using that list you can just hover
over to that cell select the drop down
menu and inside that you can select the
option so we will try to work something
like that if we have selected the end
column
the selection up here
yeah let us select the entire column
again go to data validation
the selection contains some cells
without data validation settings do you
want to extend data vibration to the
cells yes
now let us provide the list option
and
here Source you can provide us
developer
and test
press OK OK
now input message
select one
error alert
invalid
data
select from drop down
only
press ok
now when you select the cell you can see
small drop down icon right so when you
press it you will have developer and
tester option
so you can select developer for first
one and for second one you can select
tester
right okay this is good for uh one or
two options maybe three or even maybe
like five but what if you have more
departments okay let's go to this second
sheet where we have the department data
so here we have like 14 departments no
15 departments or 15 employee type names
so the first one is see your second list
developer tester quality analyst system
analyst Finance human resource so so
many options are there so you cannot
keep on typing all of them right so here
it is 15 what if you have like 25 like
50 departments right it will be tough so
for this you have another option so let
me select all this data and copy this
from this sheet to our employee sheet
let us paste it somewhere
here
let's expand this
okay now we have our list over here
now let us remove the data validation
from this column
clear all okay now everything is clear
let's select ok now let us erase this
data as well
now let us apply the list data
validation again from scratch go to list
now here we can select the source
select this particular cell
and drag it until here and it has been
loaded
now go to input message
foreign
data options
select one
from the menu or the drop down
copy
error alert
select only from the drop down menu
invalid entry yeah
now let's select ok
fine now you have the icon here you have
all the provided options
you can scroll down and select any one
of these you can select knowledge
transfer for the first one
and second one would be
system and list
and that the last one would be
human resources
now in the list everything is fine okay
this is showing you the menu options and
everything
so but what if you provide this sheet to
your new Journey or new employee in your
company and by mistake he messes up
something like deleting this okay so we
have deleted systems analyst and when
you click on the options here you don't
have systems analyst in that place you
have blank space right so there is a way
where all your you know data can be
messed up so to avoid this what you can
do is
you can actually
um
save this data in a different sheet like
I did here like Department data you can
hide the sheet or you can protect the
sheet with password or something so that
nobody can mess this up so now let us
get back to the employee data and select
this column and
clear everything
press ok
and let us also clear this
this as well in this one too
let us eliminate the rows or cells
the employee
everything
okay now we have basically removed this
data from here
now let us try to apply the data
validation once again
now here
let us select as list
and
here let us provide the option
let us go to next sheet let us select
all these options
press okay
okay let's provide input message
data options
or Department options
foreign
now let's hide this sheet
the sheet has been hidden and you still
have the options
developer
or let us provide see you
then we have developer
then we have
test
so that's how you can protect your
sheets as well now this is how you apply
data validation in your Excel what is
Excel vlookup
vlookup stands for vertical lookup
vlookup lets you search for specific
information in your spreadsheet it
allows you to search for a particular
value in a column and returns another
value from a different column but of the
same row
vlookup takes advantage of vertically
aligned tables to quickly find data
associated with the value the user
enters now let's look at the syntax to
write a vlookup function so vlookup
takes four parameters or arguments you
can see it here there are four arguments
in the Wilco function
so the first argument is called the
lookup value the lookup value represents
the value that you are searching for
next is the table array the table array
represents two or more Columns of
information the third argument is called
the column index number now this
represents the column number in the
table from which the value must be
returned the First Column is 1 the
second column is 2 and so on and then we
have the fourth parameter which is
called the range lookup now this
parameter is optional now range lookup
is used to find an exact match
so if you want to find an exact match
you need to enter false or 0 meanwhile
if you want an approximate match you
need to enter true or one if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now let me give you a brief overview on
what's going to be in our demo
so for our demonstration
we'll use a sales data set you can see
the data set on the left
using this data set we'll understand how
vlookup performs an exact and
approximate match we'll see how vlookup
is case insensitive
then we'll perform a wildcard character
search
we'll understand how to handle errors
when a match is not found and finally
you will look at two-way lookups
now here is a small example of how
vlookup works
so we want to find the units sold by
Morgan using the data set on the left
so here you can see I have the data set
it has
some rows and columns so these are the
columns which are order date region
there's a representative column item
units this unit cost and total and from
this table I want to find the units that
were sold by Morgan if you look at the
table at the bottom you can see the
representative name Morgan and Morgan
has sold 30 units now I want to find
this value using the vlookup function so
here on the right you can see I have my
lookup value which is Morgan and this is
my vlookup formula and using this
formula I am getting the result as 30.
now let's go to our Excel workbook and
perform all the demos one by one so this
is my Excel workbook that we are going
to use for our demo and here is the data
set we'll be using now this is the same
data set that you saw a while ago
so this data set has seven columns you
have the order date the region
representative's name item there's units
unit cost and total which is basically
the total or the amount of sales that
was generated
now we are going to use a chunk of this
data set and perform our vlookup
analysis
so let's see our first example and the
problem we have at hand
let me go to the exact match tab
all right
so here
I'm going to use this chunk of data
which is actually taken from the
original data set so we have taken the
first
11 rows from the data set you can see
from Row 2
till root 12 is going to be a data set
that we'll use
so we have a question here
we want to find the items sold by
Thomson
so here
Thompson is my lookup value which means
looking at Thompson I want to find the
item that is sold
so if you consider our table here you
can see we have the representatives name
Thompson
right here and from the table you can
see Thompson sold pencil
and I want to get this value to Spencer
using my vlookup function so let's go
ahead and write our vlookup function
I'll consider this as my lookup value
and here under item I'm going to write
my vlooker formula
to write the vlooker formula I'll write
first equal to
and
I'll write vlookup now if I hit tab it
will auto complete all right now let's
give the parameters so the first is
going to be the lookup value which is
nothing but thumps and so I'll just
select this cell
which is j17
comma now it's asking to give the table
array so the table array is the table
from which you want to retrieve a value
one thing to keep in mind is that the
value you are looking for should be the
first column of a table and you can
select the table array till the end of
the data set or till the column which
has the value you want to find
so here I'll select my table array
starting from the representatives column
till the end of the item column which is
going to be my table array then I'll
select the column index number so the
column index number is based on the
table array you have selected in this
case my column index number is going to
be 2 because we have selected just two
columns and the value which I am going
to find is in the second column so I'll
give 2
comma now the range lookup I am going to
give is false because I want to find an
exact match so either you can hit tab
or you can write 0 which means false
if I close the bracket and hit enter
it will return me the item that Thompson
had sold which is pencil you can verify
from the table that Thompson had sold
pencil all right
now let's try to change the table array
and see what result are we getting so
this time I'll slightly change the table
array so again we are trying to find the
item that Thompson had sold so I'll
write my formula equal to vlookup I'll
hit tab to autocomplete I'll give my
lookup value as Thompson
comma this time I am choosing my table
array starting from the representatives
column till
the end of the data set which is
till p12
again my column index number is going to
be 2 because if you consider this table
array the item column is the second
column in the selected table array so I
am going to write it as 2 comma
the range lookup I want to give as false
because I want to find the exact match
if I close this and hit enter you can
see it has written me the same result
that we saw earlier
now suppose let's say this time I want
to start my table array from the region
column which is this column
so I want to select my table array
starting from the region column now this
is going to show me an error because
your table array should always start
from the lookup value column so if you
consider Thompson as the lookup value
my table array should always start from
the representatives column so let's just
try this example
so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value I'm going to give it as
Thompson comma the table array as I
mentioned earlier I am going to choose
from the region column and let's say
I'll select till the item column give
another comma and this time a column
index number is going to be 3 because
since the table array has three columns
and my item column is the last column so
I'm going to give my column index number
is 3 comma I want to get the exact match
so I'll give 0 if I close the bracket
and hit enter you can see it has given
me an error
okay now let me just show you another
method to use vlookup in Excel so here
on the top you can see there's a
formulas Tab and under formulas tab
under function Library you see we have
an option to select lookup and reference
if I click on this
and if I scroll down below you can see
there's an option
called vlookup let's choose this
all right now here you can give
your lookup value your table array
column index number and the range lookup
under this function arguments dialog box
so here I want to select my lookup value
as
Thompson my table array is going to be
from the representatives column till
let's say the end of the data set
my column index number is going to be 2
I'll write 2
and range lookup I'll write as false
because I want the exact match
now if I hit OK you can see it has given
us the exact same result so this is one
of the other ways to use vlookup in
Excel now let's move to the next sheet
which is regarding approximate match
okay so sometimes you might have cases
where you don't have the lookup present
in the table in those cases you can tell
vlookup to return an approximate match
now one thing to keep in mind is that
your lookup value columns should always
be sorted in ascending order while
trying to get an approximate match so
here we are going to use this table and
my lookup value column which is going to
be the representatives column is already
sorted in ascending order
and let's see the question we have here
so I want to find the item sold and the
unit cost format so my lookup value is
going to be matte now if you see this
table I don't have the representative's
name matte anywhere in the table now
using an approximate match I want to
find the item and the unit cost so let's
do it
so here under item I'll write my vlooker
formula
so I'll type vlookup I'll hit tab to
complete it
and this time meluco value is going to
be matte so I'll select this cell comma
my table array I'll select
from the representatives column till
the end of
item column because I want to find the
item value format
I'll give a comma
my column index number as per the table
array is going to be 2
comma my range lookup this time I'm
going to give a screw or one
so I'll write 1
close the bracket hit enter
all right it has written binder was the
item sold by Matt
now let's try to figure out why vlookup
returned binder as the item
now let's see you were asked to insert
the name matte to the representative
column in alphabetical order so where
would you place it
ideally you should Place between qvel
and Morgan
since this column is already sorted mat
should appear before Morgan and after
cubelle so in an approximate match
vlookup will consider the previous
highest value
in this case the previous highest value
before is qvl and hence vlookup returned
the corresponding item purchased by
keval which is binder now similarly
if you wanted to find the unit cost
format
again vlookup will return the unit cost
of qvl which is 125. let's just write
out so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value is matte comma my table
array for this time is going to be from
Representatives column till the unit
cost column I'll consider
I'll give a comma now the column index
number as per the table array is going
to be 4 will give another comma and this
time I'll double click true because I
want an approximate match we close the
bracket hit enter you can see it has
written me 125 which is actually
kibble's unit cost okay we have another
question and this time I want to find
the units sold by Rob now Rob is going
to be my lookup value
if you see the representatives column we
don't have Rob now let's see what
vlookup is going to return as the item
for Rob so I'll write vlookup I'll give
my lookup value as Rob comma my table
array
is going to start from the
representatives column
I'll select till here I'll give a comma
my column index number is 2
we give another comma
I'll double click on true
so close the bracket hit enter you can
see vlookup has written me pen now let's
understand why vlookup returned pen for
Rob now if you are asked to insert the
representatives name Rob
into this column so ideally Rob would
appear somewhere between Morgan and
Sorvino because
since this is sorted in ascending order
Rob is actually greater than Morgan and
is less than Sorvino so as you know
we look up in an approximate match
Returns the previous highest value which
is Morgan here and the corresponding
item for Morgan is pen and hence we look
up returned pen from Rob all right
now moving to the next sheet
which is another property of vlookup
which tells vlookup always looks to the
right this means that your lookup value
must always be on the left
and the value you are going to find out
should always be to the right of the
table now consider this scenario where
your lookup value is on the left in this
case it is the representatives value and
I have taken cervino for an example
and we want to find the order date for
servino now if you consider this table
your lookup value which is sure we know
is actually this column the
representatives column and we are going
to find out the order date so your
representative's name is on the right of
the table and the value we are going to
find out is on the left of the table
now as per the property vlookup only
looks to the right
so if I use the vlookup function for
this example here I'll write vlookup
I'll give my lookup value as sorpino
comma multiple array I'll consider from
the order date because I want the order
date
till
the representatives column I'll give a
comma and this time
my column index number is actually the
first column if I consider my table
array as the first three columns
selected
and my range lookup is going to be false
if we close the bracket hit enter it
returns me an error the reason is
vlookup always looks to the right and
this time the value we were trying to
find out was to the left of the table
now if you consider
the opposite case suppose you have the
order date and you want to find the
representative's name you can do that
easily because you look up value which
is the order date is on the left and
your representatives column is on the
right so let's just try this I'll write
vlookup my lookup value is going to be
sorvino's order date so I'll select it
from the table
I'll give a comma my table array will
start from the G column let's say I'll
select the entire table
comma and my column index number will be
3 if you consider these as my table
array
comma my range lookup is zero if I close
this hit enter you can see we have got
Sorvino corresponding to the order date
all right now let's move to the next tab
now this tab says
vlookup returns only the first match so
we have a question at hand the question
is
find the units sold by Jardine
if you see this table
we have the representative's name Jardin
twice you see here and if you look down
we have Jardin here as well but the
items sold by Jardin at the first
instance is pencil and at the second
instance it's desk
now as per the property always returns
the first match now ideally when we
write the vlookup function and look for
the units sold by Jardine you will see
vlookup will return
36 instead of 3. let's just try it out
I'll write the vlookup function
my lookup value is Jardine
comma my table array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of
units column
we'll give a comma my column index
number based on the table array is three
I'll give another comma Now I want the
exact match so I'll select 0
close the bracket and hit enter
now as you can see it returns me the
first match of Jardine which is 36 so
vlookup did not consider the second
match
now similarly
if you consider this table
we have Jones repeated Thrice so you
have Jones here
we have Jones
here for the second time and also we
have Jones for the third time and let's
see you want to find the unit cost for
Jones so if I write the vlookup function
I'll consider my
lookup value as Jones comma my table
array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of unit cost column
I'll give a comma based on the table
array my unit cost column is at the
fourth index so I'll write 4 comma the
range lookup is 0.
if I click on this
and hit enter you can see it here
vlookup has returned the first instance
of Jones and it did not consider the
second and the third instance so our
unit cost
for Jones is 1.99 because vlookup only
Returns the first match
okay moving ahead to the next example we
have here is vlookup is case insensitive
if you consider this table
I've added another
Row in green
so if you see here I have a
representative name called Gill which is
in proper case or
popularly known as sentence case here I
have added Gill's name in
capital letters are all in uppercase so
I want to find the total revenue
generated by Gill the total revenue is
basically the total column
let's do it I'll write vlookup
my lookup value is Gill which is
actually in upper case
I'll consider my table array from the
representatives column till the end of
total column or the sales column
based on the selection my column index
number is 5
comma the range lookup is false so I'll
just double click on false
if we close the bracket hit enter
you can see it here
our vlookup function has returned the
total as
539.73 which is actually
the value for this row so clearly
vlookup did not consider Gill
which was present at the bottom of the
table in upper case
so this shows that vlookup is clearly
case insensitive
all right
now moving to the next example the
vlookup function supports wild cards
which makes it possible to perform a
partial match on a lookup value for
instance you can use vlookup to retrieve
values from a table after typing only
part of a lookup value to use wild cards
with vlookup you must specify the exact
match by giving false or 0 for the last
argument that is range lookup now we
have a question here
I want to know how much sales did the
representative whose name starts with Ki
make now here sales represents the total
column actually
so I want to find out the person whose
name starts with Ki
so if you consider the representative
column I have one representative whose
name starts with Ki that is Key Well so
using Ki as my lookup value I want to
find the total so let me show you how to
use Wild Card characters and find the
value using vlookup so I'll write my
function vlookup
okay now in lookup value I'll give Ki
after that I am going to write Ampersand
followed by
double inverted commas
then I'm going to write a star and close
the inverted comma this means the value
starts with k i Ampersand actually
represents concatenation and star
represents anything followed by Ki
so this is going to be my lookup value
in total
I'll give a comma
next I'll select my table array starting
from the representatives column till the
end of total column because I want to
find the sales
I'll give another comma
my column index number based on the
table array we have selected is 5.
comma the range lookup is 0 because I
want to find an exact match
let's close the bracket hit enter you
can see it here
vlookup has returned me 999.5 which is
actually Cable's total
now there's another way to do it
instead of selecting the cell in which
we have the lookup value I can directly
write it in the vlookup function
so I'll write the vlookup function
something like this
so my lookup value
I'll pass Ki within double inverted
commas because k i is a character value
So within double inverted commas I'm
writing Ki followed by Ampersand which
is for concatenation
followed by
a star
within double inverted commas so this is
going to be my look of values
this in total means anything that
appears after Ki will be considered as
the lookup value
again the table array I'll select as
these rows and columns
comma my column index number would be 5
comma the range lookup is zero if I
close the bracket hit enter you see we
have the same value so this is another
method or another way of using
vlookups
okay now moving ahead let's explore
another feature of vlookup so if the
vlookup function cannot find a match it
returns a has an a error now if you want
you can use the if any function to
replace the hash any error with a
friendly message so suppose
you want to find the region in which an
order was placed on 10th of May 2018.
now if the order date is not found I
want to return a message that is invalid
date
so
if you look at the order date
column we don't have any value for 10th
of May 2015. you can see these values we
don't have any value corresponding to
this date
so
if my vlookup function cannot find this
lookup value I'll return invalid date
so let me show you
how to write this
I'll type my vlookup function
I'll give my order date as 10th of May
2015.
as my lookup value and then
I'll consider my table array starting
from the order date column till the end
of
region column
we'll give another comma my column index
number would be 2 this time based on the
table array we have selected comma
I want an exact match
so I'll give 0 close the bracket and hit
enter
there you go it has returned me a error
now I want to convert this error to a
friendly message saying invalid date so
let me show you how to do it I'll do it
here so to return a valid message
I'll use the if any function
and within if any function I'll give my
vlookup function
so let me type if any
I'll hit tab
now for the value parameter I'll use my
vlookup function so my lookup value is
going to be the order date
comma my table array I'll select from
the order date column till the end of
region column comma where column index
number is going to be 2
comma my range lookup is 0
I'll close the bracket give another
comma Now if this expression results in
an error I want to display a message
that is invalid date
so I'll put invalid date within double
quotes
since it is
a text message
I close the bracket hit enter you can
see
the result which is invalid date
now moving on to the final section of
the demo
we have two-way lookup
now in the vlookup function the column
index parameter is normally hard coded
as a static number however you can also
create a dynamic column index by using
the match function to locate the right
column
and this technique allows you to create
a dynamic two-way lookup matching on
both rows and columns
now let me first show you how a match
function works so suppose
I want to find the index where unit cost
column is present so here I'll use the
match function
I'll give my lookup value as the unit
cost column name
comma suppose I'll choose my lookup
array starting from Representatives
column till the unit cost column comma
I'll give my match type as 0 for exact
match
if I close the bracket hit enter it
returns me 4 because
my array was selected from the
representatives column till the unit
cost column and in this array unit cost
is at the fourth index
all right now using this idea let's
solve the following problem I want to
find the cost of each item sold by
Morgan
so let's
write our vlooker formula
write B lookup
my lookup value is J5 which has the
representative's name as Morgan comma
my table array I'll select from
C2
till
F12
I'll give a comma and this time I know
that my column index number is at
4 but I'll be using the match function
to find the same
so I'll write match
my lookup value is
unit cost comma
my lookup array is from C1 till F1
comma my match type is 0
I closed this bracket and give another
comma and I'll give my range lookup as 0
close the bracket hit enter you can see
for Morgan the unit cost is 19.99 you
can verify from the table for Morgan the
unit cost is 19.99
all right now
we have another question here
I want to find how much sales did
Andrews make in the central region so
here I have
two lookup values one is Central one is
Andrews now looking at these two values
I want to find the total
to solve such problems
let me first create
another table
I'll place the table somewhere here
okay so let me just paste the table here
all right now I'll create another column
where I'll merge the values of region
and representatives so here let me
create another column okay I'll just
name this column as
region
rep
all right now this column
I'll use the concatenation operator
so I'll Select East
use Ampersand and then select Jones I'll
hit enter
now the same thing I'll just duplicate
it
for the other rows as well so I have my
new column created Now using this table
I can easily solve the problem
now to find the total I'll write my
vlookup formula
so my lookup value
will be a combination of j11
ampersand
k11
comma well table array will start from
the region rep which has the values of
region and rip combined
till
the last column
and from this table array my column
index number is 5
and my range lookup is zero if I close
the bracket hit enter you can see
for central region which is this one
and for Andrew's representative the
total is 149.25
all right now we are done with our demo
let's have a quick glance at what all we
did in this demo
okay so first of all we saw our data set
which was a sales data set that we used
then we started with our first example
to see how vlooker performs an exact
match we also saw how using the formulas
Tab and lookup and reference you can
write vlookup in
another way so you can use the function
arguments to give your vlookup
parameters next we saw how vlooker
performs an approximate match so we had
matte and raw which were not present in
the representatives column
after that
we saw an important property of vlookup
that is vlookup only looks to the right
followed by
vlookup only Returns the first match
following which we saw
that vlookup is case insensitive so here
we had added a new row where Gill was
present in upper case but still we look
up
found the total revenue for Gill which
was in sentence case or properties next
we saw how we can use wildcard
characters to
use vlookups
and here we saw how to use an if any
function along with vlookup and finally
we saw how to use two-way lookups choose
from over 300 in-demand skills and get
access to 1000 plus hours of video
content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more now we are on
the sheet of Microsoft Excel and here
you can see some data on my sheet
that is employee name employee ID and
salary
so here we are going to perform our
horizontal lookup but before that let me
show you that this particular drop down
menu so this particular drop down menu
has all the names of the employees in
this particular table and we have
created this using data validation in
Excel if you want to create the drop
down menus just like this then feel free
to check out our data validation in
Excel tutorial link to which is in the
description box below now let's try to
implement each lookup in Excel so here
we have employee name but we want to
find out the employee ID so for that
let's create the hlookup now for that
equals to hlookup
now the first one is the lookup value so
this one is the cell which is the
employee name now after that the table
array we have to select all the table
arrays here
now
the row index number so the employee ID
is in row index number two according to
the table so for that provide 2 and
close the bracket and before closing
brackets you might want to give the
exact match so for exact match select
false and close the bracket press enter
and there you go and if you select jet
then you'll find the employee ID of
check and if you select jury you'll find
the employee ID of cherry reflecting
here now similarly let's find out the
salary of all the employees using
hlookup so equals hlookup
and lookup value that happens to be the
name of the employee now the table array
and next we have row index number that
is salary happens to be the third row in
the table so three and
exact match
close the bracket and enter so now if
you change the values in this particular
drop down menu you will find the
employee ID and their particular salary
so Jack happens to be carrying the
employee ID as one zero zero one and his
salary is ten thousand so similarly
let's try to find out Peter's employee
ID and salary
so there you go 1005 and 50 000 as
salary so that's how you use hlookup in
Excel here you can see the first chart
so this particular data is converted
into a table format to avoid confusion
while you're fixing the data so here you
can see the name of the employee
employee ID Department salary and date
of Channel and here you can see the
salary column and the bonus percentage
of each and every employee based on
their salaries now coming to the new
data table and here on the table 2 which
is an updated table here you can find we
are going to find out the department of
the employee and the current Department
of employee and the bonus percentage
based on his or her salary so why are we
finding current Department again so here
you can see that we have an intern Emily
who has joined in the air 2020 but
recently she got promoted as a developer
so her department has been changed from
Department in turn to Department
developer in 2021 so that's what we're
gonna find out here in the current
Department using X lookup now let's
start to implement xlookup so for that
equals to xlookup
and for lookup you can see if you need
to find out the lookup value lookup
array return array and all the other two
are not important right now but you can
use them to get some exact matches in
the future we'll also use that in the
future for now let's try to use the
first three parameters that is lookup
value lookup array and written array so
the lookup value is the name of the
employee Mary and lookup array is right
here which is this one
now we are going to select the lookup
array then comma and we're going to look
up the department so this is the
department lookup array
and that's all we need
close the bracket and press enter
okay I think we missed out the lookup
value
so the employee or the lookup value
which we required was missed so I've
added it here so that is the lookup
value the first one which is Miri and
there you go
press enter and you have the department
here now let's add it to all the rows
and here you have all the rows and all
the data related all the employees now
we will find out the current Department
as you can see here you have Emily as
intern which is the older data but what
if we needed the latest data that is the
developer in the year 2021 right for
that you might want to throw up the X
lookup formula a little bit so let's try
that X lookup
lookup value which is the same and comma
now where you have to look for the array
that is lookup array this one and the
return array which happens to be this
one
and next
you can find the exact match for this
one so that's all right exact match and
here comes the important part where you
have to search last to first by default
X lookup searches for first to last that
is like this in the starting place to
the last place so that's the reason why
we had Emily as intern so now if we give
last to first then it retrieves the
latest data where Emily will be shown as
developer now select that and now you
can close the brackets and press enter
so let's add that to all the rows there
you go now you can see Emily Clark Peter
and James all they have got their
updated job profiles as you can see in
the original data Emily is a developer
now so is Clark who was originally a
tester and he got promoted to
development team in 2021 similarly Peter
became a senior Finance executive in
2021 and James the manager of sales now
let's try to find out the bonus for all
these employees based on their salary so
this one is quite simple
so X lookup
now the lookup value is their existing
salary
comma and the bonus part so the lookup
array is the salary range
then here is another important point so
here you might want to find the exact
match but finding an exact match will
not help you here you might want to
declare another type of value where you
can get exact match or next smaller item
so you'll understand it why I'm
selecting that so now let's close the
bracket and enter so
so now we have the bonus values now
let's add the bonus value to all the
factors all the rows I mean so you can
see we have different variety of
salaries that is thirty eight thousand
twenty two thousand thirty nine Etc but
here in the ranges we have provided 10
20 30 14 50. so what if the value is
between 30 and 20 that's when you want
the less number right that's when you
want the number which is equivalent to
30 or less than 30 which happens to be
15 percent so that's how it has worked
here that is 0.15 bonus to the actual
salary so slices in Excel are software
filters used along with Excel tables or
Excel pivot tables over a large amount
of data not just filtering out data but
slices also help you with an easy
understanding of the information being
extracted and displayed on the screen
now Microsoft Excel slices are
compatible with Windows and Macintosh
operating systems now let us understand
how to implement slicers in Excel so for
that we might want to get back to the
Practical mode that is starting a
Microsoft Excel
now we are on our Excel sheet and as you
can see on my screen there is some data
available on the Excel spreadsheet and
this table is not just any table this
table from Microsoft Excel has been
converted into an actual table as you
know by default Excel considers all the
data which has been inserted into the
spreadsheet as a database and to
implement this slices in Excel we might
want to create or convert the format of
database into a normal table for that
you can select all your data and just
press Ctrl T and that will allow you an
option called convert the data into
table
now since this table is already
converted as a table we can directly
start implementing or inserting slices
into the spreadsheet
now for that select all your data
then go into the insert option
and in the insert ribbon you can see the
filters group and in the filters group
select the option called slicer now you
will be provided with multiple options
since we have the columns employee ID
employee name Zone designation
Department salary employees date of
birth and employees date of Journey so
we can choose any of the options
available according to our columns and
create the slices now let me select the
first one that is Zone next designation
department and let's also select
employee name
now press OK and there you go we have
our slices
now let's try to rearrange these slices
all you can do is just select and drag
them up
and done now let us imagine that we want
to see or take a look at the employees
who are working in the East Zone then we
have all the information displayed on
the screen who are working in the
Eastern they are Jack Tony Banner Fred
Etc and their Department designation etc
etc all on one single screen so this
really helps you while you're presenting
your data in a presentation now for a
change let's try to select the
department now if your client wants to
select the data from only analytics
Department then you might want to select
on the analytics key on the department
slicer and the echo you have an employee
called lookups who works in the East
Zone and his department is analytics and
his resignation is contract East and the
salary he is getting is 65
000.
now similarly
you can see that we have only selected
analytics and your client also wants
data from it support now you can see
that analytics is gone
but what if we want both analytics and
ID support then you have an option
called selected multiple then you can
select analytics and ID support and if
you want HR you can also do that and in
the zone if you want best along with
East then you can do the same east and
west and you have all the employee
details and in the designation let's try
to Select Senior trainee okay select
multiple senior training and manager so
that's how you do it
so that's how it's done and that's how
you implement slicers in Excel to
simplify the filtering options using
slicers during a presentation and with
that we have come to an end of this
tutorial on slicers in Excel so on my
screen you can see an example Excel
budget template theme
so on my screen you can see a column
where you have the debit amount so in
the I column we have all the limit
amount what we are spending for a month
and on the right column will be the
balance amount or the running balance of
that for example you can see that there
is a row number five where the debit
amount is 8000 for a genes Levi's and it
is done through UPR payment now if I
change this value of 8 000 to 4000
something
and then you can see that the running
balance will automatically change you
can see that currently the running
balance is 73 000 and if I change this
value from 8 000 to 4000 then all the
running balances will change let's do
that so for that let's press enter
there you go you can see that the number
has been changed successfully and all
the values from the running violence are
also changed until the last date which
is the March 30th
now how is this working and not just
that you can see that we have also
included what is the total debit amount
in January and what is the running
balance that is the total available
balance after one lakh has been debated
into the account in the month of
February as February income
now the current available violence is
one lakh 13 200 and the total expense in
February is 1 lakh four thousand five
hundred right how am I doing all this
looks so much interesting right now
let's do this practically
so for that I have already created a new
sheet and I have included all the data
that we have used previously the income
of that particular month and all the
expenses of that particular month
now without further Ado let's begin to
implement the Excel budget template now
our first step happens to be converting
all the data into a natural table so you
know that in Excel all the data values
are stored in the form of a database by
default so it happens to be our duty to
convert the database type table into the
pure table type table so for that select
quality data and press Ctrl T and then
we have an option to convert this data
into a table and remember to check this
particular checkbox and tell your Excel
that your table has headers so we do
have headers here so now press OK and
your table will be converted into a
natural table
now let's type in the formulas
so now let's select the cell J2
and type in the formula
so what are we doing here is we are
trying to add the sum of J2 plus H3
so which is this particular cell and
removing I3 that is this particular
debit amount so this formula is used for
checking the running balance let's press
enter and there you go
so it means that you received 1 lakh
rupees in the month of January and out
of that 1 lakh you spend 15 000 rupees
for something maybe your educational
load or something and then the remaining
running balance out of 1 lakh Rupees is
85 000 rupees now let's copy the same
formula to all these cells
and there you go now the running balance
has been calculated for all the cells
here now remember the monthly income
available balance and debit for January
and final bonds now let's try to
calculate that for all the three months
so here we have three months that is
January February and March now let's do
a simple calculation to find out the
available balance of that month and the
total debit made by that person in that
particular month
the formula is really simple all you
have to do is use a sum function and
calculate the sum of all these values
and done right
there you go so the total expense of the
month January is 93 800 rupees now let's
calculate the total debit of February
month same formula that is
calculating the sum of
all the expenses made in the month of
February
they
now let's also calculate the sum of all
the expenses in the month of March
done so we have the final values of all
the total expenses made in those
particular months now let's calculate
the final balance
now I think I forgot one important thing
so before we calculate the final balance
we need to find out the available
balance that is the available balance
after 1 lakh Rupees is created into our
account and along with the savings that
you have from your previous month right
for that we have a simple formula
now which all we are doing is just
adding the uh income cell with the
balance cell that's all
so there you go now after crediting one
lakh rupees and adding up the uh balance
of that particular month that is we have
13 200 remaining from the month of
January and the month of February we
have income of one lakh so the total
amount is 11 300 and
I don't know it is 1 lakh 13 200 yeah
now we have the final balance that is
the difference between the available
balance and the debit made in that
particular month so in the month of
February we had a total balance of one
lakh 13 200 and the total debit of 1
lakh four thousand five hundred so the
final remaining balance is eight
thousand seven hundred
similarly the same formula has been
applied for the month of March and the
final balance we have is 37 300. so
that's how you implement budget template
in Excel all simple formulas and you
have all the numbers at your fingertips
so first let's understand what exactly
is Mis report in Excel
so Mis stands for management information
system Mis reports provide data on
different categories for accurate
decision making so Mis in Excel is a
procedure to create interactive report
using Microsoft Excel so Mis reports
help management to access the
performance of organization and allow
faster decision making so if you know to
create the Mis reports using various
business intelligence tools such as
Excel then you might find a very good
job opportunity in a well established
company now let us try to learn how to
create Mis report using Excel in a
practical mode so let's get back to the
Microsoft Excel IF getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so here you can see that I've got some
sales data of various car manufacturing
companies and I've also got some slices
so using these slicers I can get the
real-time information from the dashboard
so I'll select an ear from the first
slicer and I'll go into the second
slicer and I'll select a company now
I'll select BMW and SUV tag so we have
the data of all the SUV types
cars manufactured by BMW car
manufacturing company in the year 2018.
now let's start and create something
similar to this one
so how did I create this mis report
let's go through this in a step-by-step
way
so on my screen you can see that we have
created a completely new Excel workbook
and we have some sample data with five
rows and 20 columns
so this particular data is based on the
manufacturer and the car manufacturing
company and the type of the car
manufacturer and number of cars
manufactured in that particular year and
also the price of that particular car
Now to create a minus reports we need to
play around favor tables so we also have
tutorials on pivot tables and you can go
through that in our simply learn YouTube
channel and also we will try to link
those in the description box below
now let's select the entire data and go
into the insert ribbon and there you can
see the first option that is pivot table
so after selecting the pivot table
option it will show this particular
dialog box where it will ask you for the
range of cells you need to select and
the next one is to
create the pivot table in the same sheet
or a new sheet so we'll take a new sheet
here now select OK and there you go you
have the pivot table here so first you
have an empty pivot table and on the
right side you can see we have pivot
table Fields now you can either drag
these options into the rows and columns
or you can also click it so now let's
drag and drop these first we will select
here
and card
followed by that we will take type
quantity and price to columns
so there you go we have our pivot table
now
let's select all the data in the pivot
table
and again let's get back to the insert
option
and here you can see an option called
pivot chart select that and you will
have various favorite chart options here
now you can select any one which you can
prefer or which you like or whichever
you think can represent your data in a
best way possible so now let's go with
column chart first
let's select OK and we have our column
chart over here
now this happens to be our first chart
now let's create a few more chats so to
create few more charts we'll go back to
the same original data select again
insert and pivot table
now again a new worksheet
so here we have another empty pivot
table in the similar way let's drag the
same data into rows and columns
there you go and again we will select
all the data and create a pivot chart
go to insert option
favorite chat and now let's try to
select pie chart
select ok
and we have our pie chart over here
now let's try to create one more
same procedure select table select pivot
table then create new worksheet for the
new pivot table and now drag and drop
the data
now let's go to insert again
let's select all the data go to insert
option and pivot chat now let's try to
select the bar chart
select OK and there we have our bar
chart now
remember the first chart we created that
is in sheet 2 this one so we will try to
move all the charts to this particular
table or this particular worksheet
so let's get back to the sheet number
three right click and you can see an
option called pivot chart analyze so
from here you can move the chart select
the option of moving the chart and don't
select the first one select the object
in option and select the sheet number to
which you want to move this chat for now
we want to move this chart to sheet
number two select that press ok now we
have the chart moved to the sheet number
two
and in the same way let's go to the
sheet number four and let's move this
particular chart to sheet number two
there you go the chart got moved to
sheet number two
now you can insert the slices
so we have selected the third sheet or
third chart and inside the pivot chart
analyze option we have an option of
inserting the slicer now we will insert
the slices for here
car and
type
now select OK and you will have all the
three slices onto your sheet
now let's rearrange them
so I'm just organizing them in a
neat way
there you go
and you can also customize your designs
for all the charts
so that they look a little more better
now if you see
if I make some changes only one chart
will be interacting for this
right so if I select Ferrari and year
2020 and option as thoughts you can see
only one chart is interacting to these
particular slices why because all these
slices are connected to just one chart
here so you need to make sure that all
these slices are connected to all the
three charts what we created so let's
erase all the filters and select one
slicer at a time right click and you
will see an option of report connections
select that and you see that the
connections are only connected to the
pivot table 3. so select the remaining
pivot tables as well select OK and in
the same way select the second slicer
select the report connection option
connect pivot table 1 and 2 and select
OK and in the same way the third one
so now all the slices are connected to
all the pivot charts now if you make
some changes here they will respond
automatically in the same way
now let's select this code company the
year 2019 and hashback option and you
have all the cars which were made in the
year 2019 foreign Ford Company in the
segment of hatchback
so this was the sample data set that we
worked on now you can also work on some
complex data sets such as this Superstar
data set
now one thing you need to make sure that
when you're working with Excel Mis they
need to make sure that all the macros
are disabled on your data set and you
convert the entire data into the regular
table format of excel right now Excel is
considering this particular data as a
database so for that you need to select
all the data press Ctrl T and then
convert the entire data in the form of
tabular data and also don't forget to
click this icon which reads my table has
headers so the first row is the headers
now let's select OK and your entire data
will be converted into tabular form now
let's reset this to the normal
type which has the clear color not all
the fancy colors now the entire data is
converted from the dbms to the tablet
form and now he can start implementing
the Mis reporting pivot tables so that's
how you work on Mis report in Excel so
what is Excel macro you do certain daily
tasks and daily reports or monthly
reports that you generate and you use
data from your Excel and you scrub data
and you basically have the same things
performed or done on the Excel sheets
every time and every day or monthly or
bi-weekly or any number of times that
you open your Excel you remove certain
columns you add certain things and you
change certain values and these are the
things that you do and N number of times
on an Excel and this can all be done by
simple automated wave which is macros so
what it does is it is a set of tasks
that you can execute as many number of
times as you want
when you create a macro basically what
it does is it will record all your mouse
clicks and keystrokes basically if for
example you have your monthly accounts
report that is there and it comes every
day and you have to put it in extract
certain data and remove certain columns
that you do every time that you open
that sheet for instance you remove that
column I which has the absolute values
of your of your accounts or the sheets
that you have and you remove that column
and you edit some names you add such
things every time that you open that
report and then you format it in a
proper way and send it to your
management so this can all be done
in a simple running script called macros
so what you do is you record those
Mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically a
set of codes or task that you can
execute and automate and it can be done
n number of times so it makes your life
easy now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your Excel it's a
simple tab that you need to add in the
ribbon section which I'll be showing you
across and this will enable the macros
on your Excel so you go to files
good options
and then you need to customize the
ribbon click customize ribbon
and then there is a developer tab which
you see here it should be activated so
you just need to select that
click on the tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macros now you you
have your data and you can run macros or
record a macro and run it all on your
Excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon customize ribbon and
you can add or remove your Macros from
here so this is two ways that you need
to that you can activate uh your Macros
so how you record a macro is the next
thing
so here I have a work orders sheet that
I receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and how you record a
macro you have certain set of tasks that
you do and you know this report has so
many things that are obsolete which you
do not need which has to be put across
to your management or your for your use
so how you record or start a macro you
go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro as soon as you click
on this record macro button it will
start recording your keystrokes on the
mouse mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do so
this is the sheet that I have and we'll
try to run a macros on this and see what
it does
so here I have and
this actually works this way uh I need
to go to the developer tab and start
recording the macro so when I click
record macro it starts uh recording my
mouse clicks and keystrokes so in this
sheet I have to you know remove some
columns and the columns that are
obsolete in the data that looks weird
here should be removed and all what I
need is the work order number the
district and the tactician name and the
kind of service that we provide and the
requested workday the cost
and the payment so this is what I want
and I do it every day when I receive the
sheet and I have to make these changes
and send it across to the accounts team
so what I do is I simply automate this
by running a macro
so I go to
let's see how it records the macro
if I click record macro I save it as
work order
accounts and I'll add a little
description like
work order
counts deep
cost
click ok
and
see what I do is basically I add the
borders first
so that the data looks proper and then I
do not want this column I delete it I do
not want the number of technicians that
are there I do not want all these and I
also want the labor as the account and
what kind of payment this is very
crucial for the accounts team I do not
want any of these obsolete data
so I just delete this
okay
and then I just want to have some
cosmetic changes done so
and make sure this doesn't have any
border
and that's it this is the task that I
prefer
every day I still don't need it
and I go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now I have the macro
save and when I have it I have you know
automated these all these steps in one
simple click and how I execute it in
another sheet so I will show it across
to you
the next thing so here I have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and sent it across so I simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab and go to the macro and I
have this macro Save which we ran the
just now and I simply with a single
click I will be able to do these daily
tasks and execute in a Flash so I just
click run and it does the rest for me I
have my report ready and is in a proper
format that is required and it can be
sent across so here as we see it is done
in a single click by running a simple
macro continuing our uh to work on macro
we can simply do this by a single click
of a button by adding a button so what
you have to do is go to the developer
tab and in the control section you will
see the insert option
when you click on the insert drop down
you will see a form controls and you can
say select a button and here I select a
button and the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro and when I just
assign that macro to this button I can
edit the text by
making it as a work order accounts just
to make it simple okay
and now if you see if I just click this
button it will run the macro
and format RC
So This Is How We Run The macros in
single click of button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros or you can record
and you can edit your macro so when I
click view macros it will show you what
are the macros that I have and that I
can run and you can simply run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as well instead of from the developer
tab if you just click on record macro it
will do the same functions that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have to use a
simple application in Excel which is the
VBA Visual Basic application to edit
your macro you go to the developer tab
and then click on Visual Basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on and you
can edit the
macro here so as we see if you go back
to the Excel
we see that every sheet we have been
working on this heat and it has the
column still K and the actual sheet is
this so if I go to the Visual Basic
editor
and I'll make sure the node I remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m
and I just delete that and I click run
I go back to my sheet and you see these
changes are not there okay
this is your old macro and this is our
new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority of my orders so
these are the things that we can edit
with the VBA
so here we are what is VBA Visual Basic
application it is basically a Visual
Basic application language uh that is
used for macros in Excel
so what it basically does Visual Basic
for application is a programming
language if Excel that helps you
automate task by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily task by running a
simple macro now to help us you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our abilities to
is our work and automate our task we use
VBA
so why we be there are many advantages
of using VBA and why we prefer VBA in
macros for excel
so basically it is a very simple
language it saves time in performing
tedious tasks you have number of tasks
that you do every day as we have seen in
the previous section how we we can
simplify your daily task by just running
a simple macro and this VBA helps us in
performing those tasks in a very simple
manner another thing is it supports
english-like statements there are
multiple statements that you can use and
which are very basic English language
statements and this can help us or it is
very easy to program our code or edit
these commands you can select a range
you can it is like a if an else
statement and things like that we will
look into those in details in the next
sections now one more thing is it
improves the functionality of excel by
allowing you to make Excel behave the
way you want there are multiple
functions that you perform in Excel like
selecting a number of rows or columns or
selecting a set of cells in particular
you do it on a daily basis so these
things can easily be performed and
easily be edited and executed by using
VBA we will look into those in detail
now what is the BBA editor interface
this is particularly uh
an interface which you will have look in
detail
where where you can edit your commands
or your codes for your Excel now how
this is achieved we will see it here now
these are the this is basically the VBA
editor interface where you can see the
uh this is the toolbar section where it
shows all the options wherein undo or
save or file they will see those details
in the next section this is basically
the toolbar section of the VBA editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important menu
bar option and when you can insert
different modules and buttons and all
we'll look into those in details run is
one more important thing all these
things fall under menu bar the next
thing is the VBA code window maybe a
code window as it says is the code
window where your actual code resides
wherein you can go into it and edit the
code or write the codes and select the
different range of functions that you
can perform and this is basically the
bdb VBA code window where you edit your
or write your codes
the next thing is the project Explorer
project Explorer is simply like a
Windows Explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your VBA
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the of the Excel sheets
or the worksheets that you're working on
or the modules that you have saved and
so on basically it is an Explorer for
your PBA like a Windows Explorer which
is for the file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties Windows shows you the
properties of the worksheet that you're
working on for instance here we are
working on the sheet 2 and it shows the
properties what are the kind of uh
worksheet that we have the page break
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that the next thing is the immediate
window and the watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window where then you can run and
execute simple lines of course
individual Excel code that you can run
it will allow you to test individual
lines
which is very useful and handy when you
are writing and debugging course uh the
output if the lines that you execute can
be seen here in the immediate window
whereas watch Window watch window is
similar to it but it displays the value
of the watch expression in its current
current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the VBA code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the you the advantages of
having a watch window in your VBA
interface
so these are the things that we learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
Visual Basic for application for macros
and I'm going to show you how to you
know run some codes and run some macros
in the codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the VBA for macros so there are
two ways to open the Visual Basic
application and the first thing is you
can run alt f11 click on the sheet and
then just press and it will open the
Visual Basic for application window or
alternatively you can just go and click
on the Visual Basic I need to open the
sheet for you I'm in the code window for
you and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window and this is the
project Explorer
and this is the immediate window I will
you can run some testing course
immediately it will show you the uh code
so here we see the project Explorer
window where we see the modules and all
for our Visual Basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see how
the code develops okay so I just go here
and click record macro
and I save it as a format
and columns
[Music]
this workbook and I just save it click
OK and it has started recording so now
what I'll do is as make it simple and I
just delete some columns here
okay I do not need this
I delete this is there a wait I want
this I want the amount of payment parts
cost labor hours I do not want this
number of technicians forget it
okay
and I go for the left and see what all
do I need I need I don't need this
I delete all these and
I just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then I want to change the format I
mean the hot
so I select this
[Music]
and I change it to timestrom
okay
I'm going to go back to my developer tab
click stop recording it is saved
okay
now go back to my code
and see the
macro here so we see the macro here and
we can see the in detail what it looks
like so we see the code what it's doing
and what the macro run has generated the
codebook so we see we have basically the
name of the macro is format columns and
what it is doing we're just selecting
The Columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee select that is the E
column that we have selected and then
again so on and the next thing is the
font selection that is mentioned we are
changing it to Times New Roman size is
11 so it is basically
a basic VBA code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with m sub so this
is the code or a format of the VBA code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
will be and discuss this in further
details so for ease of explanation I
have picked up a blank spreadsheet and
I'll try to explain some basic
functions and the commands and the codes
that we use to accomplish the tasks that
we with VBA
so as we see this is the blank sheet and
I have selected a new module for it
so here I start the code and as you see
is it starts with sub and I am
specifying the
module name as number so I'll just try
to make it quite simple and
you know so we it is as soon as we enter
the sub it sends with the end sub and so
this is the start of the code and this
is the end of the code and whatever is
there should be here and this is the
name of the code of the macro now uh
I'll explain it further about the game
statement why is it used and what does
it use for so dim is basically a keyword
which is the a short form of Dimension
and it is used to declare a variables in
the VBA so here I am trying to specify
uh
a variable called X and how I'm going to
do it I will as it have it as a number
or an integer or anything so here in
this example I'll put it as an integer
or a number okay and as I put as it
populates the prompt so I select integer
and for example I select the number to
be
500. okay
and here I'm trying to assign a variable
integer a cell a value of 500 with a
limb keyword so where exactly I want to
put this you will see it when you
execute the code okay range I am
selecting it should be on the course
where I'm going to put the value of x as
and I close the bracket and what should
be the value
we will
value should be X
so now as I click runs up
or you can do it with the by running the
alt F5 key and it will run the
cool so you see here in the Excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell B5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do with the dimension
keyboard or dim keyword and you can
assign the value as integers now proceed
we proceed further with certain or
example some more examples and how we
assign the string value as a as a text
or
something else okay
now I'm going to show you what dim can
be execute I mean used as to set
variables then can be used as a
double when double is basically a longer
form of single variable it usually takes
more space but uses needs more larger
numbers okay and then you can set
double and I just don't specify it and
we can use state it basically stores the
date values okay and then again string
so what string does if you use string it
stores the text it can contain numbers
it will have some text as calculations
or anything can be performed so these
are the basic thing that I will cover
and
you can also use different uh values for
it so I will discuss this in the next
example
okay
so in the next example I'll try to
use a string value for it and
value
[Music]
this is my name so as soon as I hit
enter it ends with the answer prompt and
now I think I get my code so I put a
stream book it has
three
okay now
I'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value of a
country to one of the cells so let's see
how it goes and I select country and in
country I select Mac
[Music]
okay now what is the value or the cell
that basically takes the or we will put
the name of the country as so I have to
specify a range and as soon as I hit it
goes and I have to specify the
the cell here so here I put it as G
and 4 okay
so I close it
and I put a value what value I am going
to assign it is a country
okay
try to run this code right
see G4 the name populates as
a country here so this is a dim keyword
is being used as a string in our VBA
code so
we can also use
VBA to you know pop up a message or an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be uh
executed using a
code here which I am going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
foreign
keyword I'm going to use the keyword as
double
y double is used is basically uh it
gives a longer it can be used for a
longer form of single variable ticks it
usually takes more space and larger
numbers and we'll try to assign it okay
now I'm going to pop up a message in
that which says value of a is so and so
so I'm going to give value of a as
two five zero okay and how I it pops up
a message okay so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value I mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and you want you can
enter the text and you can edit so here
I'm going to
write a code which you know which gives
a pop-up message a message box saying
that the value of a is signed so
the value of a a
I'm going to put it in percent code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay now that's it and let's try to run
this and you will see a message for
popping message box popping up
okay so the value of e is the message
box pops up saying the value of a is
250. so
in the next example I am going to write
a code wherein you know you can give a
value or a string you can assign it to a
selected cell and this basically used
when you have some you know when you
have a task of you know giving a value
to a particular cell or you have to
assign a text or say something about a
report okay so this let's see how it
goes and we use the
I will say it as
and with some procedures
the name
again name
so here I am giving to I am going to
give a user input and it will be as a
string okay you can give an email I mean
any string or any statement what my user
input will be I will Define it here
[Music]
this is the report for
Abu let's make it simple
okay and where I'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell that I
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
I have defined user input as this is a
report for VBA so this cell turns into
you this is a report for VBA
I run this and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and you know it makes life quite simple
when you use VBA for this as we have
seen before we have used message box now
I'm going to use the same message box
to display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes I'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your name
and I'm going to put it under course
that my name is
and we'll try to run it
see here
so it pops up a message saying that my
name is it fun so this is a message box
that you can display and I can do
anything with this uh
this is a PBA okay
[Music]
okay I run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an Excel sheet or try to run a
Workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or you know Define a
report or kind of data in it and this
can be used using uh run using the
message box
and now I have another good example
wherein you know you can write a code to
tell Excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so here it is
I'll put it as sub
okay
and
it will again populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
the entered
value
is
and it should tell me
which or I specify which cell it is that
we are going to find the value of okay
so I gave a range
of
I have to give it in codes
I'm going to
go to computer
and it should tell me the value
of the number that is present in the
cell
A1
okay
friends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use Excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
I can change it to
a
as well and try to run it and it will
give me the number so this is simple way
of you know populating a message box
which will tell us the
value of a uh let me show you one more
simple example where in a message box
pops up or a welcome message that can be
power set when you open the Excel or
worksheet so
so let's uh name it as Auto
open
and then again message box I wanted to
populate and what does it say
I put it in quotes welcome
hour
oh she
she
it's very simple you just run it and
see it pops up a message saying it
welcome to a workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or do simple
welcome message on Excel
next I'm going to show you a code
wherein you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
curve
so we name it as add value
now I specify the range I mean where I'm
going to specify a cell
where the value will be given to the
cell
now I'm going to give it as B5
okay to put it as curves close the
parenthesis
what is the value that I'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0. okay so now with this code I mean
I'm going to assign a value of 250 to
the cell B5 let's see
run it see
again I do it to E10
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now I can run the same thing and give a
range of cells I mean okay let me make
it very simple here
I give it as a B1
through b
as
four five zero so let's see what it does
see here I'm going I'm specifying the
range to be B1 through B5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay in the
and then I can give another set of range
here
like let me specify it
means to be
[Music]
c one
to give it a course
[Music]
C4
and I separate it with a comma and I can
specify another range so the next one
will be D1 to D4
and then I close the codes close the
parenthesis now what is the value that I
give is
let's say
two three zero
and I try to run it
so it gives the value of c 1 through C4
and D1 through D4 as 230 has been
specified in the code
so this is one of one more example
bearing you can assign values to the
uh so range of cells or cells and with
the VBA
one more thing I can you know assign a
value to a particular cell by specifying
these cells it's a very simple just
specify the cells like
oh six
seven
and I close the parenthesis I assign a
value to it value equals
10. let's see
see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
Root 6
and column set
okay so this is one more example wherein
you can assign values to particular
cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario wherein you need to select
a
range of cells in the sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using BPA so I will show you
how this is our let's say select
range
okay and
and I am going to set a dim variable as
a example
let's say it has example and um what I'm
doing is I'm specific range design to
select a range of its cells okay now I'm
going to set the variable as
set example where I am going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected so let's say a one
to D
okay this will be the selection
and what I'm going to
set the value okay I am going to set a
value
example
I'm going to give it a value of
256 so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here I'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and I'm going to
assign a value with this function so
this makes it quite simple and this will
be used in a regular daily task wherein
you know there is there will be a
scenario where you have to select a set
of cells and give a give a value to it
so you can do it with the click of a
button with a VPN
now I can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so there is
I'll remove this
and instead of assigning a value I'll
just
select
it now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it
and then it's it becomes easier for you
to copy paste and do some functions so
you can select this and you can assign a
value and you can also give a set of
values to a particular range or cells
with these codes
now what if I want to do a selection of
the same rows and columns in the next
sheet and I can do this with the
set of another set of commands so I will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing and we specify the worksheets
okay the worksheets
I want it in sheet 2 okay so I just put
it as sheet and I activate it basically
activating it and now I am going to
specify the worksheet
2 and what is the range that I am going
to select the same thing okay
A1
to
D Phi
okay
what I'm going to do I am going to
select it
okay and see what happens here
okay okay
so here I am selecting the worksheet too
and I'm activating it and I'm going to
assign range and I'm going to select it
so I can just copy the same or select
the same set of cells in the next sheet
okay now when there will be I as I said
there will be a you know by requirement
where you need to copy some cell
contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that it's uh
again a simple code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a copy and paste I'm
just making it simple by giving
something that we can understand and
relate
copy
okay so what I'm going to do is I am
going to select this range and I'm going
to copy it and paste it somewhere here
okay so let me just remove this
and actually first we have to specify
the range where you want to copy the
cells okay so let's say it is again A1
it should be in codes D5
[Music]
of course
and I am going to select it okay
then what I'm going to do is uh once you
select this the selection that you have
should what should be the function and I
am going to specify the selection and
the function should be copying it
okay so I just said that and where I'm
going to paste it so I have to now
specify the range where I have to paste
this selection and you can just mention
the
column here let's say G
uh
10.
okay
close it
I'm going to select it and then where
I'm going to paste it I can do it in
this sheet okay active sheet
everything
and paste it so we are selecting a range
of cells selection and that selection
what we are doing is we will copy it and
now we are going to specify the range
where you are going to
select it and then paste it
quite simple let's
okay see and
you can just change it to so it is
visible on this
okay
so this makes uh quite easy and you can
run it
uh the next scenario will be like
when you need to get the count of the
number of cells like you have to have a
selection and you need to count the
number of cells so this can also be done
and it's quite easy
I am going to show it to you
let's say the summary account
search
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you are using it and
I'm going to set a variable let's say
I'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay because we
will specify the range of
the cells that we are going to that we
need to count basically so I'm going to
set a variable as a range and then
what we are going to do is
specify
just by the range or your selection
where you will count the where you need
the count of the number of cells so even
if the high hopes
now how you want the output you want it
you want a message box to pop up
so you will set a message box
and
what should it give it will give you the
count of the variable that is the
variable is here is examples Okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this area
okay let's see it says
okay here I think and list it so I just
specify the number here and let's see so
it gives you the number of
found in this 20 okay
now let's see I'm going to
do six
so it gives you the selection so it's
quite simple it will be very useful in
our daily task and wherein you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it
uh well I can further tweak this and to
determine the uh the county number of
rows or columns so it's again very
simple I just need to do some changes
here I have to set the
column count
so if I want to
calculate the number of columns
just
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message the number of columns
yet
see it gives there are five columns okay
one two
one two three four five okay so it gives
us the number of columns here if I
change it to
should give me
four four
okay similarly you can count the number
of rows here
just change
chain three this is six rows are there
okay
see
so this way you can calculate the number
of count the number of cells number of
columns number of rows
with this
the next thing I'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the most widely used statement and
one whoever is in programming are very
much familiar with this function so what
it does is we specify a condition if a
condition is met then the outshoot
output should be such and such we can
specify the condition and it will check
whether that condition is there and if
it is
space and easy if it is achieved then
you will have to specify the output as
well so this can be achieved with the if
statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understands the basic uh English
language so it's not very complicated
and I'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition and if
that condition is met then the result
you specify the condition and the result
board okay so this is one thing and then
you can specify the s or else condition
where you know you specify the condition
two then the result should be
this
so here you are going to specify two
conditions or multiple conditions where
you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or Maps
and you have to select the result you
can do this manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
I have it here
let's
go and
I specify as
if statement
okay now I have to specify the variables
now I have to wear variables I have a
score and I have a result and the score
is an integer the number and the result
is a string pass of a so I specify this
okay dim
score
as specified as integer okay
and then there's another variable that I
have to set result
as
string
okay
now what the score will be the score I
have to specify the range
score I am giving it as a range I mean
it's in my
cell A1
okay
I specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
should be alert
and then I'm specifying a condition here
if
score value the variable
is greater than or equal so as I said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
English language functions available
then
the result result is another variable
that I have said result what it should
be it should be
in codes
okay so if this condition is met then
the result will be this okay
and now where I want to specify my
result I should give a range for that
so I give it in the next column or any
one
this is the basic example
value should be the result
okay let's see how it runs
see
says press
change to 40.
it doesn't give me anything because I
have specified only one condition here
okay
75 let's see how it shows
see so this way it's very basic
condition that you are specifying you
are specifying two variables the score
and the result and then you are giving a
value for it and you are specifically
condition if the score is greater than
then the result should be passed
now in the next uh section uh we will
simply tweak this and use an if then
else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition and see so here again
we'll use two variables that is the
score as integer and the result as a
string and let's stick to the same
values
and now
um I'm going to specify it and if the
score is greater than 60
then the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before and then
I'm going to specify another condition
here else
the result should be
it should be okay
thank you
okay
and now I have to go to laser and if
statement I have to specify the answer
and the result will be again in the
value I mean the range will be V1 so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is passed otherwise it is fail
okay it is pass let's see 40 and
run it again
foreign
two variables again we are giving it a
range and we are specifying one
condition if this condition is met the
result is passed otherwise else it is
fail
so another set of example
the next statement that we use or we are
going to discuss is the Loop statement
that is the for Loop statement and why
we use it there are there are situations
and tasks that you need to execute and
you need to do it several number of
times
these are basically executed
sequentially it means one after another
so the first treatment or the function
is executed and the next is taken up so
and then the next and so on so these
Loop statements allow us to execute a
statement or a group of statements
multiple number of times many number of
times and this happens only when the
first task or the first task is done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we will discuss a
simple example of the for Loop statement
so let's see how it
works and I'm going to set up a
Loop statement okay again the I'm going
to make it as Loop one so here it is I
have to specify the
variable that is dim
and I'm going to specify X as an integer
okay I'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it
executes okay for x equals to 1 2
very cool okay let's see
and I'm going to specify the range
as so what I'm going to do is basically
I'm going to fill the column A from 1 to
24 with some value from 1 to 24 with the
values of 1 through 24 okay
so I'm setting up a range
and How It Ends is it gives me a value
foreign
so we are setting up a loop we are
setting up a an integer a variable X as
integer and we are setting the value of
x to be 1 to 24 so here for 1 it
executes the first thing is it it takes
X as 1 and it fills in A1
and then the next value of x will be 2
and it goes to A2 and fills the value as
2 so just let's try to execute this and
you will see the
row column A filled with 1 through 24.
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as X
and the number of values is going to be
24. okay so this is one basic example of
a per Loop statement
now let's do some more addition to this
uh
example by you know executing another
sector for Loop and giving the output
and we'll code the output to be the
color code advance in the column B so
how we do it it's a basic simple example
that I'm going to take and again what
I'm going to do is I will have this
values here and I am going to convert
the
V column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see in
what I'm going to do is I'm only going
to change the B
and what action is going here we put a
value now we are going to select it and
with this selection
what I'm going to do is it should select
it and it should color the interior with
what
foreign
X
and then I'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the
box to be color and I'm going to put it
as a solid
it will fill the whole thing with the
solid
and then I just execute it see
it takes this
color B
and it's coded like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for Loop statements so there
are numerous examples and exercises that
we can perform tasks we can perform with
the PBA and this can be found in detail
next courses Advanced courses now what
is regression so when you talk about
statistical modeling regression analysis
is used to estimate the relationship
between two or more variables and
basically we would want to look at two
or more variables and basically a
relationship of those variables with the
response or the Target right so for
example if we look at our data here we
have temperature we have price of ice
cream and then we have units sold and we
can go ahead and make predictions so for
example when you look at regression here
you see something like this which is
regression statistics you have Anova you
have different plots which we have here
which is X variable X variable 2 and
then you have normal probability plot
now we have already seen how you can
have your add-in that is data data
analysis which helps you in doing
different kind of data analysis here
right now how do we do this so we have
our variables here which is temperature
price of ice cream units sold and when
we talk about regression we need to
understand which one of these are
independent variables which one of these
are dependent variables right so when
you talk about your X that's your
independent variable or we can say
predictor or explanatory so when you
talk about your independent variables or
as we say predictors or explanatory
variables these are the factors that
might influence the dependent variable
and when you talk about dependent
variable that's your response or Target
that's the main factor you are trying to
understand or predict so we can plot a
scatter plot to see relationship between
variables if they are linearly related
are they positively related negatively
related and so on we can also get values
such as R square which is coefficient of
determination regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so here is one of the links of
one of my edit other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
Spark
now here let's see how do we do this in
Excel so basically we would want to use
our variables which is temperature price
of ice cream units sold and then get
these plots so what we can do is for
example I can get rid of this and might
be I can just say
no borders and when it comes to these
plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal using your data analysis
add-in tool so we have been given
variables here now as I said when we
talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have multiple variables right so
you might have heard of univariate
analysis by variate analysis and so on
well
here we are focusing more on using Excel
to do our regression analysis so I'll
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things as Basics should be known
that when we talk about regression
analysis what does it do it helps you
understand how the dependent variable
changes when one or more independent
variables vary and it basically allows
us to mathematically determine which of
those variables really has an impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so mainly the
goal of the model is to get the smallest
possible sum of squares and draw a line
that comes closest to the data so that's
what we mean by our regression line or
basically looking at the points and
seeing if the points fall on a
regression line if there are residuals
that is points which do not fall on the
regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about
statistics we differentiate between a
simple and multiple linear regression so
you have something called a simple
linear regression models which basically
gives you the relationship between
dependent variable and one independent
variable using a linear function and if
you use two or more variables that is
explanatory variables to predict the
dependent variable we are actually
dealing with multiple linear regression
so if the dependent variable is modeled
as a non-linear function because the
data relationships do not follow a
straight line we have to use non-linear
regression
now what we will do is we'll see how we
can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this might
be based on temperature price of ice
cream we would want to find out how many
units were sold now what we can do is we
can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
Excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert you can then choose the
kind of plots which you want and here
you have insert scatter plot so we can
choose this and you can choose the first
option so that gives you a blank layout
and what you can do is now you need to
select data so for example let's click
on select data and then you can say add
so what we would want is we can give a
name so we want X values and we want our
y values right so when you talk about y
That's your dependent variable or your
response or Target so that is in our
case units sold and X values are 1
set of features or variables or multiple
variables so here I can click on this
series X values and then I can select
this
now in y values what I can do is I can
select these and then I can just say
Okay so that shows me that it would be
giving me a regression scatter plot now
let's say okay and we have some points
plotted here now if you would want to
see the impact of one individual
variable such as temperature or price of
ice cream you could as well do that now
what you can also do is you can add more
meaning to this by giving in a title or
you can also go into Quick layout and
you have various options here so you see
it gives you what is the access title
what is the series and I would prefer to
use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your R square and that gives you
your Y and X that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change the chart title to something else
say scatter plot of uh dependent
uh West independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning and we can get
rid of this one so we have series and we
can say what are these points if you
would want to add in Legend if you would
want to do that or I can just get rid of
this and I will keep these values here
which we will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always compare these values so here I've
created a simple scatter plot
and then I can look at dependent West
independent variables
or I could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis so
basically you can hear
say for example just say Y and might be
here I will say x and we can rename that
later now how do we perform data
analysis or get into regression right
now what we would want to do is
we would want to get or we would want to
do the regression analysis to
demonstrate the relationship between
dependent and independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation you might have known
about it so it is basically why when you
say y
equals you can say BX plus a plus c and
this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression where X is your independent
variable Y is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected mean value of y when
all X variables are equal to 0 so
basically on a regression graph that's
the point where line crosses the y axis
and that's your intercept
when you talk about B that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as X changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your uh
sorry that's basically your random error
term right which is basically the
difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise right now what we can
do is we can also reduce this
equation to Y is B X plus a and that's
the equation of a line we can look into
this and the linear equation can be
understood mathematically in this way
now how do we do it in Excel so what we
can simply do is
here let me
yeah
so we need to get into data and then
here we have our data analysis add in
you can click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression so that's what we would want
to do now we'll say okay now here you
need to give your input y range so as I
said you will have to select the
dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your X and Y so y being your target
that's basically your unit sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to X either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so I
will select temperature price of ice
cream and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels right now
we can always look at the confidence
level we can change that so you can say
whether you want it in a new worksheet
or you can just say output range and I
will probably just click here and select
one of the cell here now we can also
choose the other options which we would
want to see as a part of this regression
analysis so basically we have selected
input y range which is your dependent
variable you have selected X range which
is your independent variable and if we
are building a multi regression model
then we
have chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range which is basically on this sheet
and then we can select the residuals so
that basically gives you your residuals
now we can also get your line fit plots
which you were seeing earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots and then basically
just say okay
and let's say okay and that basically
gives you your regression analysis
output so we
basically have your summary output we
also have Anova we have our serial
output that's from the previous one and
basically we can get rid of this that's
not required
I can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have our plots so we
can basically look into these so we have
our normal
let's get rid of these
get rid of this let's get rid of this
and then what we can do is since we had
some existing data it has overwritten so
let me get rid of this and I'll repeat
this step again
and let's say no water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do a reaction analysis so we go get into
Data we get into Data analysis we choose
regression
we have already chosen our y range which
is column c x range is multiple
variables we have gone for labels output
range which we would want to select a
particular cell so let me select this I
am going for a serials line fit plots a
normal probability plots and say okay
so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature here the variable is price
of ice cream right so that's your one
variable and second variable and then
you also have your normal probability
plot now to interpret this or to
understand what we have here where we
look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what Excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
Excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at multiple r value here and we
can
let's also fine tune this one
yeah we have our values here and if you
see we have our R square now we can then
basically look at our multiple R so what
is your multiple R that's your
correlation coefficient which basically
measures the strength of linear
relationship between two variables so
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient it can be any value between
minus 1 and 1 and its absolute value
indicates the relationship strength
so the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so 1 basically
means a strong positive relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and zero means no
relationship at all now when you are
looking at R square that is the
coefficient of determination which is
used as an indicator of the goodness of
the fit so it basically shows how many
points fall on the regression line so
your R square value is basically
calculated from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now when we talk about looking at the
value of your R square so it is
basically we can be seeing that this is
0.450788 that's the value which I am
talking about so it basically means 45
percent of our values fit the regression
analysis model so in other words 45
percent of dependent variables that is
your y values are explained by the
independent variables that is your X
values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit and here we have considered multiple
variables now when you talk about your
adjusted R square it is the R square
adjustment for the number of independent
variables in the model so uh you would
want to use this value instead of R
square for multiple regression analysis
such as in our case
now you also have standard error so
that's basically goodness of fit measure
that basically shows the Precision of
your regression analysis so the smaller
the value the more certain you can be
about your regression equation so when
when we talk about your R square that
represents the percentage of dependent
variables variance that is explained by
the model and standard error is
basically an absolute measure that shows
the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into regression statistics
terminologies to basically understand
more of this and if you're already from
data science background that then you
already know what I'm talking about we
are just seeing how Excel easily helps
us in doing these things now we can also
look at observations here which is
basically the number of observations in
our model which is seven
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your Anova values here
so we basically see DF you have s s m s
f and significance F now to understand
these so basically what we are doing is
or what Excel is doing is it splits the
sum of squares into individual
components that give information about
the levels of variability within your
regression model so when you talk about
your DF that's basically the number of
degrees of freedom associated with the
source of variance you have sum of
squares that is your SS so smaller the
residual SS compared with the total SS
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about Ms that's
your mean Square you have f is basically
the F statistic or you can say uh f-test
for the null hypothesis basically it is
used to test the overall significance of
the model and then you finally have your
significance f which is the P value of f
so uh when we when we usually talk about
simple linear regression the in Anova
part is not really used or it's rarely
used right but when we look at the
significance F value that gives an idea
of how reliably or statistically
significant our results are so if
significance f is less than 0.05 that's
5 percent our model is okay if it is
greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at so you basically have
your intercept here so when you talk
about your intercept temperature price
of ice cream so we know we are looking
at our variables and then we are also
locate looking at our intercept which
basically gives you
more details on your coefficients so the
the main important thing when we talk
about regression analysis is basically
your coefficients it basically enables
you to build a linear regression
equation uh in the form of y equals BX
plus a which I explained earlier and
then basically we can understand our
regression analysis output better now
when we look at the residual output
which we are seeing here so that gives
you your observations how many
observations we have it shows what is
the predicted unit sold and then it also
gives you your residuals so we can
compare the estimated and actual number
of sold umbrellas based on the
observation so we have
11.209 here and if you compare that's
basically 12 the second one is 15 and
here it is 13.5
you'll have and similarly you can
compare all the values of actual units
sold and what our regression has
predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these and
we will see if there is any difference
or no
right so obviously there will be or
there would be some difference because
independent variables are never perfect
predictors of your dependent variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values so that's what we see
here in the residual section so for
example when we look at this one which
is 11.209 and the actual is 12 we see
what is the residual and how far is the
predicted value from the actual value
so similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our graphs
so we have basically our variables we
are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically uh add in
more details to this particular plot and
you also have normal probability plot
which is basically getting your values
from your probability output here so
this is how you can perform a simple
regression analysis and now what you can
do is you can as I said you can
basically be looking at your scatter
plot you can be looking at your y and x
and your R square values right but
remember what are the variables which
you are selecting and then you can
compare these with basically the values
what you see here so remember here I've
chosen my both set of variables and you
can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target
so it's pretty simple here you can add
more details to your scatter plot or the
plots what we have created or Some
people prefer to do it using formulas so
basically we have some statistical
functions that can help you do linear
regression analysis such as you have
Linux you have slope you have intercept
you have correlation and so on so
basically you can use these particular
functions and what you will have to do
is
you will have to basically go in for a
function if that's what you would want
to do and then you can search for
functions and say for example I'll just
say lynnest and say go and here I have
my function so if I would want to really
use this one I can do that what I will
have to do is then select the variable
so if you just say okay and that
basically says your known y's known X
your constants your stats and basically
you can use the formula also but we are
not covering that here might be in the
later videos we can do that so just try
out and perform some regression analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of Performing regression
analysis using your data analysis add-in
in Excel power query is an advanced
feature of Microsoft Excel that allows
you to prepare your data for analysis
you can perform numerous text
computations and numerical analysis to
make your data more powerful and
informative Excel power query is a data
preparation and transformation engine
it allows you to carry out the extract
transform and load operations on the
data sets from multiple sources
now
let's look at the challenges solved by
power query
earlier in Excel there was difficulty in
data connections Now using power query
you can connect to a broad range of data
sources such as relational databases web
files text CSV Json files and even fetch
data in the cloud volume variety and
velocity are the characteristics that
define Big Data it was a major problem
to handle such data
Now power query enables you to transform
your data to an appropriate size it also
allows you to work on any shape of data
from any source
earlier updating your data and
refreshing it in real time was an issue
using power query reputable process
query is adopted to update the data in
real time and in the future
in Excel it was not so easy to reshape
transform and manipulate data but using
power query provides a highly
interactive experience and sophisticated
tools to prepare your data now
from Excel 2016 onwards power query on
Windows has been fully integrated into
Excel but in Excel 2010 and 2013 for
windows power query is a free add-in
you can go ahead and download the link
once installed the power query tab will
be visible in the Excel ribbon now
coming to the features of power query so
Excel power query allows you to clean
transform manipulate and process your
data for analysis it helps you to
automate repetitive tasks that you want
to do it over and over again you can
search for data sources and make
connections as and when you want Power
query helps you to prepare and shape the
data in the right format for performing
analysis
and finally once your data is ready you
can share your findings or use your
query to create interactive reports and
dashboards
now let's have a glance at the demo that
we are going to work on in this video
so we look at how to load data from
different sources
you will understand how to extract
tables from web files so we'll extract
tables present on Wikipedia Pages then
you learn how to sort and filter data
up next you'll see how to group your
data how to split a column into multiple
columns
and then pivot and unpivote your table
then you're going to work on date
columns and make some transformations
understand how to append tables and
merge tables vertically and horizontally
now let's open MS Excel and start with
importing a simple text file so you can
see here I have my Excel file opened and
in the middle you can see I have my
employee txt file
now this is a comma separated file
meaning that the values are separated by
commas as you can see it here
The Columns have been separated by
commas and all the values have a comma
between them
now this text file has information about
the name each company and the city to
which the employee belongs to
let's see how easily you can import this
EMP text file into Ms Excel
here I'm using
Excel 365 or Office 365 where power
query on Windows has been fully
integrated into this version of excel
so what I'll do is first
let's go to the data Tab and
you have this section called get and
transform data so I'll click on get data
under get data I'll go to from file
and select from Text slash CSV
once I click on it it will ask me to
give the location where the file is
there
so my file is on desktop I'll click on
power query files and here you can see I
have my employee txt file you can see
the type here it says text document
click on EMP
and hit import
now this will take some time to import
the file onto Excel
it's establishing a connection you can
see there you go so here you can see the
file name emp.txt you can see the file
origin as I said the delimiter is comma
and we have the data type detection and
here you can see
we have a text file so Excel power query
feature has automatically detected the
column names so we have name age company
and city as our columns and these are
the values
now let's hit load
so this will load all the rows and the
columns onto Excel
there you go it was really quick
Excel has automatically loaded our text
file
now you can see here we have another tab
called queries and connections so we
have made one query and have loaded the
employee data
it gives a preview also you can see it
here
and if needed later you can go to edit
and change some values that we'll see
later
now you can use this data to create
simple visualizations
so let me show you how to do it so let's
first select the data and we'll go to
the insert tab under insert tab I'll
click on recommended charts
let's say I want to know how many
employees belong to a particular City
so I'll click on the second chart which
says the count of Name by City And I'll
click on OK
here you can see
we have a nice clustered bar chart and
you can see in Bangalore there were five
employees in Hyderabad we had two and in
nashik we had one you can see the count
here this is a pivot table
if you go back to our actual data here
you can see
in Bangalore we had Vidya Sonam Avinash
this Varun and himani
and there were two more people from
Hyderabad and one from nasik
so you can use the Excel power query
feature to import data onto Excel and
make some visualizations
now if you want to fetch some data that
is present on the web or on the Internet
Excel power query features and
functionalities can help you import
those data as well
we will now see how to import data
specifically a table that is present on
the web
here I'll be using a Wikipedia article
on the list of European Cup and UEFA
Champions League finals let me show you
the page first
so this is my Wikipedia page on the list
of European Cup and UEFA Champions
League finals if I scroll down you can
see all the details here
and I would like to import this table
which has the list of all the finals so
we have columns like season winners
score Line run us up venue and
attendance let's import this table onto
Excel
so I'll copy this URL first
now let me open a new sheet I'll go to
sheet1
and then on the data tab
under the get data section
I'll go to from other sources and here I
have from web which allows me to import
data from the web either you can follow
this path or if you see here there's an
option to get data from the web if I
click on this
it is asking me to enter the URL so I'll
paste the URL of the Wikipedia page here
and let's click on OK
now it's navigating and okay
you can see power query feature in Excel
has given us a list of tables which you
can see here
we have something called as document
there's a key table and here you can see
there's one table which was extracted
from the Wikipedia page and the table
which I am interested in is this table
which has the list of European Cup
finals you can see it here
Excel power query feature has
automatically detected these rows and it
has given a
list of columns as well you can see
these are the columns
now we'll explore the transform data tab
present in the per query
now if I click on transform data it will
take me to the power query editor
let me just click on refresh now this is
the most important section
Now using the power query editor you can
clean your data filter your data
manipulate your data
and make it ready for analysis
now let's explore a few tabs available
here so we have a Home tab that has
a query section you can see you can
reduce rows manage columns sort the data
transform the data combine different
tables
now there is another tab called
transform which allows you to select
your data type transpose your rows and
columns
columns and here you can see you can
find out some summary statistics
and you can manage your date values as
well
now if you want to add some new columns
to your data you can do that as well and
you also have a view tab
now here
if you see the first two rows the values
are the same you can see season season
these are all repeated
which we actually don't need
and these are pretty similar to our
column names
similarly if I scroll down
you see there are some rows
which have null values
so actually these rows do not add up any
value or do not add any value to our
data so we'll clean this data first
so let's see how to do it
now if you want to remove certain rows
in the table what you can do is
go to the Home tab and under reduce rows
click on remove rows
and then choose remove top rows
if I select remove top rows it will ask
me how many rows do you want to remove
from the top
you can see it here I'll give I want to
remove the top two rows
now let's click on OK
you will see
that the Excel power query editor has
removed the first two rows and on the
right you can see the steps that were
applied
you can see it here previously we had
these two rows which were redundant
and once we applied the step
it has removed the first two rows
similarly let's go down and remove the
last
one two three four five so we are going
to remove the last
seven rows from the table
so again I'll go to reduce rows and
click on remove rows now this time I'll
select remove bottom rows
and here I'll choose
I want to delete seven rows from the
table
from the bottom
I click on OK
if you see
the last seven rows have been deleted
let me show you the last row which is
this one
so the last season of
UEFA Champions League was held in 2020
which is this year
and Bayern Munich won the Champions
League against
a French team that was Paris Saint
Germans by a score of 1-0
now if you see the last value that is
the attendance
you can see the value is 0 which means
there were no Spectators in the stadium
it was because of the covet conditions
now let's do some more manipulation to
our data suppose this time I want to add
a new column let's say a stadium name by
extracting values from the venue column
so let me just show you the venue column
so this is our venue column so the first
value is the stadium name
then we have the city in which the
stadium is there
and finally we have the
country name
so I want to extract only the stadium
name so you can see we have some
stadiums like Santiago bernabao this
Wembley San Siro
another stadium so I want to extract
only the stadium names
so let's see how to do that
I'll click on the menu column and go to
add column tab
under add column here you can see we
have extract now if I click on this drop
down there is an option to select
text before delimiter so if I choose
text before delimiter here
I'll give my delimiter as comma
so everything before the first comma
will be considered as the stadium name
now let me click on OK
now here you can see under applied steps
it says inserted
text before delimiter if I scroll to the
right you can see the last column
has our stadium names
let me double click on this and change
this to
stadium name column
and hit enter even this step is applied
here you can see renamed columns
similarly
let's explore a few more features
now I want to add a new column called
Stadium City
so if you consider this venue column
whatever is there between the two commas
is the stadium city so for example
Santiago bernabao is in Madrid similarly
Wembley Stadium is in London San Siro is
in Milan so these middle values I want
to extract into a new column called as
Stadium City
so let's see how to do it
so I'll click on the menu column and go
to extract
and again I'll select
the extract tab
and here now I'll choose
text between delimiters
and my first delimiter I'll give is a
comma
and a space you can see here all the
values
have a comma and a space
and my ND limiter will be another comma
then I'll click on OK this will add a
new column
to the extreme right of the table you
can see here we have text between
delimiters and it has extracted the
stadium city
let me go ahead and rename this
column as Stadium
City and hit enter
you can see the applied step here
now
I want to split the score column into
two columns so here we have the score
column and
the left value presents the number of
goals that were scored by the winning
team and the right value presents the
number of
goals that were scored by the losing
team
so here I'll split the column into two
columns as winner score and loser score
so what I'll do is select this column
and go to the Home tab under the Home
tab we have split column
I'll select split column and then choose
by delimiter
so automatically Excel power query
detects that this Dash is my delimiter
and I'll split at each occurrence of the
delimiter
let's click on OK
now you can see
the score column has been split into two
it has renamed the column as score.1 and
score.2
what I'll do is I'll go ahead and
will rename this column as winner score
and this will
rename it to Loser score
I'll hit enter
and I have renamed it successfully
next
let's change the windows team and the
runner sub team values to uppercase
so suppose
I want to change all the values or the
club names of the windows team to upper
case so what I can do is
I'll select this column and go to the
transform tab
under transform tab I have this option
called
format
so here
I'll click on format and then
you can see I can change the case to
lowercase uppercase capitalize each word
so here I want to make all the winner
teams as uppercase I'll select uppercase
there you go we have successfully
converted all the winner team names to
upper case
similarly let's do it for the runners of
team as well
so here I have my Runner sub team
I'll go to the transform tab click on
format and select uppercase
now we saw
how to do some simple
manipulation of our data so we created a
few columns split a few columns
now to save all this I have to go to the
Home tab and then click on close and
load
this will take some time and load our
data onto this Excel sheet
you can see here it's loading the data
this will take a bit of time there you
go
Excel power query feature has
successfully
perform some manipulations on our data
some calculations on our data and then
it has saved the final version and
loaded it onto Excel Now using this
clean data we can do some analysis let's
say I want to find the seasons in which
the winners team scored more than three
goals so we have a problem statement at
hand we want to find the seasons in
which the winner team had more than
three goals scored
so what you can do is select any cell in
this data and go to the insert tab and
click on pivot table
here I'll click on existing worksheet
and then I'll give my location
I'll place my
pivot table somewhere here and click on
OK
all right now
since I want to know the seasons I'll
drag season onto row
and I'll also drag
the Winner's team
column onto rows
then I'll choose my winner score under
values
here you can see we have the pivot table
ready
now we need to filter this table to see
all the winning teams that scored more
than three goals so what I'll do is
I'll select this winner score column and
place it under filters
and here you can see I have my filter
let me click on this drop down
and I'll select multiple items
from this multiple items I'll choose 4 5
and 7 because these values are greater
than 3 and click on OK
here you can see I have filtered my
pivot table and
to the left you can see the season
and the winner team that had scored more
than three goals in the finals
all right
similarly
you can perform some more analysis
suppose I want to know how many times
Real Madrid won the championship so
let's see
I'll click on one cell in the data set
go to the insert Tab and click on pivot
table
I'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location here
let's say I want to place my pivot table
here
I click on OK
all right so the question we have is how
many times have Real Madrid won the
championship so I'll choose
the Winner's team column and place it
under rows
and
let's see
we'll select the winner score as well
and let's convert this winner score from
sum
to let's say count and click on OK
and
since I want to check only for Real
Madrid
so what I'll do is I'll go to
the insert tab and I'll insert a slicer
here I'll choose
winner teams as my slicer and click on
OK
and out of this I want to choose only
Real Madrid so I'll select Real Madrid
you can see it here Real Madrid have won
the championship 13 times
okay let's say you want to compress your
data and remove unnecessary columns
without losing any information you can
do that using a feature in the power
query editor called unpivot to perform
this task we'll use a census data of
India from Wikipedia so let me first
show you the Wikipedia page
so this is my Wikipedia article which
says list of states in India bypassed
population
and if I scroll down
you can see it here there's a table
which says bypassed population from 1947
to 2011.
so there are a few columns like rank
this state or Union territory and we
have population starting from 1951 till
2011 which was our last census
here you can see if I scroll further
there are
nearly 29 States and we have seven union
territories so we will extract this
table and load into Excel first
okay so let me click on a new sheet
and we'll follow the same drill I'll go
to my data tab
and click on get data under get data
I'll go to from other sources and click
on from web
here it will ask me to provide the URL
link of the Wikipedia page so I'll paste
the URL here and click on OK
now once I have done that
it will load a few tables
onto Excel you can see there are a few
tables here I'll click on the first one
so we have our table here
now let's do some transformation to this
data
this opens in the power query editor
okay I'll click on refresh first
this will take some time to refresh the
entire data okay we are done now if you
see this data clearly
the first row in this table is not
necessary at all because these are our
column names so we also have our column
headers already present so let's go
ahead and delete the first row so we'll
go to the Home tab under remove rows
I'll click on remove top rows
now I'll give my
number of rows as 1 so we want to remove
the first row only I'll click on OK
you can see the first row has been
deleted
if I scroll further
I actually don't need the last row as
well which is the total
so what we can do is we can also remove
the last row from the bottom
so I'll
select one
click on OK
you can see the step has been applied
and
you don't see the last row that was the
total row anymore
so the task that I want to do here is
I want to compress
all these columns which are basically
the population columns
so I'll
select my
state or Union territory column
and go to the transform Tab and here I
have the option to unpivot columns so
I'll click on this drop down and select
unpivot other columns
you can see here the step has been
applied and
all the population column from 1951 till
2011 have been unpivoted if you want you
can go ahead and rename these columns
let's say I'll write it as population
column
and
let's say this is
I'll rename it to total population value
all right now we are done with our
preparation of data let's go to the Home
tab and click on close and load
now this will take some time to load the
data onto Excel
all right so we have our Census Data
here so first you can see
rank 1 is uttar Pradesh and we have the
population starting from 1951 till 2011
then we have for Maharashtra
if I scroll down you can see the other
states we have Tamil Nadu Rajasthan this
Karnataka if I scroll further
we have odisha this Telangana Kerala now
if you see here the population values
from 1951 till 2011 for the Telangana
state are all n a which means there was
no data available
now this is because Telangana was only
formed in 2014 so there was no census
for this state
let's continue with our demo and let's
explore a few more features and
functionalities of our query editor
now the next table we are going to use
is an adventure Works customer table
now this data set is provided by
Microsoft for practitioners who want to
learn power bi Excel or similar
Technologies and want to do some
manipulation some calculation some data
analysis stuff
so let me go to a new sheet and let's
import
the adventureworks customer data set
it's a CSV file onto Excel first so I'll
go to my data tab
and click on get data from here I'll go
to
from file and choose
from Text slash CSV
you can see it here in my power query
files folder I have my Adventure Works
customer table
I'll select this and click on import
this will take some time to load the
data set
you can see the preview of the data set
here so we have
columns like the customer key we have
the prefix of the customer name the
first name the last name of the customer
date of birth
marital status
if I go to the right we have annual
income total children education level
occupation and homeowner column as well
so let's click on transform data
here we'll learn a few more
features of our query
okay we have our data on our power query
editor
so first what I'll show you is
let's change the prefix column the first
name column and the last name column 2
proper case
so you can see it here the prefix first
name and last name columns are all in
uppercase now if you want to change the
values to proper case
just
hit Ctrl and select the three columns
and
go to the transform tab under transform
tab you have format
so if you click on format here you can
see we have lowercase uppercase now
proper case is to capitalize each word
so I'll click on capitalize each word
you can see it here now
we have converted the prefix first name
and last name column
into prop keys The Next Step I'm going
to show you is let's merge all the three
columns the prefix column the first name
column and the last name column into one
full name column
so
what I'll do is I'll select the three
columns
and then let's go to add column and
under add column we have this option
called merge columns
let's hit merge columns
okay
now it's asking you to give the
separator I'll select my separator as a
space
and click on OK
so before click on OK I want to change
my
new column name from merge to let's say
full name
and now let's click on OK
you can see here it says inserted merged
column and if I go to my
right
you can see it here we have a full name
column now if you want
to shift the location of the full name
column you can do that as well
just
hold this and keep on dragging to the
left
this will move the entire
table to the right and you can place it
wherever you want so I want to place it
let's say here
okay
now actually I don't want all these
columns so let's delete it
so click on this and I'll right click
I click on remove
you can see we have removed the prefix
column similarly let's remove the other
two columns you can either right click
and do or go to the Home tab and then
select remove columns
all right
now
let's say we want to add a domain name
column from AWS customers by extracting
the characters between at the rate
and.com
so actually I'm talking about the email
address
from this email address we want to
create a new column called as domain
name for that we'll extract characters
that are present between at the rate
and.com
so let's see how to do it
I'll select the email address column and
then I'll go to add column under add
column I'll click on extract
and this time we want to extract
between two delimiters also I'll select
text between delimiters and I'll give my
starting delimiter as at the rate
and my end delimiter would be.com
now let's click on OK
so this will insert a new column to the
extreme right you can see we have our
domain name
let's go ahead and
change the column name to domain name
and hit enter
all right you can see the step has been
applied
now we are done with
our preparation of customer stable let's
just go to the Home tab and click on
close and load
so all the transformation that we did in
the power query editor
will reflect here so you can see we have
our full name column
and if you see
we have our domain name as well
okay
Now using the power query editor you can
perform some
statistical analysis now let's explore
those statistical features
for this we'll be using another data set
called adventurebox product data set
again this data set is also provided by
Microsoft
so let's go to the new sheet and here
I'll go to the data tab
click on get data
under from files I click on Text slash
CSV here you can see we have Adventure
Works products right click on import
let's click on transform data
so we have our data
loaded on to the power query editor
the data is mostly clean so let's not
alter this data let's straight away go
ahead and explore some of the
statistical features that we have here
now let's see
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the product table
we have this product name column and say
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the table
how to do it
so what you can do is click on this
product name column then go to the
transform tab now in the transform tab
you have an option called statistics
click on this drop down and select count
values
now this will open another window
that will return the total number of
products in the table you can see the
value here it says 293.
now to move back to the query editor we
have to cancel this step here so let's
just click cancel or close
we are back again
all right
now let's say you want to calculate the
average product price from the product
table so if I move to the right
you have a column called Product price
so let's see what is the average product
price from the product table so I'll
select this product price column go to
the transform tab under statistics I'll
select average
so this will give me the average product
price which is
714.4373 you can consider any unit you
want let's say this is in dollars
now then we have to cancel this step to
move back
okay
now if you want to find the maximum
minimum product price you can do that as
well so let me select my column
product price and go to the transform
tab under the transform tab
we'll click on this statistic drop down
and let's say I'll select minimum so
this will give me the minimum product
price which is 2.29
similarly
if you want to find the maximum product
price so select this product price
column go to the transform Tab and then
choose maximum
so this is the maximum product price in
the product table we have
let's cancel this step
okay
now you can also round the product cost
and product price column to two decimal
places so if I show you both the columns
you have your product cost and you have
the product price column you can see the
floating values of the decimal points
are not constant it's varying so let's
limit it to two decimal places what you
can do is Select both the columns and
then go to the transform tab
in the transform tab you have here
rounding
and click on this drop down and select
round
now here I'll give my decimal places as
2.
if I click on OK
you can see here both the columns the
product cost and the product price
column have been rounded up to two
decimal places
I can scroll down you can see
all the values have been rounded up to
two decimal places
all right
now let's say you want to add a column
called discount price column by
multiplying 0.9 to the product price
column
and let's say you also want to round
that new column to two decimal places so
how to do it
so we want to give a discount of
10 percent so I'll select this product
price column
go to add column and then I'll choose
custom column
here we'll write a formula
so I'll give my new column name as
discount price
and my formula would be
I'll select product price
I'll click on insert
and then I'll multiply this product
price by
0.9
so this will give me my 10 discount
on the product price and click on OK
you see here we have a new column added
which is Discount price
so
If the product price is 34.99 if you
give a 10 discount
it's 31.491
all right
now the next question was to change the
or round the decimal places to 2
so go to the transform tab under
rounding I'll click on round
let's see I'll give two and click on OK
so even this has rounded the discount
price column to two decimal places
now we are done with our mathematical
operation on this product data set
so we saw how to find some average count
how to round up values how to add a new
custom column
so let's go ahead and
close it
and load it onto Excel
you see here we have our new product
table
added here and
the last column if you see it's the
discount column that we added
okay now it's time for us to explore
another feature so we'll use a table
called adventureworks calendar table
which has basically a date column and
let's see how using power query you can
prepare that data as well and make some
manipulation some calculations
so let me go ahead and import
adventureworks calendars table again
this data set is provided by Microsoft
so I'll
go to my new sheet
and I'll go to the data tab
click on get data and from here I'll
click on from Text slash CSV and you can
see I have my calendar table here I
click on import
now this will open in the query editor
you see here this data set has only one
column which is a date column so let's
click on
transform data
okay
now if you see here the first row is
actually the column name
so
let's do the transformation here let's
push this as the column name so I'll go
to the Home tab and under Home tab you
have this option called use first row as
headers I'll select this
you see here we have the column name as
date
now
before making any
operation let's see
if all the fields are available
you see here if I click on
the date drop down
year month quarter weekday day
everything has been shaded out and I
can't access this the reason is
the date settings are not correct
so we'll change the regional settings
let me show you how to do it so we'll go
to file and I'll select options and
settings and go to query options
under query options we have something
called as Regional settings
here
under Regional settings we'll select
English United States instead of English
India
so I'll just scroll down
and here we have English United States
and I click on OK
now once this is done I'll go to my data
type and I'll select date as my data
type
I'll choose replace current
okay now you can see my date column has
been formatted if I go to
the date tab you can see I have access
to all this
now let's do some operations on this
date column
let's say you want to find the earliest
and the latest date from ew calendars
table or the adventure box calendar
table
so what you can do is Select this column
go to date drop down under transform and
here we have the option of earliest and
latest so if I click on earliest
this will show you the last date which
was 1st of January 2015
let me close this
similarly you can see the most recent
date
I'll go to the date
drop down and click on latest and you
have 30 June 2017 as the latest date
and close this
now let's add a new column c d name
start of the week and others so I'll
select my date column
go to add column
here under add column I have
my option to
select the D name the week name and
others so I'll click on this date drop
down and under day
let's say I want to choose
name of d
this Returns the D name
similarly
let's say
I want to find out
the start of the week
you can see we have the start of the V
column or start of V column now one
thing to notice here is
in this power query editor the week
starts on a Sunday
now suppose we want to start your week
on a Monday you can do some
Transformations on this formula tab so
here in the formula bar you can add
a 1 here to make sure your week starts
on a Monday so if I hit enter you will
see all this values will change you can
see it's 28 4 and 11 this will become 29
5 and 12. let's hit enter
you can see it here
your start of the week is on a Monday
now there's another method to make sure
your week starts on a Monday let's
cancel this step
okay I have to insert it once again so
I'll go to date
and here I'll choose
start of week
now the week starts on a Sunday
so one more method is to
add D dot
Monday you can see automatically
power query is giving me a suggestion so
I'll hit tab to finish it and I'll hit
enter
now you can see the values have changed
and our week starts on a Monday
now let's see we want to add a few more
columns like start of month name of
month start of year
and the year value so you can just click
on the date column or select the date
column go to the transform tab
okay not the transform tab let's go to
the add column Tab and here let's say
I'll choose here
so we have all the year values and
similarly
let's say I want to know the start of
the year
now you can do a few more
Transformations let's say I want to know
the month
now here it gives us 1 which means
January that's February March and so on
and so forth
let's say we'll do one more
I click on this
go to my
date
drop down and here I'll choose let's say
I want to know
the day of year
all right now we are done with all our
transformation and preparing your data
on a date field so let me just go to the
Home tab I'll click on close and load
now this will load the
data set on to excel you can see it here
we have the data ready now you can use
this data to make some analysis
draw a pivot table draw a pivot chart
and do a whole lot of things now while
working on a project it is possible that
not all your data will be in a single
file it could be stored in multiple
files so it's important to combine and
bring all your data together
now we will see how to join your data
vertically
I have my data present in a CSV folder
so let me show you the folder first
so this is my CSV folder let me open it
and I have some files these are named as
project one two three four and five let
me open just one of the project files it
has a very small quantity of data
you can see it has a month column and an
amount column let me close this
and
let me show it to you again let's open
project four
all the files have the same number of
columns you can see this also has a
month column and an amount column
now we'll combine all this data together
and load it into Excel let's see how to
do it so I'll open a new sheet
and I'll go to my data Tab and click on
get data
then I'll go to from file and this time
I'll choose from folder
now this will ask me to give the folder
location of the path location where my
CSV files are
so I'll choose
browse
and here you can see I have my CSV file
I'll just double click on it
and click on open
now it has selected my
file path
or the folder path
then I'll click on OK
you can see these are the files you have
projectmon.xls
project 2.xls and so on
I'll
click on this combine drop down and I'll
hit combine and transform
now this will give you the preview of
one of the data files
you will see it now
you can see it here it says sheet1
okay
now it's processing all the data files
present in that CSV folder
and this will be uploaded onto our power
query editor
now you can see here on the power query
editor
all my
data files have been combined vertically
here you can see the month column
on the extreme right it's the amount
column and to the extreme left we have
the source name or the
source file where the data came from so
first is Project one then we have
project two if I scroll down we have
project three files project four and
similarly we have project five
now this is one way in which you can
merge your tables vertically so we are
done with it let's just go to the Home
tab and click on close and load
all the Transformations that were
applied you can see it here we have our
final table
and we have successfully
combined
five Excel files
again you can also join your data
horizontally this would be like an SQL
join where the data is present in
multiple files or sheets based on a
common key column you can join the
tables so you can perform a left join a
right join an inner join based on the
problem that you are trying to solve so
let's merge two tables based on a column
I'll show the data set first it's an
Excel file which has three worksheets
so here is my Excel file which we'll be
using to
merge our data horizontally you can see
there are three worksheets
the first one is year 11 which has data
regarding the student name the gender of
the student and the course the student
had opted for
similarly we have another for 2012 or
year 12 we have the student name gender
as well as the course
and finally we have a courses table or a
courses sheet which has all the details
regarding the course
so we have the course name the teacher
who teaches or teacher who taught that
course we have the lesson type the
number of credits and the assignment
type now we'll use this data sets
to load it onto Excel using power query
so I am on my Excel sheet let's just
open a new sheet I'll go to the data Tab
and here I'll click on get data and this
time I'll choose
from Excel workbook
and I'll select my file which is
students and courses I click on import
so we'll just see how to import two
tables and join them horizontally
so let me first select the courses sheet
and I'll click on transform data
now this has loaded the courses table
onto power query editor the table looks
fine we have the course column teacher
everything is fine
now let's load one more table and then
we'll merge it so here under the Home
tab you have
a section called new source
I'll click on file
I'll again select my students and
courses and click on import
and this time let's choose
another table let's say year 11 which
has the column name as student gender
and course
I click on OK
it has successfully loaded this table
onto power query editor
now if you say this
the first row is actually our
column names so I'll go to the Home tab
and select use first row as headers
so this will push the first row
to the column names you can see we have
done it successfully we have my student
name the gender column and the course
column
now let's merge it so if you see here in
the Home tab we have a section called
merge queries
let's click on this drop down and select
here I have my table which is year 11
and let's choose one more table that is
courses
now the kind of join
I'll choose as left outer join which
means it will take all the rows from the
first table and matching records from
the second table
here I need to select the common key
column so if you see both the tables we
have the course column as the common key
column so I'll select
this and now you can see there's a tick
mark which means it has selected the
rows and the column successfully you can
see it says the selection matches 175
175 rows from the first table
and let's click on OK
let's just expand this
and click on OK
if I scroll to the right you can see I
have successfully merged
both the tables
now if you want
you can remove unnecessary
rows or columns suppose if you see I
have the course column
from the year 11 table and here also I
have
the course column
now this is
redundant let's just remove one of the
columns I'll just select this column
I'll go to
remove columns and I'll select remove
columns
okay
the rest looks fine we have successfully
merged both the tables by using a left
outer join
let's just click close And load
now this will take some time to load our
data onto Excel you can see it here we
have successfully loaded it onto Excel
now we are done with our demo part
now let's just see what all we have done
in our demo so I'll
go to my first sheet here you can see
we had
imported a simple
text file first and then we plotted a
graph which is a pivot chart
then you saw
how to upload
a file from the web so here we imported
a UFO Champions League table which was
present on Wikipedia and then we plotted
some
graphs and charts you can see we made
some analysis using pivot tables
and then we imported another web file
which was based on a population data and
we used the unpivot option or the
unpivot feature in the power query to
reduce the number of columns
then we made some calculations to our
customer table which was from Adventure
works
then we used another table
called the products table here we saw
some statistical calculations and we
added a column called discount price
where we used conditional operations
and then
you saw how we manipulated a date column
and then we saw how to append and merge
multiple tables what is a pivot table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in a spreadsheet to obtain
a desired report
it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives pivot tables are specially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually
now
let's understand the different
components of a pivot table
so there are four main components first
we have rows when a field is chosen for
the row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table
similar to The Columns all row labels
are unique values and duplicates are
removed
columns
is the second component
when a field is chosen for the column
area only the unique values of the field
are listed across the top
then we have values each value is kept
in a pivot table cell and displace the
summarized information the most common
values are sum average minimum and
maximum finally we have filters filters
apply a calculation or restriction to
the entire table
so let's jump over to Microsoft Excel
and let me show you the data set that we
will use in this demo so with India
being ready for its 16 census in 2021
that is next year it is a good time for
us to analyze India's last census data
from 2011 and see where different states
and cities across India stood in terms
of population literacy and other
socio-economic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in Excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin
first I'll show you one of the features
that Excel offers us so suppose I click
on any cell and hit Control Plus Q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis
now you can see by default Excel has
prompted certain features such as
formatting we have charts totals and
this one more called tables now Excel by
default has created some pivot tables
for us now the first one you say is sum
of district code by state names
next we have sum of sex ratio by state
name
then we have some of child sex ratio
some of male graduates and some of
female graduates by state name and there
are others before creating our pivot
table so let's have a final look at our
data set
so First Column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of India then we
have the state code we have the state
name district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each City
then we have the male and female
literates next we have the sex ratio
then we have the child sex ratio
next we have total number of graduates
and finally you can see we have male and
female graduates so using this table
we'll create several pivot tables
now first of all let's create a pivot
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement
so our first pivot table will have the
total population for each of the states
in descending order
so to create a pivot table you can click
any cell
in your data go to the insert Tab and
here
left you can see we have the option to
create a pivot table so let me select
pivot table
now my range is already selected the
entire table
and here I'll choose existing worksheet
because I want to place my pivot table
in the same worksheet and I'll give my
location I'll point to cell Q5
now let me click ok
you can see the pivot table Fields
appears here on the right
now since we want to find the total
population for each state so what I'll
do is
I'll drag my state name onto rows
so here in our pivot table you can see
we have the different state names listed
now
we want the total population for each of
these states
so in the field list I'll search for
total population which is this one and
drag it under values
you can see
we have a sum of total population for
each of these states by default
Excel built sum any numeric column you
can always change it to average minimum
maximum anything you want now we want to
sort this column in descending order so
I right click go to sort option and
choose Z to A that is largest to
smallest
you can see here in 2011 Maharashtra had
the highest number of population
or the total population in Maharashtra
was the highest then it was uttar
Pradesh we had Andhra Pradesh
and if I come down we have nagaland and
Andaman and nicobar Islands towards
the end
so this is a simple pivot table that we
created now the next problem we have is
we want to find the total sum of
literates in each City belonging to a
certain state so let's see how to do it
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
here I can click on pivot table
my range is selected
I'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location
which is Q5
I click on OK
now here we want to find the total sum
of literates so what I'll do is first
let me drag
total literates column two values you
have the total sum of literatures from
all the states
next I want to see the sum of total
literates based on states and cities so
let me first drag state name onto rows
and then will drag City
on two rows
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
to the left of the pivot table you can
see we have the state names and
the cities per state and on the right
you can see the total number of
literates from each City if I scroll
down we have Assam then you can see we
have Bihar
and if I keep scrolling we have all the
states haryana himanchal Pradesh that's
Jammu and Kashmir which has now become a
union territory
we have jharkhand Karnataka and other
states as well moving on
okay so the next thing we want to see is
what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state
with that we also want to find the
states that had the highest and lowest
sex ratio in 2011.
so let's create a pivot table for this
I'll click on any cell go to insert
choose pivot table
click on existing worksheet
I'll select cell Q5
and click on OK
now
since we want
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio so first I'll drag those columns
either you can manually scroll and
drag it or here you have the option to
search for it so if I look for child
you can see we have
the same
column listed
you can just drag it from there let me
delete this
and I also want the sex ratio so I'll
place it on top of child sex ratio
next we want to see it based on
different states so what I'll do is
I'll take
state name and put it under rows
so here you can see we have our pivot
table ready
on the left you can see we have the
different state names listed and on the
right we have the values
now we want to find the average Now by
default Excel will sum the numeric
columns you can see it tells you sum of
sex ratio and child sex ratio so what
you can do
you can click on this drop down and go
to Value field settings
and here summarize values by you can
choose average
you can see the custom name it says
average of six ratio click on OK
our entire column is now
giving us the average sex ratio
similarly for this column let me convert
it into average I'll again click on the
drop down
go to Value field settings
click on average
and click ok
and you can see here we have the average
of child sex ratio for each of the
states now the next question says which
states had the highest and lowest sex
ratio so we'll consider this column
so we'll sort it in any order you want
you can do it either ascending or
descending let me short it in descending
order
you can see we have our
column sorted now
so in 2011 Kerala had the highest sex
ratio and if I scroll down to the bottom
you can see himanchal Pradesh had the
lowest which is around 818.
up next let's explore one more feature
of pivot table so suppose you want to
see the top or bottom few rows of a
pivot table you can do that as well so
here we have a question at hand
we want to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates so let's see from the entire
pivot table how we can filter the top
three cities
so I'll go to insert click on the pivot
table option
go to existing worksheet
click on Q5
and hit OK
now since we want to find the top three
cities I'll drag
City column onto rows and then we want
the female graduates so in the search
bar I'll look for female
and I'll choose this column that is
female graduates and drag it
here on to values so I have the sum of
email graduates for each of the Cities
now since we want to find the highest
number of female graduates in the top
three cities so let me first sort this
column
I'll sort it in descending order
we have it sorted now from this you can
say that Delhi greater Mumbai and
Bengaluru are the top three cities
but it's displaying all the cities for
us
so let's filter
only the top three so what you can do is
right click
and go to filter
under filter you have the option of top
10 I'll select this
here I only want the top three
so either you can
go down like this or you can directly
type 3
your column is already selected let me
just click on OK
there you go we have the required pivot
table ready and it only displays us the
top three cities with the highest number
of female graduates
now the next thing we want to see is how
to use a Slicer in a pivot table so we
have a question here What's the total
population for all the cities in
Rajasthan and Karnataka
so let's create a pivot table for this
and see how you can use a slicer to
filter the table
click on existing
I'll click on a location this time q6
click ok
now since I want the total population so
I'll drag total population onto values
and then I'll select
the city
onto rows and then the state name also
I'll place it on top of City so you have
in the pivot table all the states and
their cities
and on the right you can see the total
population for each of these cities
but our question is we want to find only
for Rajasthan and Karnataka
now for that what you can do is
go to insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivot table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer and click on this
and since we want to slice the table
based on
state that is Rajasthan and Karnataka
I'll choose state name
as my slicer field
you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want
the data for Rajasthan and Karnataka so
I'll search for
these two so here we have Karnataka so
let me select Karnataka first
and I also want for Rajasthan
so let me select Rajasthan also
you can see in our pivot table we only
have
data for Rajasthan and Karnataka
so this pivot table
shows you different cities from
Karnataka and the total sum of
population from each of the cities and
similarly we also have for Rajasthan
moving ahead now we will see another
very interesting feature of pivot that
is how you can
create percentage contribution of a
table
for example we have a question here
what's the percentage contribution of
male and female literates from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that
I'll create my pivot table
click on existing
and I'll select an empty cell
okay
now here since we want to find the
percentage contribution of male and
female literates so first I'll drag
mail literatures onto values followed by
female literates onto values by default
it has summed up the male literacy and
female literates value
and also I want to drag
State column
to rows
so here you can see the sum of male
literatures and female literates per
state I want to convert this as
percentage contribution so
what we can do is
I'll select any cell
and
I'll right click
and I'll go to so value as and here I
have the option to select percentage of
grand total so I'll select this
you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates to the
total
now if I sort this you will get to know
which state contributed or has the
highest percentage contribution
so we have Maharashtra for male
literatures
then we had uttar Pradesh in 2011
if I come down
we had meghalaya nagaland and Andaman
and nicobar Islands
as two states which had little or
minimal contribution to male literates
similarly let's do it for female
literates
I'll go to show value as and select
percentage of grand total
so you can see here also Maharashtra
uttar Pradesh then Gujarat and all had
the
highest percentage contribution to
female literates
so this is another good feature
to convert your data and see it in terms
of percentage
now moving ahead let's say we want to
find the bottom three cities from each
state that had the lowest female
graduates
we can do that as well I'll go to insert
click on pivot
go to existing worksheet select an empty
worksheet and click on OK
now since I want to see based on States
as well as cities so let me drag the
state name first onto rows
and let's drag the city column on to
rows
next
we want female graduates so let me look
for female graduates in the field list
I'll drag it onto values
now we have the list of states and the
respective cities
and to the right of the pivot table you
can see the sum of female graduates from
each City
now
first I'll
sort this column
I'll right click go to sort and click on
shortest to largest
now we have sorted our female graduates
from
shortest or smallest to largest now
since I want to find the bottom three
cities from each state I'll come to the
cell
right click go to filter and select top
10.
now I'll
replace top 10 with bottom and I want
the bottom three cities from each state
I have my
column selected that is sum of female
graduates if I click on OK
you can see here some of the states
don't have three cities so you can see
Andaman and Uber islands has only one
city that is Port Blair while the
remaining you can find
the bottom three cities with the lowest
number of female graduates so Andhra
Pradesh had these three in Assam we had
nagao then there was dibrugar and silcha
similarly if I come down in haryana we
have palwal kathal and zind
if I come further here you can see for
Karnataka this gangavati this Rani banur
and this Kolar similarly you can see for
Kerala as well
now moving ahead
now in the next example I'll tell you
how you can create a calculated field or
a calculated column in Excel with the
help of a pivot table so in a pivot
table you can create or use custom
formulas to create calculated fields or
items calculated fields or formulas that
can refer to other fields in the pivot
table
calculated Fields appear with other
value fields in the pivot table like
other value Fields a calculated Fields
name May proceed with sum of followed by
the field name
so here we have a sales table that has
columns like the items which has
different fruits and vegetables and
those have been categorized as fruits
and vegetables we have the price per kg
and this is in terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see if you want to find the
sales for each item in the table you can
create a calculated field
so your sales column is going to be the
product of price per kg and quantity so
let me show you how you can do that with
the help of a pivot table
I'll create a pivot table first
click on an empty cell
hit OK
now
if you see on the top under pivot table
analyze and under calculations we have
the option Fields items and sets
if I click on this drop down I get the
option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field I click on this
I'll give my field name as sales
and I'll select my formula
I'll first click on
price per kg and hit insert field
I'll give a space hit shift 8 to give
the product symbol and then I'll double
click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
I'll click on ADD
and I click on OK
if you see here
there is a calculated field that is
present in the pivot table fields which
is sales but it did not add it to our
original table or original table is the
same but here we have added a calculated
field which is present only in the pivot
table list now we can use this it has
already taken it under values
now let's say I want to find the sum of
sales for
each item
under each category
you can see it here we have our category
fruit and we have our category vegetable
and under that we have different items
like apple apricot banana similarly in
vegetables we have broccoli this carrots
corn eggplant and others
so this is how you can create a
calculated field in a pivot table
now there's one more good feature that
Excel offers us in pivot table is to
create a pivot chart so you can use your
pivot table and create different charts
so I'll show you how to do that
if I go to insert
here I have the option of recommended
charts click on this Excel gives me some
default charts which you can use
let's say I'll select this
let me drag it a bit to the right
here you can see I'll close this pivot
field list
this is a nice bar chart that Excel has
created this is called a pivot chart now
here you can see the category fruits and
vegetables and the different fruits and
vegetables or the items
in the y-axis you can see the total
seals if you see from the graph guava
meet the highest amount of sales now if
I sort this let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava meet the
highest amount of sales now since I
sorted and changed my pivot table the
pivot chart also automatically gets
updated similarly there are other charts
also that you can create let's go to the
insert Tab and
let's click on recommended charts again
let's look for a pie chart so this is a
pie chart that you can create let me
click on OK
so here is our pie chart and each Pi
represents a certain item
and the pi that has the highest area
represents it had the highest amount of
seals in this case you can see
it is guava and similarly we have other
items as well this is fruit banana
that's corn
and we have spinach and others
let's explore a few other charts so
first I'll
click on my pivot table go to insert and
under recommended charts let's now
select a line chart
if I hit OK
move it to the right so this is a line
chart
you can see it starts from guava
which had the highest amount of seals
then it drops
and in the x-axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables broccoli made the
highest amount of sales with
2800 rupees and our lowest was eggplant
at 900 rupees for fruits papaya sold the
least at 700 rupees
let's take another chart I'll go to
insert
under recommended charts let's see
this time we'll see a bar chart now this
is a
horizontal bar chart and not a vertical
one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this
is an horizontal bar chart now you can
always increase and decrease the size of
this charts
let's explore
our last start let's take the area chart
for now
so this is an area chart again it looks
similar to the line chart it starts with
guava which had the highest amount of
sales similarly papaya under fruits had
the lowest amount of seals and the
vegetables it was
broccoli and finally eggplant made the
lowest amount of sales under vegetable
now let's go to our first seed and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for pivot tables in Excel so we had our
data
this is a 2011 Census Data from India we
had the different cities the state names
and we had the total population total
literates female literates male
literates we had the sex ratio total
graduates and other information
so we began by understanding how to
create a simple pivot table where we
calculated the total population for each
state and sorted it in descending order
we found that Maharashtra uttar Pradesh
had the total population in 2011.
then we saw
another preview table where we
calculated the total sum of literates in
each City belonging to a certain state
so you can see we had the different
state names and the cities under each
state
then
we saw another feature where you could
calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex ratio
after that we saw
how you could find or filter tables
we saw how to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that Delhi
greater Mumbai and Bengaluru were the
top cities with highest number of female
graduates next
we saw how to use Slicer in a pivot
table so we sliced our table based on
Rajasthan Karnataka State and saw the
total population for all the cities in
Rajasthan and Karnataka
in the next sheet
we explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literatures from each state
then
here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates one thing
marked that some of the states did not
have three cities for example Andaman
had only one city that was sport player
but the others we found out the bottom
three cities that had the lowest female
graduates
finally we looked at how to create a
calculated field in a pivot table so we
saw
how to create a calculated field called
sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw there's a
column chart we also saw or looked at
a bar chart that was a horizontal bar
chart similarly we saw how to create a
pie chart as well today we are going to
talk about a Microsoft Excel interview
questions so here I'll be discussing
some important questions that you will
come across when you finish interview
for Excel and we will start with the
basics the beginner level and most of
them will be discussed here will be the
beginner level at the beginning and then
we'll discuss it at the further left
okay so of the first question that you
might get asked is what is a cell
address in Excel so
a cell address is a combination of
column letter and a row number that
identifies a cell on a worksheet
basically each cell will have a
Associated column number column letter
and a row number so you have to keep in
mind it will be always be column letter
and a row number each Excel sheet will
have suppose for instance if you take
Row 5 rows will be in numbers and the
columns will be in letters column a
column B column C column D and so on and
the numbers will be for the rows so for
instance if you take this particular uh
cell the cell address is D5
column D and row 5.
so this is the cell address now let's
move on to the next one
now you will be asked what is relative
cell referencing and absolute cell
referencing in a Excel
so relative cell referencing is usually
the relative references change when a
formula is copied to another cell
depending on the destination's row and
column okay so this is called relative
cell referencing absolute cell
referencing irrespective of the cell you
know you don't have to depend on the
value of the cell destination there is
no change when a formula is copied so
this way I'll explain it in the next
Slide the basic difference is this type
of referencing is there by default in
Excel relative cell referencing you just
insert the formula you don't need to put
a dollar sign in the formula whereas
absolute cell referencing if you don't
want to change in the formula when it's
copied across cell then absolute cell
referencing requires you to add a dollar
sign before an after the column and row
address so see for instance
this is relative referencing you know if
you see this this particular cell is
having we put the value as A3 into B3 so
what it will do is it will multiply A3
and B3 and it will give the product this
is relative cell reference whereas
absolute cell referencing is again the
same thing but you have to put a dollar
sign before the column and the row
number so here you are specifying this
as a pre into B2 okay A3 into V2 and it
will give you this particular answer
irrespective of that it will give you it
will calculate what is there in this and
it will give you the answer
okay now we need to move on to the next
point is basic question when you go
scroll across an Excel sheet sometimes
you have a header on the first row and
if you scroll down you will not be able
to see the first row so there is a
process uh or the there is a trick to
freeze the paints in the Excel so you
just need to have the rows locked so how
do you freeze paint this is the question
so what you need to do is you need to
select the view tab go to the view Tab
and go to freeze panes it's a basic
thing and you will see this if you see
here
select the third row and click freeze
pins so you just select this and click
the page
okay so you're going here and you're
going to the third row and you are going
to view Tab and you are selecting free
Spin so what happens is first two rows
will be locked
okay
these two rows will be locked similarly
for if you want to freeze the columns
okay it's the same thing I am going to
select this particular column
and then click on view and then click
freeze pin so what happens is the first
two columns are locked A and B will be
locked and if I scroll right you will
always see the customer name and
category column so these two we have
logged and the next will be scroll so
this is the function of freezing panes
okay now coming on to the next one and
you will be asked and you have an Excel
sheet or a spreadsheet and you want to
restrict you want to protect the data
for from anyone or from someone cop from
copying the cell for your worksheet so
how do you do that you need to select
that particular data that you want to
protect and then click Ctrl shift F and
then you will see the protection tab
okay you just need to go to the
protection Tab and select lock
okay and you will be asked to put a
password wherein you will be getting the
review tab where you you need to select
the sheet put a password and just save
it so I will show you across in
one of the examples here so this is
particular data that you have and you
need to protect you select it
so here as I said I selected it and then
I just press Ctrl shift F so here you
see the protection tab click the
protection Tab and then click select and
then locked and then click OK and then
you need to go to the review Tab and
then click on the protect sheet and
you're having the you need to select
this protect worksheet and contents of
locked cells so you are selecting these
and you are protecting the content and
you just need to put some password
okay and then click ok
so this is how you protect the data on a
worksheet and you are selecting this
area Ctrl shift F and just put up a
password and select lock sheet so this
is how you protect the sheet from anyone
to copy it second
and now the next question that you might
be asked is what is the difference
between a function and a formula in
Excel
so you will be asked this question and
you need to remember this formula is
like an equation which is typed in by
the user you are typing it suppose a 1
plus B2 you are typing this formula in
one particular cell okay whereas
function functions are predefined
calculations it is like a formula which
is already there in Excel and you can
use it so as it says here it consumes
more time and it has to be typed in
manually you this is as per the need
basis and this is particularly it's very
quick and very efficient you have
inbuilt formulas in Excel the sum and
multiplication product and various other
things that you will come across so this
is the basic difference between a
formula and a function in Excel okay
the now the next question that you might
be asked is uh or you need to know
basically is the order of operations
used in Excel while evaluating the
formulas so what is the order you need
to remember this acronym padmas p e d m
a s or another simple terms you can use
this also please excuse my dear and
Sally so these are the acronyms p e d m
a s now let's see what happens first and
you uh in math when you do some
calculations you have order of
operations okay bod mass is the one of
the order of operations now in Excel
similarly in Excel when you put up a
formula you Excel will calculate it in a
particular order and this is called the
order of operations and the Order of
Operations is first it will calculate
what is there in the parenthesis it will
perform this function and then it will
see if there are any X exponents in it
and if it is there it will do that
calculation the next and after that it
will see if there is any multiplication
or division so p e d and then it will
see if there is any addition okay and
then the last one will be the
subtraction so Excel knows this and you
have to know this so that when you put
up a formula you will know what is going
to happen first and you will not mess up
with your formula okay this is the order
of operations it is one of the important
questions in the interview for a
beginner Excel level now the next one is
how will you write the formula for
following multiply the value in a cell
A1 by 10 and add the result by 5 and
divide it by 2 it is quite simple okay
so I'm just giving it as an example in
this slide and you might be asked
something else so you will be given a
task to calculate or put up a form the
purpose so when you are asked to
multiply the value in a Cell of A1 by 10
so this is particularly okay A1 is the
particular cell that is being given and
you are multiplying it okay you put it
in parenthesis and then add the result
by 5 so it will calculate the
parenthesis first okay and if it sees if
there are any exponents you have to
think in that way if there are any
exponents in it or not and then
first you will see the parenthesis and
then exponent there are no exponents
here and then it will do the
multiplication and then the addition and
the revision okay so you will get this
particular answer and if you put it
simply in this way your answer is wrong
because it will multiply it into 10 add
5 and divide by 2. so you have to check
which one is right and you have to make
sure that you are putting the right
parenthesis Okay so
this is the homework
okay
the next question is uh there is a
different what is the difference between
count counter and count blank these are
three particular important things that
you need to these are similar but they
are quite different when you actually
see it okay so first we will see what is
count count is basically it counts the
number of cells which have numeric
values as the name suggests it is count
it will count the number of cells which
has numeric volumes okay if you see this
column and uh at a11 we are putting it
as count equals to a 10 to A2 to 8 and
so you are taking this range and you're
finding out what are the number of cells
which have numeric value if you see this
one two three four five so five cells
have numeric values it counts the cells
which has numeric value and the next
thing is the counter okay what counter
does it counts the number of cells which
has any form of content it can be
anything it can be a number it can be a
alphabet it can be anything it will see
what are the number of cells which has
any form of content okay for example
this is the same example we here taken
here and we have put the function as
counter A2 to a 10. now see one two
three four five six
seven so it sees that there is
seven cells have some content in it it
is numbers and letters it can be
anything but it has some content so
counter is the function for this then
the next one is Count black okay as the
name suggests it will count the number
of blank cells only
so again the same examples count black
A2 to a 10 okay it will see what are the
number of blanks okay if you see this is
blank and this is black so two cells are
blank so it will count the number of
blank cells only okay now the next one
is uh what is the shortcut to add a
filter to a table why do we use filter
and it is one of the basics uh function
in the Excel where you need to do some
sorting and it can be done by using a
printer what is the shortcut key it's
very simple control shift and L this is
the key that is used to put up a filter
you just press this
Ctrl shift L altogether and you will
find the filter and you can sort it now
the next question that you will come
across is how do you create a hyperlink
in Excel so it's quite simple there is a
simple shortcut Ctrl
key you press these two together and you
will get the option you will select the
it will select the cell where you have
to insert the hyperlink hyperlink
basically it redirects to any other
document it can be a web page it can be
a Word document it can be another Excel
sheet or so on okay so these are the
things okay
now another important questions uh that
is how to merge multiple cells
text strings in a Cell so how do we
merge the text strings in multiple cells
into one cell
there is one particular simple function
that you can use which is called called
as concatenate concatenate function is
used to merge text strings present in
multiple cells okay and it's a very
simple thing you just need to put this
equals to concatenate and then if you
for example this is the formula
concatenate text one text to textly or
this is concatenate A1 comma B1 comma C1
this is the data in our three cells
Excel is fun in A1 V1 and C1 so now if
you want to put them all in one and you
can merge it in one cell using the
concatenate function and it's very
simple concatenate and parenthesis A1
comma P1 comma C1 okay and you will get
it all merge in one particular cell okay
so this is how you use the concatenate
function and you can also use the and
operator to combine cell values it is
the same thing we can use the and
operator instead of Commerce okay and
and I will show it to you in the example
here
okay now we have this I'll just copy
this thing to
yeah okay
let's make it simple and now I want to
put this here equals
con
e
concatenate
and A1
comma B1 comma c i just close it and I
put enter so you see this this all three
the different text is merge in one
particular cell and it will you can
perform various merge functions using
the concatenate function it's a very
simple thing and it is a frequently
asked questions in the interview okay
the next question uh it is very a very
important one again and very basic as
well so how can you split a column into
two or more columns you have some
particular text or a sentence written or
data written in your cell or a column
and you want to put them across in two
or more or many number of columns so how
do you perform this function it's very
simple again you need to select that
particular cell so for instance we have
it here is India is a democratic country
India space is space a space the
Democratic space country so the it's a
different text here and you want to
split this particular sentence into
different columns okay you need to
select that cell and then go to the data
Tab and then choose text to columns
there will be an option when you need to
select text to columns okay and you will
see this screen okay and you need to
select the choose the delimiter here and
what we are specifying here is first it
is a delimited and then we are selecting
a delimiter as space because we see that
that is space here which is very common
and we want to split it so you will see
a preview here which shows what your
output will be like India in one column
is a democratic country so the diameter
is space here and T unit is like this
and then click next Okay so so you will
see the options select the columns data
format and choose the destination now
you see the data View and you need to
select the destination where you want to
put this output as and you select that
and then click finish and this one what
it does it it's it splits the text into
multiple columns okay so you see this
you have selected this as the output and
it starts here India is a democratic
country so you will come across some
data which is you know huge and there
are spaces or objects or anything that
is differentiated it with and you need
to put them in different rows or
different columns so this is the
function r that you need to use to split
the text into different or multiple
columns okay okay the next question can
be very simple one or most widely used
in fact and what is the use of vlookup
and how do we use it so what is this
particular thing in Excel vlookup
function is used for looking up a piece
of information in a table and extracting
some corresponding data or information
so you have some set of values in one
particular column and you want to
retrieve or extract the data
corresponding to that particular column
or a cell in the code sheet okay so the
syntax is something like this it is you
need to go to one particular cell where
you want the output as and you type the
function
vlookup and you are selecting the value
where it is the cell exactly where you
want the output to be and you are
selecting the table here and the you are
specifying the column index and range
lookup so value this indicates the value
that you have to look for in the First
Column of a table okay and then the
table table basically this refers to the
table from which you have to retrieve a
value we will show this in the example
in the next slide and the column index
column index it provides the column in
the table from which we are to retrieve
a value okay we will specify the column
index which one you are looking for
the next thing is range lookup which is
optional true with the if you put true
it is approximate match which is default
and false if it is exact match if you
are looking for the exact match so what
is the use of vlookup and how do we do
it okay so frying the product related to
a customer name Richard okay you have
this sheet and in this one you want to
see what Richard has bought okay what is
a product that he has bought and you can
do this with the vlooker function okay
so you just go here and you type in the
function vlookup you're naming it as
Richard
and first thing is the value it is H4
okay and then the next thing is the
table okay table is A2 because this is
the table okay and you're looking for
customer name Richard
okay and then you are selecting this the
whole column index which is E15 I mean
you are selecting this whole table then
15 okay e 15 you're selecting this and
then the next thing is option which is
giving you the uh arrange lookup okay
what it does is it's optional it is you
are looking for an exact value or an
approximate by default it is approximate
match so how it performs the function
okay so it gives you the answer as
scanner it goes and lookups for Richard
in this particular it will give you the
output here and the A2 is the table that
it will look for the customer name and
it will search for Richard and then it
will give you the arc camera now the
next thing will be vlookup different Pro
lookup function how different they are
we look up lets the user look for a
value in the left most column of a table
so as we've seen in the example it
allows you to look for data in the lack
moves column of the table and Returns
the value in a left to right okay it
starts in left to right lookup function
lets the user look for data in a row
column and Returns the value in the
another raw column it will give you the
lookup function in the next workout okay
not very easy to use as compared to the
lookup function okay as we see uh it's a
bit complicated when you compare it to
the lookup function it's quite simple
and it is used to replace the we do cup
function okay so this is the different
lookup and vlookup function now Excel is
basically used for reporting mainly used
for reporting to management you have to
extract different kinds of reports and
what are the report formats that are
available in Excel this is one of the
important questions again for a beginner
level and there are three formats
basically compact form outline form
tabular form okay these are the three
formats that are available report
formats that are available in Excel okay
the next question is about a function
which is how does IF function work in
Excel okay the F function in Excel it
actually performs a logical test and you
will give a condition it performs the
test and returns a value if the test
evaluates to true and another value
which you again will specify if the test
result is false okay for instance we
have here a simple example which is
shown in the slide and what we are doing
here is a written record is valid if age
is greater than 20 we have age here
specified and salary is greater than 40
000 else Returns the record is n value
so we are giving two conditions and it
actually checks and evaluates whether
these conditions are met and it will
give you then output whether record is
valid or invalid based on the two
conditions that are specified okay and
F22 axis which is this this column we
are specifying it should be greater than
20 and G2 to G6 which is the salary
column and we are specifying the
condition to be greater than 40 000. So
based on this two things it will check
and perform if these conditions are met
then it will give the desired result
okay so this is the function that is
used in Excel IF function okay the next
thing is sum IF function okay again the
sumif function adds the cell value
specified by a given condition or a
criteria so you are giving a condition
and you are actually doing another
position which is performing the
addition okay that will add the cell
values based on a condition again it is
shown here the total sum of salary where
salary is greater than 75 000. again for
example the salary column is G2 to G6
and we are doing a sum F function what
the result will be it will perform the
addition of salaries which are greater
than 75
000 so it will see which values are
greater than 75 000 and then then the
output will be it will be adding these
salaries which are greater than 75
000 okay
now coming to the next slide we will
discuss another important function
counter and we'll find the data
um result based on the data that we have
and the countif function so we have a
slide data here and using the Kobe data
find the number of days in which the
number of deaths in Italy has been
greater than 200 okay it's not uh shown
here for some reason but I will show you
in the Excel sheet okay so this is the
data that we have and we will try to
find the function so we'll use the
countif function and counter function is
again simple counter you are specifying
the column that is the source that you
are looking for that is G2 the column G
and it is 2. it starts from 2 Row 2 G2
till G three five triple seven which is
the end of the column and what you're
looking for is Italy you are specifying
it in the codes Italy and that's the
next column that it will look for is the
E column the number of cases okay here
we have the number of cases e22 again we
are specifying the range and what we're
looking for is number of cases which are
more than 20. so we'll perform this
function and it will show you the output
okay I'll show you to you in the Excel
so here is the sheet and I will uh try
to get the answer here and
the
so we are performing count
and okay count okay
and you're giving the brackets
parenthesis G2 which is the
countries column okay entries column
here we'll specifying the whole range
three five triple seven
that is beginning a long a long list of
data and you're specifying the page and
what you're looking for is particularly
any country you can pick up like Algeria
okay
Algeria and you specify it in quotes
comma
then what is the next Target that you
are looking for is the column e various
it is mentioning the number of cases
okay so you specify the column range for
the number of cases which is again e and
then
uh
the three five triple seven I mean it's
a basically long list of data that you
are looking for and then you are what is
the condition that you want to know and
you are have to specify it in course and
what you're looking for is number of
cases which are more than
you hit enter
okay so it gives you the output as 143
so there are 143 days in which the
number of cases were more than 20. so
let's refine our search further let's
see 30. and it gives 140. so another
example that you can take is let's pick
Afghanistan
Afghanistan and quick so for about 19
days that you will see the number of
cases where more than 30 and this can be
done with the count F function
so the next question is uh about the
pivot table
so what is a private table it's
basically is a summary of table of the
data set I mean the data that is there
that can be you know multiple number of
rows and columns which has different uh
data that has to be uh that is there in
the reports and you need to analyze
those Trends and you need to create a
report and basically present it to the
management or in a presentation so pivot
table is a summary of table you know
whatever data is there you can put it in
a summarized format they are useful if
you have long rows or column that hold
values you need to drag okay so you have
long list of data and you need to
summarize it and put it in a
presentation or a you need to track the
values so
it's very simple you have to select the
data and then go to the insert Tab and
select pivot table okay and then it will
show up like this and you need to select
the table which is a table or range and
then you need to specify where you want
to put up this private table okay and
it's quite simple and I can show it to
you in one of the examples Okay so
what you need to do is you need to
select this and once you generate our as
we have seen in the previous slide you
need to select this and you need to
select the output where you want to put
the pivot table and then once you do
that you will see something like this
and you need to select these particular
fields and put it in value so it will
for example you need to select the depth
number of death you can just simply
click this select this drag and drop it
in the values okay so these are the
different fields that can be put up in
the table okay we can show it to you in
the example here
so this is our data and we need to show
it in a review table okay select this
and then go to the insert app and click
private theme okay
select that and it will show you the uh
table or the range and now where you
want to put it okay I will put it in the
existing worksheet okay and I'll just
select which color I'll put it
here for example and it will show you
this and click ok so this is the table
and now you need to select the fields
that you want to show in the table for
example we need to see the continents
the number of cases as per the
continents okay I selected and put it in
the row and we see the immediately we
see it in a table where you see the
number of names of the continents and
now I want to see the number of cases
and I simply select it
and put it across in the value so this
is quite simple and very informative
very short and crisp
form of presenting the data in
a private table okay so this is how it
is being used and it is being presented
you just need to go to the insert tab
pivot table and it will generate the
table and then you can select the fields
all right
so the next question here is uh how do
we create a drop down list in Excel this
is particularly useful when you need to
sort a particular data with the drop
down list whereas number of different
variables are there and you need to
select one particular uh field and sort
the data so you can do this by creating
a drop down list using the data
validation in presenting the data tab
it's quite simple you select the data
and you go to the data validation tab in
the data and click select data
validation so once you select that it
will ask you to specify a range so you
need to select what data you need to
sort and put a drop down so you need to
select this and click
data validation and you select the list
option which shows you that there is a
different option okay I'll show it
across in the Excel for example what we
have here is some particular data and we
have different variables we need to sort
or put a drop down list so just go to
data as in as said in the slides and go
to data validation and click data
correlation now as you click it it will
ask you to data validation settings okay
and in the drop down go and select list
option so it will ask you to specify the
source so when you ask to specify the
source just click this particular column
and click ok so here I'm mentioning the
source is column B okay B 3 t b fourteen
Okay click OK and then it will give you
the option so here you can uh you can
put this in anywhere across the Excel
and click the option okay so this is the
way to drop down using the data
validation option so in the next example
we will see so how do we apply Advanced
filters in Excel we use the advanced
filter option present in the data tab so
this is the scenario wherein you have
multiple set of datas and you need to
sort it and it's it's actually huge data
and you need to sort a particular column
or a field with this criteria and you
can select it and specify the criteria
and specify a range what you want to
uh select or based on what criteria the
range can be specified and you can just
get it in a single click so this is the
option you have to go to
data tab Advanced and you have to apply
the advanced filter and then you need to
specify the list link that is the is
killing the source then the criteria
wherein you specify the criteria present
here I mean you are specifying in this
case we will take an example where we
are trying to sort the data or the
number of cases based on number of
deaths and in a particular country and
we are specifying the output the copy to
field is the output where you will see
the output so I'll show it to you in the
Excel so here we have a spreadsheet
wherein you will see all the uh data
with data that we have and based on the
countries and the continents and the
number of deaths number of cases and so
on okay and that's also has different
fields like the date year and month you
know so so here I am going to sort the
data which is particularly for Europe
and which has that's of more than 200 in
a day so how do we do it go to data
Advanced and the
you need to select copy to another
location okay and this is the list
screen so it's basically given in this
countries okay and the criteria range
you have to specify this so I am going
to select this as my criteria okay and
then I have to put the output in one
particular cell so I need to select it
again let's say here okay
and then I just click ok
see it's quite simple instead of running
through the whole thing
we can just do it with a simple
function okay so it shows me the deaths
which are more than 200 and for which
particular country and for which
particular
continents are all right so this is
basically made very simple with this
option the next question is uh
you know you need to highlight some
particular cells using a particular
criteria in this case we are trying to
analyze or highlight those cells where
the total sales is more than five
thousand dollars so what we do is we use
conditional formatting to highlight the
cells based on the criteria it's a very
useful tool in analyzing data and
Visually it helps you know you can have
a look at the data in quick flash you
will see the data and it's quite visible
using the conditional formatting so how
we do that is I will show it to you now
so as said in the slide we have the data
of the sales that is provided to us and
we need to see who has done more sales
which is greater than the 5000 so just
go to home and you need to say go to
conditional formatting so for that you
need to highlight or select this go home
conditional formatting highlight okay
and you have different options here you
select create through that and you
specify the value I here my criteria is
five thousand dollars okay we can select
which color so let's go for green
okay
see this you will immediately see the
option you don't have to dig or look in
deep into the data and find out which
one is more than 5000 or any particular
value okay so conditional formatting now
moving on to the next question the index
and match function you must be familiar
with the index and match function and
why it is used basically index function
is a very powerful tool wherein you know
you for example you have a table of
planets in our solar system and you want
to get the name of the fourth planet
Mars so you can do it with a formula
using the index function and at the same
time you can use the match function okay
with the match function together you can
play wonders with it okay match function
is another function that is designed to
find the position of an item in a range
for example we can use the match
function
to get the position of a word or look or
in this case we have a name and we can
use the index and match function to find
the city how we do that is shown here
okay it looks quite complicated here
when you see the formula but I can show
it to you in the Excel and explain it
further okay so here I have and I want
to know where these people are and where
they belong to okay
so
let's see how it goes uh we have seen it
and we use the index function okay
index okay now when I have to specify
the range okay so the range is A2 and it
shows it selects the
name and I want to select it from A2 to
okay sir okay E7 sorry
e
column e 7 okay so as you see it
highlights the whole table okay now what
I'm going to do is I want to match it
okay match it with a condition I am I am
specifying a condition a 10 why because
I have to specify a name here and it
will show me the city where he belongs
to okay where it shows is a two okay if
you see A2 it shows the name through A7
I have to specify the range here okay
not just one name we are specifying the
holding as you see if you put the values
it will show you the selection
okay as soon and what it should be it
should be the exact match so 0 denotes
the exact match parenthesis is closed
and I am putting another match condition
okay what is this and this will give me
the output what output is okay
B9 okay this is my city v9 is the city
where I'm trying to find from okay and
what it should look for is a column A A1
through
e one okay let you select these this
particular row and
what it should be it should be the exact
match again okay let's see how it goes
it will give you an error because you
haven't put the value here okay so let's
see
thank you
and okay hit enter and you will see the
city where he belongs to okay
now let's see where Anna belongs
enter let's use Dallas okay so this is
the one other function index and match
function being used and it can be asked
in frequently in the interview questions
okay the next question will be uh how to
find duplicate values in a column okay
there are two ways that you can actually
do this and one is basically the very
simple one which is the conditional
formatting and the other one is we have
seen this before count if function okay
how we do that you need to Simply select
the data and go to conditional
formatting and select duplicate values
it's quite simple and there is another
way which give you the color-coded
conditional formatting okay there is
another way that is the countif function
how we do that is again the you have to
put another column and put up a counter
criteria contact function wherein you
see that you are specifying the range
and the
the value which is being twice or enter
duplicate and you have to put up a
condition I will show it to you in the
text so here we have the data and I need
to find the duplicate values here so I
just select this and as I said it's
quite simple go to conditional
formatting form and then go to
conditional formatting and select
highlight cell rules and simply go down
and select the duplicate values okay it
will give you which color you want you
can simply select red R anything as you
see the moment you select you will see
the duplicate values highlighted okay so
I just cancel this and there is another
way then count a function so I'll put
another column where it says duplicate
names and I will put up a counter
function here
okay
so let's see how a counter function
works here to check the or find the
duplicate names so as I said I put up a
formula a function here for the count f
and we'll drag it to other cells okay
counter and uh since it's an absolute
reference I have to put up a dollar
symbol
okay my reference here will be H the
count here h
okay and again dollar because I'm using
it as an absolute reference
colon
through
dollar symbol again
nine okay so it drags till at the whole
it tracks till the
all the names okay the H9 all right and
then
what I'll do is I'll put a comma
and why I want to do is I have to select
H2
okay this is my criteria I mean it is
repeating twice all right and
I have to close the parenthesis and if
it is more than one okay so this is my
formula I just put enter
and it should say true so this is the
condition and it is true okay I simply
drag it the whole thing and whether
events is repeated yes it's true Andrew
it's a duplicate entry false me is a
duplicate entry and it says true and as
you see me and events are duplicate
entries so this is how we use the
counter function and the conditional
formatting to sort duplicate entries in
the date
now let's move on to the last question
for The Beginner's level and since we
have duplicate entry there is also a
problem to remove duplicate entries so
how can you remove duplicate values in a
range of cells okay to Simply do that
you can delete the duplicate values in a
column by simply selecting the
highlighted cells and press the delete
button so you go in each column and you
see the duplicate values select it and
delete it okay and this is one tedious
way of doing it and you can also after
deleting the values you can go to the
conditional formatting choose clear
rules to remove the rules from the sheet
so this is one way okay the next thing
is again a simple button that is there
in the data tab that is the
is one of the tools present in the data
which is simply called as remove
duplicates it's quite simple and it's
there in the data tools let me show you
in the Excel so here we are and we have
this data and we need to check and
remove the duplicate so as I said go to
the data Tab and simply click on remove
duplicates and when you click on it it
will ask you you want to continue or
expand this selection I just say
continue with the current selection and
remove duplicates okay select all click
OK two duplicate entries that were
removed previously we saw that events
and
[Music]
and over there any weather so that has
been removed okay
so that's it for the beginner level and
we'll go to the intermediate level in
the next slides choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so here we are at the intermediate level
questions and these are like a higher
level or intermediate level compared to
the previous things that we have
discussed with the basic level questions
for the Excel interview so let's move on
to the next thing
and so there's there are some scenarios
where you enter the date or
some dates in particular data sheet and
you need to find out what is the day of
the week okay so you might be asked you
a question how do you find out the day
of a week for a particular date so that
is the function we we have a specific
function and that is the weekday
function to find out the day of the week
for a particular date okay so as we know
these are the seven days of the week and
we just put the function as it says
equals to VT and we need to enter the
column or the area or the cell address
here so weekday is the function and it
will give you the
which which day it is of the V okay we
go as it says one it denotes Sunday
okay and three is again Tuesday okay so
this is the function that is used to
find the day of the week
so now we move on to the next one
and there is a there might be a question
what are the wild cards available in
Excel so basically Excel Sports three
types of wild card which are
Asterix the star it represents any
number of characters it can be used in
different formulas and all like
multiplication and all so it represents
any number of characters okay the next
one next Wild Card is the question mark
it represents one single character okay
you just need to memorize this in the
back of your mind that it represents one
single characters okay whereas Asterix
is it represents any number of
characters and the third one which is
rarely used in Excel it is the tilde it
is used to identify a Mobile card
character that is till the Asterix
question marks in the text okay and it
is very rarely used so you need to
memorize these three things that the
there are three types of wild cards we
can see the functions of this in the
later sessions okay the X1 is we have a
question here what is the data
validation illustrate with an example
you might be asked this question and you
have to know what is data values what is
what is it used for and you should know
how to set up in an example okay data
validation is a feature in Excel that is
used to control what a user can enter
into a cell okay so you have with the
data validation you are not allowing a
data kind of data that should be input
in the cell okay for example you have
the authority by setting up the data
validation that you can enter either a
number or at text or just a number and
so on okay using the data validation and
where is it available it is in the data
tab okay select data validation option
present under data tools okay and you
just need to select the particular cells
where you want to set up the data
validation I'll show it to you in an
example so this is how it looks like you
just need to go to data tools and click
on data validation and it will show you
and you have the options here allow and
if you click on the drop down you will
see different options like I will show
it to you in the example here okay
for this particular thing if I want you
know a this column should have only
names and it should have if you insert a
number you will be thrown with an error
okay you will get an error message
saying that this is not a valid option
okay so there are some columns where you
have to put only names or you have to
put only number so you can set this up
with the data validation
technique okay you just allow it or
customize it as per your requirement so
this is how it looks like when you set
up another so here we have set up a data
validation saying that it should not
allow you to put any text okay so you
will get an error when you put a number
here the value does not match data
validation restrictions defined for this
cell okay so here as an example I have
some data where I am putting the names
here and I'll put the salary here I want
to make sure that you know we cannot
enter any numbers here okay it should be
only text it should have only name so
how do I perform that how do I restrict
any user to
that they should not be able to enter
any number and you should only enter the
text okay so there is a function okay
you just need to go to data validation
click data validation and here in the
setting I'll go to custom there are
different options here you can you can
choose whole numbers decimal list date
time so your these are the option and I
go to custom and I am giving a
particular formula here
what is that it should be only text okay
so it's a simple thing it should be text
and I need to define the range okay so
how I'll Define the ring I just select
this okay and
all right select the range okay
so I have selected the range here and if
you go to input message
and error alert you can customize it and
here we are taking the default one and
this is the input message if you want to
set or customize something okay so let's
see how it works okay I have said this
and then I try to put a number here and
it throws me an error the value entered
is not valid because we have set a
restriction a user has restricted value
that can be entered into the cell so
this is how the data validation work
okay the next thing is you will be given
a situation wherein you have to uh you
will be given data and you have to
perform a function like in this example
we are taking a condition wherein you
will have data and you have to specify
the result based on the data you have to
formulate it okay so given below is a
student table write a function to add
pass or fail to the results column based
on the following criteria you will be
given a criteria so this is the student
table you are giving the student names
marks and attendance and then based on
that you will have to specify a next uh
I've got a formula wherein you will see
the result okay based on the past
student data you have to put a pass fail
results in the column based on the
following criteria what is the criteria
and for example here in this example
what they're saying is you have to say
that the student is passed if his marks
is more than 60 and the attendance is
more than 75 percent okay so how we
perform this function as it says you
have to use the IF function and check
with the hand condition to fill the
results column okay so let's see this in
the example here
so here is the example and we will
perform the
IF function and check with the and
function so how we do that is here okay
so I have to put the IF function here
okay and check with the and function
okay and I have to specify the
conditions I have to subscribe where it
should C D or check the conditions okay
so we are checking the conditions here
and the marks should be in row I mean
the column U and it starts with u5 so
let's see U 5 okay it will immediately
go to column U and five row five okay
and then what is the condition we are
satisfying here it should be greater
than 60 okay and the other condition is
uh the column V that is the attendance
column okay and what is the condition we
are specifying V 5 should be greater
than
75 okay
and we just close these conditions with
the parenthesis and now we have to
specify the result whether it is pass or
fail
pass
comma
in quotes again
three okay so let's see how this works
okay
okay see this works okay the marks is 50
and attendance is greater than 80. so he
is failed because he has marks are 50
his attendance must be more than 75 but
yes he is he has not scored marks more
than 60. so we drag the same formula to
the whole thing and you will see the
result okay this is quite simple and you
will see this
you formula and using the if and
check and check with and condition okay
now moving on to the next question you
might be asked to you know this is
simple function wherein you can you will
be asked to calculate your age in years
from the current date okay so how we do
that there is a particular function and
it's very simple use the ear Frac or
dated IF function to return the number
of whole days between start date and the
ended so you specify a standard which
will be uh today's date and the I mean
the birthday and then the end day will
be today's day for example okay and you
will get to know the age using the year
fact function and dated IF function okay
so here is a small example and this is
how we use the ear Frac function okay
you specify this function and then
specify the inputs that is the today's
dates and the date of birth and the
today's date okay and this is one of the
ways to get it and there is also created
F okay this again it is day-to-day
function and you specify the input cells
okay so let me show you an example for
the same
so here we are and we have today's date
that is 4th of May and date of birth for
anything it could be so I will specify
the EF flat function
equals
here drag okay
and then I shoots as soon as you enter
you specify the start date and the end
date okay and I will specify the start
date as today's date I fix the column
and then I put the comma
and then the end date should be this
thing okay and just close it and it will
give you the
h
okay so this is the eight for example if
you want to find out my age I don't want
to reveal my birthday but it's okay
um
okay
let's see if it calculates
I am 32 years old okay all right so this
is one of the ways and similarly you can
use the dated expansion shown in the
example all right now moving on to the
next question you have a nested if
statements this is very important and
you will definitely be coming across
this question how are nested if
statements used in Excel what are nested
statements the F function can be nested
I mean it can be Loop when we have
multiple conditions to meet okay it can
be nested the false value is replaced by
another IF function okay you have
specified some condition and you are uh
putting up a condition and if that
condition is not there or not met then
if it will be replaced with another
IF function so the syntax will be like
this below is an example so we actually
we use two if statements in conjunction
okay so here is an example here we are
specifying a condition wherein you know
uh the result is excellent if it is more
than 80 and if it is less than 60 it is
bad or average so this is very simple
you are perform one if condition and if
that is not met
it will go for the next if condition so
we are nesting two if conditions we are
joining two if statements okay uh I'll
show the same example here in the Excel
so here we are we have some data and the
students and their Mars okay and we are
specifying a condition wherein if the
result or marks are more than 80 the
result is excellent and if it is less
than 60 it is bad or average okay so how
we get this is we use two if conditions
if statements so as we've seen it
if now the first condition is our source
or the source is B2 okay so B
and what I am specifying is it should be
greater than
80. all right I just close this and the
result should be excellent okay
foreign
excellent if it is more than 80 and if
this condition is not met it will go to
the next if statement okay we are
nesting another if statement what is the
condition here for the next statement it
will check B2 is
less than or equal to 60. you can
specify any marks all right so if it is
less than 60 it should give the result
as bad
or average okay
specify anything and you
okay
and just close the double parenthesis so
let's see how it works okay see
it works like this
now let's pull up the same formula the
for the other results okay
see if it is more than 90 it is 90 it is
excellent so it is checking the first
thing if it is greater than 80 it is
excellent okay now in this case for Mark
it is bad why because it will first see
whether it's excellent or not if it is
not excellent then it will check the
other condition if it is less than 60 it
will give you the bad result all right
and similarly so on for the other
months all right so this is how we use
the nested if statements you are adding
two if statement the first condition and
the second condition with another if
statement okay okay when it comes to
excel it is basically involves a lot of
data and a lot of data to be analyzed
and we have some powerful tools which
are used in Excel to analyze the data
one such uh important tool is
descriptive statistics
that is used to analyze the data so we
might come across a question and you
will be given a data or a table and you
need to find the descriptive statistics
of the columns using data analysis too
okay so you will be given us maybe for
example anything and you will have a lot
of data you have to use the descriptive
statistics option in Excel for the data
analysis okay how you do that is you
have to add a pack okay you should be
knowing that you need to add a pack
which is called the analysis tool pack
which you go to uh file options and then
just click on the add-on and select the
analysis tool pack click Excel add-in
and just click go and it will add the
option and then when you select the data
you have to go to the click on the data
analysis option which will be which will
show up when you select the Addle or
when you add the Adam okay then you need
to select the descriptive statistics
what we need to do is we need to analyze
this data and it will show you the
values like mean and the you can also
customize you can you see you have this
data and for you to check each and every
row and find the mean the smallest the
uh maximum number and things like that
so this can be easily done using the
descriptive statistics for the data
analysis uh I'll show the same thing in
the Excel how it can be performed so
here we are and I'll show you first how
to add the
option to it okay go to add and select
analysis tool pack as shown in the slide
and you need to click go if you just
click OK it will not add so just click
go and then you need to select analysis
tool pack okay it will give you these
are the different options yeah for now
we are selecting analysis tool bracket
and then click OK as soon as you do that
you will see the data analysis this
option gets enabled when you add that
pack so this is the data that you have
you need to find or analyze using the
descriptive statistics
so as you see it
click data analysis and click select
descriptive statistics okay and it will
show up the option like this and you
need to select the input range okay for
some reason it's already there and if
you want me to show I will show it to
you across you have to select the whole
date
okay this is my input range you need to
select this labels in the first row so
that you know it doesn't take the first
row okay I'll show
foreign
you are getting a summary statistics
which is the default and you can select
the confidence level that is the mean
value and you can set it up by whatever
well value percentage you want and you
are selecting the largest one and the
smallest number so all these data will
get analyzed and it will open up in a
new sheet and just click OK and you will
see this so these are the if you see
this is our data paid organic social and
revenue so this is uh
okay
let's make it more precise
okay so with a single click yeah all our
data is analyzed okay this is the mean
value and this is the minimum is zero
maximum is so you can set this is the
total and the number of count is
thousand so you don't need to scroll
down and check what is the largest
amount that is paid so this is the
largest amount for the
wait okay and so on so before the
largest revenue generated all these
things are generated with a descriptive
analysis okay descriptive statistics
with a data analysis tool so the next
question is about a pivot table and this
is more refined or more advanced
compared to the last one that we
discussed in the beginner level so here
you are asked to create a pivot table to
find the total cases in each country
belonging to their respective continents
you are giving you are being asked to
put up a table or pivot table with two
variables basically each country and
their respective continent so again we
have the same data and we need to set up
a pivot table which shows the continents
and the countries with the respective
continents the number of cases okay so
let's see how we get this in the example
so here we are we have the same data it
shows the days months your cases
countries
and there
are consonants okay
continents here and so on okay so I'm
I'll go to the insert Tab and select the
pivot table okay again the same thing I
will be asked to enter a input range
okay so I select this
and since it's huge I'll just
put the number to be seven seven seven
okay let's assume
now this is our input data and where you
want the output to be it's already
selected you can put it anywhere I am
putting it here okay just click OK and
it will give you the option to select
the fields now what we want is number of
cases okay which will show you the value
and the countries and territories their
respective continents so okay so this is
how it looks like and we have to check
now it is asking us to find the
countries Okay so
with their respective continents you see
this you see Africa as a continent and
you will see
okay
you will see Africa
if you just remove this you will see the
number of on I mean the cases with the
respective continents and if you want to
include these countries territories
where their respective continents you
will see as such if you just expand this
we will see the countries that are
having the cases in the continent Africa
okay so country wise sorted with the
continents okay this is the other
Advanced step to get the data or show
the data in the pivot table okay another
question that you might be asked this is
a basic and we have already seen this in
the previous example that I have shown
how do you provide the dynamic range in
data source of a pivot table you have to
select a particular data source in your
input table for to show up in the pivot
table so you have to select the input
range but how do you create or how do
you create a provide a dynamic range in
this data switch so just need to create
a name table to provide a dynamic range
so where is the data of your table so as
we have seen in the previous example you
will be able to select the input range
and you just need to put this value any
number so that you know it will pick up
the dynamic range for your input source
for the table okay so now we move on to
the next one and this is about about the
pivot table again is it possible to
create pivot table using multiple
sources of data yes
yes you can create a pivot table from
multiple worksheets sometimes you will
have different data in different sheets
can you create a pivot table for all the
worksheet in a single pivot table yes
you can but there is a condition there
should be a common Row in both the table
so you cannot have different types of
data there should be a common row okay
so then only it will act as a primary
key for the first table and the foreign
key for the second table okay so this is
something that you have to remember and
you need to create a relationship
between the tables and then build the
pivot table so you have to analyze what
kind of data it is it should have a
common Row in both the tables on both
the sheets and then you have to
establish a relationship between this
table and then build the table okay
there is a visit for that well
see that later now let's move on to the
next question so the next question is
again you know with the pivot table uh
wherein you I will be asked to further
refine or you know refine your search
and show it in the data so here we have
with the code data example again you
will be asked to create a pivot table to
find the top three countries from each
continent based on the total cases using
the coveted again and we have done this
before we have created a preview table
for this and we need to further refine
it showing the top three countries with
the number of cases and I will show that
same thing in the Excel and we already
have created a table and we'll refine it
further to show the top three countries
which are having the
highest number of accounts in the
respective context so here we are we
have the table uh already with us and I
just click on the
show field list it will show me the
countries and territories what we are
asked is you know to show the countries
with the top three that is number of
cases
so you just need to go here and you need
to select the value filter there is a
filter which you can select with the
value and how I select top 10 and what I
need is top three it's very simple and
you just need to know these themes okay
and based on the sum of cases okay this
is our field already then just click OK
and it will show you the top three
countries so it's quite simple and it is
very important to know this feel and how
you play with the value of the filters
for each particular uh field in the
pivot table so it shows you these things
all right and now you can refine it
further with the continents and all okay
so different continents and you can see
this so you go there and there is a
value filter you can set up all right we
have set up a value filter okay
okay now there is another one
how do you create a column in a pivot
table okay like you will be given a
situation where you need to add one more
column and show it in the pivot table
with a particular calculation or with a
particular value and you have you don't
have that actual value in your data but
you have to calculate it and show it
across in the table so there is another
option which is called pivot table
analyze and you need to create a
calculated field from pivot table
analyze option so when you go to your
table and then go to pivot table analyze
you will see the option to add a
calculated field okay just go there and
click select calculated field and you
need to Define so in this example we are
going to Define another column where we
calculate the bonus of the sales and
there is a particular Formula E formula
is you put an if and statement and then
you calculate the formula you specify
what is the bonus and what is the way
that you're calculating the bonus and it
will particularly add it another column
to your table so let's see how we do
that in the
table act so here we are we have this
table and I have inserted a pivot table
and I am putting it in
output here
okay
and then you will get the table okay now
you need to select the
customer name
and the unit solar unit price sales okay
so we'll add another column to it how we
do that is this
go to pivot table tools and then you go
to analyze okay
click on field items and set okay you
need to select calculated field here
select that and we are defining a new
field here which is the bonus thank you
bonus and as I said we will put up a
formula for this and we will Define it
how we calculate the bonus okay and then
get and statement which we have seen
before how we uh put up a
an event statement okay now I'm going to
say it has
like the sales my sales should be
I'll specify a condition how they will
calculate the bonus if sales is greater
than 4000
and the unit sold okay I am trying to
put it as the unit switch also depends
on the units sold
is greater than 1000 okay for example
let's say a thousand a person who is uh
able to do a sales of thousand four
thousand and the unit sold should be
more than thousand then the sales
what is this the bonus will be
sales
into that is the amount of sales he has
done
into five percent okay let's say five
percent bonus and sales
is
if it is two percent okay
okay
we are adding this field bonus click add
okay so we have added this and we have
put up a calculation for the formula and
you will see this look so this is simple
way of adding the column to your
existing data and we are doing the
calculations and showing it up okay so
this is one way go to pivot table
analyze and field items and sets you can
select this option and add it okay you
can customize this as I said with adding
different fields this is pretty handy in
analyzing the data which does not exist
in the table and you add some value to
your pivot table okay
the next question will be about slicer
you must be familiar with what a slicer
is in a pivot table and how do you use
it for the purpose of using it and how
do you put up a slider in the pivot
table so how does a slicer work
basically slicers are used to further
filter data in the pivot table suppose
you already have some data and it's for
ease that you can do it by just adding a
slicer you can select particular uh
data in our field and you can see the
output for that particular field that
you have chosen in the slicer okay so
it's very simple go to the insert Tab
and select slicer under printers okay
and then it will be like this okay and
here if for example you see this is our
period table we have added two slicers
to filter our table that is month and
countries and territory so this will be
the general pivot table that looks like
and we have an added another two slices
that is month and Country so if you go
for example if you want to see what is
the number of cases and some of the
deaths for a particular month and for a
particular country you can just do it by
a single click and it will show that
particular data only in the table let's
see and do this in our Excel okay
so there is a table uh pivot table
already created for this and I want to
add a slicer so how do I go ahead and do
this is I go to the
options and insert slicer okay at the
moment you click on it you will see what
are the options that you want to add you
can select different fields and
select the slicer put it uh for this
example we are choosing month
okay this is one of our sliders you can
just put it here
adjacent to the and again
this will be our slider okay
let's add another slicer here
okay
and this will be the countries and
territories okay
click on that and you will see two
simple badges here that you can choose
from so if I want to know in the month
of Feb how many number of cases were
there for particular let's see the
moment I choose the month it will show
that particular number of the
corresponding table for the whole and
now I want to further refine it to a
particular country so for example
Australia okay so there were total
number of 18 cases and zero deaths at
the same time if I go for Algeria it is
like this so
as you see
it goes like this okay so this is one of
the very important tool that you can use
to show the data in a much simplified
Manner and ease
okay so the next question is about the
pivot table again what is the percentage
of contribution of each country in
continuance to the turkey cases again
the same example for our code the kovid
one in this time we want to show the
output as the percentage of contribution
for each country and continents to the
total cases so we have the same data and
we generate a pivot table and we should
show it as the sum of the cases to be
percentage okay and this is how we do it
this is our
data and I'm going to create a pivot
table for this
okay
so it shows the table and here I have to
show what is the fields that we need to
select okay first is we are just
selecting the cases and the countries
and territories Okay so
cases To Be True Values okay
okay so this is how it looks like
now when I see
it shows the number of cases now if I
just want to refine it further and see
it as number of
percentage percentage as the number of
cases okay so how I do it show field
list I go here and I go to Value field
settings okay then
again
number format show the value as okay
sorry
show the value as you need to select
this thing the percentage of grand total
and then just click okay
and you will see
this to be the percentage so it shows
the data in the form of percentage okay
this is very simple and you just need to
remember as we have seen before
super field and then value field
settings okay this is the thing that you
need to check okay Grant percentage
there are other options also and you can
select from whatever you want to cut in
this case we are showing it to be the
percentage okay okay guys now the next
question is about a very important
aspect a presentation when we come to
private charts how do you create a pivot
chart in pivot tables this is very
basic or very you know important aspect
of pivot tables that you can represent
data in a in the form of a chart and
there are different types of charts
which I'll show it to you in the uh
example okay so we have a data here and
we want to show it at in right now it is
in a table at home okay we have put up a
pivot table for this and now if the same
thing can be put up in a pivot chart
okay so what you need to do is go to the
insert Tab and select the pivot chart it
depends on different versions of excel
that you have different uh forms or
different buttons so I will show it
across to you and this is how it looks
like okay it's very simple it can be a
pie chart it can be a bar chart it can
be different forms and we can see that
in the example here okay so let's go to
the example and
so we have the pivot tables generated
here already what you need to do is you
need to select the table and go to
insert and
see the options there are there is a
column chart there is a line chart there
is Pi Bar area scattered and other parts
okay there are different forms okay so
right now what we do is we will select
the column chart here okay you need to
select the pivot table and click on the
column chart again there are different
forms which can be seen in some time now
so this is the basic form okay and it
will show you the countries I mean the
and it will show it as a form of a chart
okay again you can change the chart type
you can change it to Pi okay this
personally is very good in presenting or
doing presentation and you can select
different forms different styles okay it
will also show you the percentage
so this is one form of presenting your
table into a chart okay again bar type
is also there
so this won't suit here in our example
there are different ones I'm just
showing it to you
as how it looks like so depending on
your uh I mean the aesthetic you can see
and select what kind of chart is best
suitable okay
so this is how you put up a pivot chart
in pivot tables okay
so this has been last for the
intermediate level and what are macros
in Excel create a macro to automate a
task basically you have some daily tasks
that you perform in Excel okay and you
can do this with quite ease using the
macros okay it basically is a program
that resides within the Excel file and
it is used to automate tasks in Excel
some daily tasks that you run like run
when you come across in any data and you
have to scrub that data and you do some
daily routines and by removing some
columns or adding some formulas and you
know doing some adding some colors and
changing the fonts or be it anything
that you perform and you have to do a
repetitive task so all that can be done
by recording a approach and this is what
macro is used for in Excel so how you
capture those steps in Excel is through
a macro to record a macro you can either
go to the developer tab in the Excel and
click on record macro or you can use or
access it from The View tab Okay so
these are the
ways to access macros okay just go to
the developer tab and click record macro
wherein you know when you click record
macro it will record the steps that you
are performing in each step and it will
capture that and you can save that it is
like a daily routine that you run and
you can do all these multiple steps
maybe n number of steps within a single
click by running that macro later on
okay so you record a macro and run that
okay you do it through the developer tab
go to developer tab and click record
macro and it records all the steps that
you are performing okay you need to name
it and you just need to perform the
actions and it will record the macro and
you just save it later on whenever you
come across the same daily task that you
run you can just click it by running
that macro okay wow so in a single click
it will perform all the actions that you
have done or steps that you have
performed on that particular Excel sheet
or any other Excel sheet okay this is
very handy when you have similar data
and you do the similar task each day
okay so this ends the intermediate level
and in the next slides we will see the
advanced level so now we discuss the
advanced level uh interview questions
for Excel and when it comes to the
advanced level you will come across
definitely you will be asked about what
if analysis how does it work how does it
how does what-if analysis work in Excel
so what if analysis as the name suggests
you have to have
an analysis done okay with the help of
different complex mathematical
calculations like formulas and using
different formulas and calculations you
can experiment with the data and you can
analyze if this particular input changes
what will be the scenario how will your
output turn out to be so as you can see
it is about different variables to see
how your changes would affect the
outcome of a situation so this is what
what if analysis is and the same thing
can be done with Excel and how it is
done is you need to go to the data Tab
and click on the what-if analysis under
forecast okay so there are three options
in
one is the scenario manager goal seek
and the data table so these are the
three situation or three tools which are
available in the Water Analysis in the
data tab okay so goal seek is basically
for reverse calculations okay and you
have some idea you have some set goal in
mind and you have certain variables and
what you need to do and what you need to
achieve to have certain set goals okay
you have you will set a value for the
goal and with the goal seek option you
can get to know what value you have to
achieve to come to that level okay so
this is what goal seek is it is one of
the simplest sensitivity analysis tool
and so for example you know that you
know a single outcome you would like to
achieve like you you have a set goal
that you have to achieve this particular
grade
okay and the goal seek feature in Excel
allows you to arrive to that goal by
mathematically adjusting a single
variable within that equation so you set
the goal and you will do the what-if
analysis goal seek
option to know what you have to do or
what you have to achieve for the set
goal
the next option is the data table and it
is basically used for sensitivity
analysis okay so in this scenario
you the data tables allow the adjustment
of only one or two variables within a
data set but each variable can have
unlimited number of possible values okay
so basically they are used for side by
side comparisons and it makes it very
easy to read the scenarios okay one but
you need to set up the data table
correctly okay and what you do is you
give the input in the table and then you
set up the formula and for instance you
need to calculate the monthly payments
for a loan okay you provide the
principal amount like whatever amount
you are taking 2 lakhs three lakhs and
you set the interest rate in a formula
okay and you set the term in and then
you need to provide different uh input
options like what loan amount that
you're taking and you say set the
formula and go to data table and I mean
go to what if analysis and select the
data table table stretches across and
then you will see the monthly payment
options or the monthly Emi that you can
calculate there are different uh things
that you can calculate you can calculate
the Target or the sales bonus or things
like that okay giving different
scenarios in the variables okay but you
need to set up a data table it might be
a little challenging but yes it is a
very powerful tool okay so the next one
is the scenario manager it is a bit more
complicated come compared to the other
two but then it is more advanced than
goal c as it allows you the uh to adjust
the multiple variables at the same time
okay and this is very complicated
compared to the other two and it is even
I mean it gives more better output when
it compares to the other two what-if
analysis tools
so here when you go to what if analysis
and the scenario manager you have to
select the data and provide different
scenarios that is different values for
each scenario and then it will create a
it will analyze calculate and create
different scenarios okay so it becomes
very easy for you to analyze what if you
are changing the value of your interest
amount or the
term of loan or your targets like
monthly targets or an yearly targets and
things like that and you just have to uh
see what the scenario will be when you
set this particular value
for a
table or for data whatever targets that
you need to set you can use this what-if
analysis in Excel for the different
scenarios and different calculations
okay these are very powerful tools and
you need to know this
now as we move on to the next one you
might be asked what is the difference
between a function and a subroutine in a
VBA okay
even though these two are used quite
frequently there is a
pretty much different from each other
okay so a function always returns a
value of the task it is performing okay
so when you are writing a module you
will have a function when you have a
function it will always give you a value
okay for example you are performing an
addition it using the function it will
give you a value for sure whereas
subroutine it does not return a value of
the task it is performing functions are
called by a variable okay you can set up
a variable and you can call the function
okay whereas subroutines can be recalled
from anywhere in the program in multiple
times okay in many different ways you
can recall a subroutine like we have
seen we write a subroutine and we put up
a button and we can when you click the
button it will recall the subroutine
functions are called by variable okay
you have to set up a variable and when
you enter it will come up okay functions
are used directly in spreadsheet as
formulas whereas Subs cannot be used
directly in spreadsheets as formula okay
this is very important difference and
the next thing is the functions can be
used to perform repetitive tasks and
return a value whereas users must insert
a value in the desired cell before
getting the result of the sub so this is
particularly limited okay whereas
functions can be used to perform
different repetitive tasks and return a
value user input is not required whereas
if you see the subroutines user must
insert a value okay in the desired cell
that to in a particular cell which is
defined in the subroutine to getting the
desired result okay so these are the
differences between functions and
subroutines now the next one is what is
the difference between this workbook and
active workbook in PDF so when you work
on modules and different Excel
spreadsheets and workbooks you will have
these different workbooks open and there
is a particular difference and you might
be asked what is the difference between
this workbook and active workbook so as
the name suggests this workbook refers
to the name of the workbook where the
code is actually running from okay you
are running a code VBA code and it is
the actual workbook where you are
running the code from and that is this
workbook okay and you have multiple
spreadsheets open and you are working on
particular suppose for example you are
working on a sheet X okay and you active
workbook is the workbook that is
currently active from the different open
verbs you have different open workbooks
but you are working on one particular
workbook and that is called the active
workbook so this workbook is the
reference to the name of the workbook
where the code is actually written
whereas active workbook is the one one
that is currently open currently active
Okay so this is the difference between
this workbook and the active workbook in
VBA as shown in the example this is a
simple sub that is written a code that
can be written to find out which
workbook is the uh it which workbook is
the uh this workbook in the VBA and the
active workbook as well okay so this is
a simple thing that you can run to
determine a it shows the active workbook
and the this workbook okay so as we move
on to the next one
so this is the question how will you
pass arguments to a ppf function okay
there are two ways if any arguments can
be passed to a VBA function as a value
or as a reference so this is an example
that you can see it is by reference the
key word for this is by reference okay
so when you are passing an argument by
reference the keyword should be by r e f
whereas by value you're specifying a
value and the keyword is by v a l value
okay so these are the two ways that you
can pass an argument in VBA
so when you pass an argument by
reference in a procedure the variable
itself okay the variable itself is
accessed by a procedure and it is to the
location or the address in the memory
okay the value of the variable is
changed permanently by the procedure in
this case all right okay so to pass an
argument by reference you should use
buyer that is the keyword before the
argument okay so in this example it is
clearly shown what is the keyword that
is being used okay and by reference is
the default in the VBA unless you
specify something else which in this
case is by value okay and as I said the
keyword for buy value passing the
argument y value is by v a l okay so
when you set the keyword by Van the
variable what happens is the by value
argument function or argument
is passed through by value okay the
number function is called here which
means it assigns a value to the variable
X here okay because the variable was
passed by value in the function any
change to the value okay any change to
the value of the variable is only the
current function so it ends after it
performs the function okay then it
revert backs to the value when it is
declared again where it is set to zero
so if the variable has been passed by
reference in the function then the
variable would have permanently assumed
the new assigned value so this is the
basic Difference by reference and by
value
so now we move on to the next one now
there might be a question that you will
be asked that how do you find the last
row or a column in a VBA okay so to find
a last row sometimes you have long list
of uh data and it has like
like number of rows and N number of
columns so instead of scrolling down all
together to find the uh last row you can
use this VBA code you can write this
code it's a very simple one and it will
give you the last row you will find the
last row with the single click okay
let's see it in the VBA so here I have a
sheet which you know it has long list of
uh rows and instead of scrolling down I
can just find out the last row with this
VBA code okay I just click on this and
as seen in the slideshow I have just
returned it and we will see the if you
just run it and you will see the number
of rows it will give you the last row in
the sheet okay similarly we can do this
for the column as well okay in case if
you have long list of our large number
of columns instead of scrolling right
you can just uh run this VBA and you can
see you can know the
the last number of column okay number of
columns so as we've seen in the last row
now we'll see the code for the finding
the last column it's the same thing uh
instead of row you will see it as column
all right and if when you run it you
will give the it will give you the last
column okay
now let's move on to the next one so you
might be asked this how do we check
whether a file exists or not in a
specified location there is a code
simple VBA code that you can write and
you can run you can use this utility to
find out whether the file exists or not
okay and you need to check whether the
file exists and if it does it will give
you a message that the selected file
exist and if it doesn't it will pop up
with the message box saying that the
file selected file doesn't exist so what
you need to do is you have to specify
this function okay and check file exists
this is what it does okay you have to
specify a variable that is the store
file name where you will give the
location the location of the file and
the name of the file okay and then you
will also specify whether the file name
is there or not now so it runs this and
it will see either the file name exist
or the file actually exist or not
and it will give the appropriate message
box we can run the same thing in my PC
and we can check it
so here we are I have put this and I
have done the same thing and what I'm
looking for is this book two okay let me
maximize it this is what I'm looking for
and the location is desktop okay so let
me run this and you will see whether it
exists or not okay and it says this to a
selected file exists so it goes and
checks whether the file exists and then
it will give you the message so this is
how we check using the video so the next
one is uh you know there is a powerful
tool called debug and you need to you
might be asked questions about how debug
works or how you check the debug okay to
debug a video code line by line you can
use the f8 key okay you can also create
a breakpoint to terminate the execution
so for this if you go to your VBA you
will see the option as debug okay you
can use this
by clicking on debug or by pressing the
f8 key okay so what debug does is it
will show you the step-by-step execution
of your steps okay it will check each
and everything and if there is an error
it will pop okay and the what is
breakpoint is at some point of time you
can check one particular step okay you
can stop the if suppose if there is a
thousand line codes and you want to
check on one particular step like maybe
800 step so just go to go to that
particular step and you can enter a
breakpoint and it will show you what is
actually happening at the that point
that particular step and you can see
this in the locals window or the watch
window okay so let me show you some
simple example of how this debug can be
used to check our course okay so here I
have written a simple code for this and
it is basically uh let me show you how
debug works okay this is the okay let me
maximize it and we'll see okay so this
is the debug option that you can run and
you will see what happens okay this can
be done by clicking f8 all right so step
into is the option and you can check
f8 and you can press f8 again it will go
to the next step all right and it will
show you what's happening actually uh
you can see this in the uh locals window
what's actually happening let me see uh
let me maximize it a bit
so that you can actually see okay so
when I press f8 okay
step into
you will see what happens in The Next
Step okay this is what is happening a is
empty B is 0 I is zero okay I step into
it the next step again so it goes here
you can see what changes happen I press
f8 again
so this is what is happening all right
so it is checking each and every step so
debug is the tool that you can use to
check the course whether see this is a
very simple program but then you will
have some different codes where you
functions are routines that you can have
where you have thousand line codes and
you need to check each and every step or
some particular step so this comes in
very handy okay let me press f8 and it
shows what happens in which uh you can
step into each and every step and see
what happens okay and now if I show
there is something called as toggle
breakpoint okay this one particular is
used by
pressing the F9 key wherein you will see
what is actually happening at some
particular step okay so how you do that
is you just need to go to a particular
step and click on the bar here and it
will get highlighted into red so so this
is what is happening okay so in the
watch window you will see that
particular step will be uh magnified or
you can see what is actually happening
in the step okay so let me start it
again
see what happens
I press f8 again
so here it sees it actually shows you
can toggle and you can see what is
happening in the watch window at that
particular step so module one ABC the
variant is empty so expression is B this
is what is happening at this particular
step okay so this is how debug can be
used
so now as we move on to the next one
well you might be asked to create a bar
chart with the given data using VBA so
you will have some data and you can
create a bar chart or a any kind of
chart with the VBA we have done it with
the pivot tables and all but then we can
do the same with the VBA so it's a
simple thing a simple sub that you can
drag and create embedded chart using
chart object this is the sub that you
can